HAVE THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE OR GOING TO GO RIGHT
AND OR OUR OUR MEETING HERE
TODAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD AND
WHEREBY YOU.
OFF YOUR CELL PHONES -- DON'T
HAVE CONVERSATIONS IN THE ROOM
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE CONVERSATION
THAT'S FINE BUT LEAVE.
DON'T DO IT HERE IN THE ROOM.
SO WE CAN HEAR EVERYBODY AND HER
TESTIMONY.
AND LISTEN TO THE MEMBERS WHEN
THEY CAST VOTES WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE -- RULES ON TESTIMONY WE'RE
GOING HERE TEN BILLS TODAY --
WHAT? THIRTEEN OF THIRTEEN BILLS
WE GOT THIRTEEN BILLS TO HEAR
TODAY [inaudible]
AND YEAH.
AND WE HAD TEN ITEMS ON CONSENT --
WE WILL TAKE TESTIMONY.
TESTIMONY THE RULES ON TESTIMONY
TODAY WILL BE TO WITNESSES PER
SIDE -- ON EACH ISSUE AND TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR OTHER PEOPLE CAN GET
UPAND SAY WHETHER THEY'RE FULL
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL.
BUT NO FURTHER TESTIMONY BEYOND
THAT -- THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY.
OF FOR EVERYBODY.
WILL BE ITEMS -- SB TWO SIXTEEN
OF A CENTER GALGIANI IS BILL --
SIR WHAT COUNTS HIS BILL SB.
TWO SIXTY SEVEN SB.
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN SB.
THREE FIFTY EIGHT SB.
FIVE ZERO NINE AND SB.
FIVE FORTY THREE CENTER PAN.
SB OF FIVE NINETY THREE CENTER
ON BURKE.
THE SENATE CARDS SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE AND THIRTY TWO THOSE --
ITEMS TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY THREE THOSE ARE ALL ON
CONSENT FOR TODAY.
WE WILL TAKE A MOTION ON THAT
WILL GET A QUORUM AND WE WILL --
GET A CORPSMAN SAYS WE HAVE THE
RECORD NUMBER MEMBERS RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL OPERATE AS A COMMITTEE
OF THE WHOLE.
AND BEGIN TO HEAR BILLS.
AND OUR FIRST SAUCER IS RIGHT
HERE -- CENTER GLACIER.
AND SIR GLACIERS PRESENTING I
BELIEVE CENTER ON ON SB.
THREE NINETY SEVEN AND CENTER --
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR AND SB THREE
NINETY SEVEN PUBLIC TRANSIT
OFFERS PASSENGERS WITH PAT.
ON EVACUATION ORDERS CENTER YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR ON THIS BILL.
THANK THANK YOU -- CHAIR VAL AND
AND MEMBERS.
THE OPTION THAT THIS BILL DO YOU
IT THAT REQUIRES TWO THINGS IT
WOULD REQUIRE A PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATOR. TO ALLOW PASSENGERS TO
BOARD A TRANSIT VEHICLE WITH
THEIR PETS.
WHEN AN EVACUATION ORDER IS
ISSUED?
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE IN EACH
TRANSIT OPERATOR TO DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES FOR ALLOWING PETS ON
PUBLIC TRANSIT -- THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO THESE TYPES OF
EVACUATION ORDERS.
HI ACT AS EXPERTS ESTIMATE THAT
OVER TEN THOUSAND PETS WERE
DISPLACED BY THE WALLS THE HILL
AND CAMPFIRES ALONE TEN THOUSAND
PETS.
THE AMERICAN JOURNAL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLISHED A STUDY IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SHOWING THAT
PEOPLE ARE RELUCTANT TO EVACUATE.
DURING A DISASTER WITHOUT THEIR
PETS AND ANIMALS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO NEARLY --
NINETEEN MILLION DOMESTIC PETS --
THE PREPARATION FOR THEIR
EVACUATION TIMES EMERGENCY IS
CRUCIAL TO THE SAFETY OF THE
OWNERS AND THE PETS THEMSELVES.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF HURRICANE
KATRINA.
CALAVERAS CONGRESS CONGRESS
PASSED THE PETS ACT.
IT MANDATED THAT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS PLANS ACCOUNT FOR
COMPANION ANIMALS.
HOWEVER ADOPTION OF THE SLOTS
BEEN SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE
NATION.
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA OUT OF A RESPONSE
EMERGENCY SYSTEM DEVELOPED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX BY CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
ALONG WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD NAG -- NOTED THAT RESOURCES
FOR PLANNING TRAINING EVACUATING
ANIMALS DURING EMERGENCIES WERE
LACKING THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOWEVER THERE'S BEEN NO
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES.
ALLOWING PETS ON A PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION DURING EMERGENCY
EVACUATIONS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN ENSURING THAT BOTH PETS AND
THEIR OWNERS.
ABLE TO GET SAFELY -- TO AWAY
FROM THESE DISASTERS.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN HERE THROUGH
THE CROWDS OF FIVE SECURITY TO
GET INTO THE BUILDING THIS.
AYE FEARLESS ADVOCATE FOR THE
BILL JENNIFER FEARING AND WE
WELCOME HER TESTIMONY AS THE
CHAIR REQUESTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAU YOUR
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER FEARING I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY IN SUPPORT OF SB --
THREE NINE SEVEN AS THE
CONTRACTED ANIMAL CONTROL AGENCY
FOR TWELVE MUNICIPALITIES IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY IS
CHARGED WITH PROVIDING EMERGENCY
RESPONSE DURING TIMES OF
DISASTER.
AND DURING A MAJOR EVENTS
PRIMARILY FAST MOVING FIRES ARE
YOU MAY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
DO JOIN WITH OTHER FIRST
RESPONDERS TO ASSESS WITH
ACCUSATIONS.
REMOVING BARRIERS TO SELF
EVACUATION SUCH AS ALLOWING
RESIDENTS ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION WITH THEIR PETS
WOULD FREE RESOURCES FOR MORE
COMPLICATED EVACUATIONS LIKE
LARGE ANIMAL RESCUE OR
EVACUATION OF RURAL AREAS THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORT.
SO AS THESE LARGE FIRE AND OTHER
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED EVENTS
BECOME MORE THE NORM INSTEAD OF
THE EXCEPTION WE DO APPRECIATE
ALL EFFORTS AT THE STATE MAKES
IT MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE AND
THEIR PETS TO GET TO SAFETY SO.
WE WITH THAT WE WOULD URGE YOUR
YES VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR PLEASE.
YEAH.
THE TRANSIT JUST WORKED IN THE
NAPA VALLEY TURN.
ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL WE THINK
IT MAKES A GOOD POLICY PEOPLE
USUALLY JUST WANNA LEAVE THAT
LEAVE THE PAST BEHIND.
OKAY.
OTHERS SPEAKERS PLEASE.
MR TURN MEMBERS MADISON DOLLY ON
BEHALF OF MARS PET CARE AND MARS
INCORPORATED IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
FUTURE MEMBERS MICHAEL HIM TELL
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION WILL HAVE AND SOME
SUPPORT POSITION ON THE BILL
JUST YET BUT WE ARE LOOKING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE IT
TAKES A VERY MINOR AMENDMENTS
HOPEFULLY -- THAT CAN BETTER
INSURE THAT BILLS
OPERATIONALIZED AS INTENDED --
BUT OTHER THAN THAT -- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING.
FOR OKAY THANK YOU -- WE HAVE
SPEAKERS -- OPPOSING THE BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD ANYBODY'S
OPPOSING.
THIS BILL THIS IS THE US BE --
THREE NINETY SEVEN SIR GLAZERS
WILL ANYBODY OPPOSING -- I SEEN
ON ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SENATOR DODD YEAH I I TOTALLY
SUPPORT THE BILL I'M IS.
THE VOTE ON YES ON THIS BUT I
GUESS I WONDERED YOU KNOW IT ARE
THERE ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THE KEEP CALM LIKE --
YOU KNOW OTHER PASSENGERS ON
THERE LIKE BEING.
NO ATTACK BY A PIT BULL OR
SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE I MEAN
LOOK AT AYE AYE.
I JUST THINK WE OUGHT TO THINK
THESE THINGS THROUGH -- THEN THE
MOST WE CAN BEFORE WE JUST PASS
A BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE THE
RIGHT THING TO DO I I JUST.
WORRY ABOUT THAT PARTICULARLY
DURING A STRESSFUL TIME IN --
PEOPLE ARE FREAKING OUT AND THAT
MAKES ANIMALS AND EASY YEAH WHAT
DO WE DO ABOUT THAT.
AFTER GLAZER HAVE A QUARTER A
QUESTION CAN YOU ANSWER.
THANK YOU AT YOUR BILL AND AND
SENATOR DODD.
IT IS A GOOD QUESTION AND IT
CERTAINLY IS A POTENTIAL --
THING THAT COULD HAPPEN OUT
THERE THAT'S WHY PART OF THE
BILL IS TO ASK EACH TRANSIT
OPERATOR TO DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES.
OFFER ALLOWING PETS -- SO IT
DOES INCORPORATE THOSE KINDS OF
SIR CIRCUMSTANCES THAT MAY OCCUR
AND TO HAVE THEM THINK THAT
THOSE ISSUES THROUGH.
SO THAT THEY CAN BE DONE
APPROPRIATELY IT'S NOT MEANT
THAT A A PET SHOULD DISPLACING A
PERSON.
AND CERTAINLY -- AN ANIMAL THAT
IS NOT IN THE RIGHT CONDITION TO
BE TRANSPORTED IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
SO IT'S MY HOPE THAT THAT
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IS GOING TO
DEAL WITH EXACTLY THAT QUESTION
WHICH IS A VERY IMPORTANT.
ONE OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I SEE NONE.
CENTER -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WHICH ARE LOS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
BILL.
WE CARE ABOUT OUR PEOPLE HERE IN
THE STATE WE ALSO CARE ABOUT OUR
FOUR LEGGED FRIENDS.
AND THIS IS TRYING TO FIND A WAY
TO HELP BOTH BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WON'T LEAVE.
IF THEY'RE LEAVING BEHIND THEIR
THEIR FAVORITE PACKED WITH THEM
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIND THAT
BALANCE THIS BILL THANK YOU --
WE GOT COCO CHANEL.
WELL THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
COCOS BEEN A VERY GOOD COM DOG
[inaudible]
THAT'S COCOA.
ALL RIGHT CENTER GALGIANI SO
[inaudible]
LOVE [inaudible]
ALL.
DONE.
WHAT WE'LL DO IS TURN OVER
CENTER DOT DOT WILL PRESENT
CENTER DOT WILL PRESENT HIS BILL --
EVERYBODY THIS IS ITEM SEVEN
ARGENTO'S SAYS BE. THREE THREE
SIX TRANSPORTATION FULLY
AUTOMATED TRANSIT VEHICLES THIS
IS SENATOR DODD'S BILL EVERYBODY --
SB.
THREE THREE SIX AND SIR YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR FOR THE PRISON THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SB THREE THREE SIX REQUIRES THE
PRESENCE OF AT LEAST ONE PUBLIC
TRANSIT EMPLOYEE ON ANY FULLY
AUTOMATED TRANSIT VEHICLE.
FULLY AUTOMATED VEHICLES CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE TRANSIT
BUT THEY POSE RISK AS WELL
ESPECIALLY PUBLIC SAFETY OF
TRANSIT RIDERS AND ACCESSIBILITY
FOR DISABLED CUSTOMERS.
TRIP TO THE BOYS OFTEN SERVICE
SOCIAL WORKERS ON THERE PUBLIC
TRANSIT VEHICLES DISABLED AND
ELDERLY PASSENGERS RIDING THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION OR PARA
TRANSIT.
RELY ON TRANSIT EMPLOYEES TO
HELP THEM ONBOARD AND OFF BOARD
SECURE WHAT WHEELCHAIRS AND
OTHER SERVICES.
SCHOOL CHILDREN COMMUTE TO
SCHOOL USING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION WITHOUT AN
EMPLOYEE ON BOARD THESE CHILDREN
WILL NOT RIDE.
TO WITH ADULT SUPERVISION.
WITH ADULTS OR SUPERVISION.
PASSENGERS ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO RANDOM OR PLANNED ACTS OF
VIOLENCE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ASSAULT AS WELL AS A HOST OF
OTHER SAFETY CONCERNS WHEN LEFT
ALONE ON THE VEHICLE.
ADDITIONALLY OVER A MILLION
DRIVERS TRANSPORT PASSENGERS FOR
A LIVING PUBLIC TRANSIT JOBS ARE
STABLE JOBS AT GOOD WAGES AND
BENEFITS THIS IS STAY IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
FULLY AUTOMATIC AUTOMATED PUBLIC
TRANSIT WOULD DISPLACE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS WITHOUT.
RETRAINING OF JOB CREATORS A
RETRAINING OF JOB CREATION PLAN
NOT ONLY DOES THIS IMPACT
WORKERS BUT THEIR FAMILIES BUT
ALSO IN THEIR FAMILIES BUT ALSO
IMPACT STATE'S BUDGET.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE PRESENCE
OF THE LEAST ONE PUBLIC TRANSIT
EMPLOYEE ON ANY FULLY AUTOMATED
VEHICLE THERE FOR CALIFORNIA CAN
GREATLY REDUCE THE RISK OF
PASSENGERS MIGHT FACE WHEN
REWRITING IT FULLY AUTONOMOUS.
TRANSIT BECAUSE I PROTECT PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION JOBS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IN HERE TO TESTIFY IN THIS BILL --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR -- FOR
FEDERATION ALSO MATT BROUGHT UP
REPRESENTING THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION.
OKAY WITNESSES IN FAVOR THE BILL
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AN
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL -- ALONG
WITH -- THE MACHINISTS AYE OF P.
T. E. LOCALS TWENTY AND TWENTY
ONE THE INLAND BOATMEN ME TO
UNION UNITE HERE AND OTHERS --
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- THE USER CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL THE TEAMSTERS IN ABOUT
A MINUTE TRANSIT UNIT REPRESENT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF TRANSIT
WORKERS IN THE STATE.
AND AND AND FOR THESE WORKERS
THIS BILL IS.
AT ITS VERY CORE ABOUT THE
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE THEIR
TRANSIT MEMBERS PROVIDE ON A
DAILY BASIS -- THEIR JOBS ARE
JUST.
TURNING THE STEERING WHEEL AND
STEPPING ON THE GAS -- DAY
PROVIDE.
A MYRIAD OF SERVICES INCLUDING
BEING A LOCAL SOCIAL WORKER.
BREAKING UP FIGHTS -- PUBLIC
SAFETY FIRST RESPONDER -- THEY
PROTECT OUR KIDS -- THEY HAD
ASSIST THE ELDERLY AND THE
DISABLED AND WITH.
THE ONSET OF A OF AUTOMATED
VEHICLES THOSE NEEDS THOSE NEEDS
FOR THE SERVICES DON'T GO AWAY.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT IT
KNOWLEDGE IS TO BE FOR THE
SERVICES AND PROVIDE A CREATIVE
WAY THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THEM WITHOUT HANDCUFFING
THE TRANSIT AGENCIES -- SOME
FOLKS WANT US TO PROVIDE A
LICENSE COMMERCIALLY DRIVER A
COMMERCIALLY LICENSED DRIVER IN
THE VEHICLE.
THE TEAMSTERS AND AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION REPRESENT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF COMMERCIALLY
LICENSED DRIVERS WE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
COMMERCIALLY LICENSED DRIVERS IN
ALL OF THE BUSES BUT THAT'S NOT
REALISTIC WE NEED TO HAVE
REALISTIC POLICIES.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN EMPLOYEE
THAT CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICES
WITHOUT.
WITH PROVIDING THE MAXIMUM LEVEL
FLEXIBILITY SO WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL [inaudible]
THIS PLEASE.
IS TO TURN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE.
COME FROM MY PERSPECTIVE OF WE
AS THE STATE HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH THE FUTURE OF WORK AND
ENSURING THAT THERE WILL STILL
BE JOBS -- AS WE SEE INCREASED
AUTOMATION AND TECHNOLOGY USED
ON TO CHANGE WORK AND ALSO IN
SOME CASES TO DISPLACE WORKERS.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL IS MEANT
TO DO IS -- TO UNDERSTAND THAT
SURE THERE ARE GOING TO BE
CHANGES TO THE TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE USED --
AND THAT CAN BE THAT CAN BE GOOD
OR BAD DEPENDING IN THE WAY THAT
THOSE TECHNOLOGIES ARE DEPLOYED --
BUT THAT WE CAN YOU WE AS POLICY
AS YOU AS POLICY MAKERS AND WE
AS UNIONS CAN PLAY A ROLE IN
HELPING TO SHAPE THAT FUTURE.
AND HELPING TO INSURE THAT
WORKING PEOPLE CAN CONTINUE TO
FIND A MEANINGFUL WORK SO THAT'S
THE GOAL WE'RE TRYING TO STRIKE
WITH THIS BILL HERE IN.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU OTHER WITNESSES PLEASE --
STEVE ALL COMING UP THE NAPA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND THE ALAMEDA CHARACTER --
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT ALSO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GERMAN RECESS ARE DIEM HALF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY STATED ASK FOR SUPPORT A
OTHER -- WITNESSES -- OKAY -- WE
HAVE THE OPPOSITION COME FOR
PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU GOV RIGHT HERE.
HAVE A SEAT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
MICHAEL HIM UNTIL THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION WE ARE BETWEEN -- ON
THIS BILL DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL TO
HISTORICALLY -- OUR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT PRE JUDGING --
THE FUTURE OF WORK IN THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A TRANSITION
POINT MEANT -- PARTICULARLY
PARTICULARLY AS THESE VEHICLES
HAVE NOT YET BEEN DEPLOYED
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSIT AGENCIES --
WE ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
THE BUILDING MORE THOROUGHLY I
AND IF THERE'S ANY FEEDBACK THAT
COMES FROM THIS COMMITTEE WILL
BE CONSIDERING THAT AS WELL.
ON WILL BE TAKEN DECISION AT
THAT TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES SIR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE
MIKE ANDERSON WITH THE SHEET
METAL AIR RAIL TRANSPORTATION
FORMALLY UNITED TRANSPORTATION
UNION.
AND WHAT WE CONCUR WITH THE
STAFF'S RECOMMENDATIONS IN
NUMBER SIX ABOUT THE TRIAL
PERIOD.
THAT HAVE SUNSET AND ALSO WE
THINK THAT THE PERSON ON BOARD
SHOULD BE CAPABLE OF OPERATING
THE VEHICLE -- IF IT BECOMES
NECESSARY.
WE THINK THIS MAINTAINS A LEVEL
OF SAFETY. FOR NOT ONLY THE
PASSENGERS THE EMPLOYEE.
AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC THAT
SURROUNDS IT MUST BE SHARE THE
ROAD WITH.
FISH THESE VEHICLES SO WITH WITH
THAT THAT'S ALL THE OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
OKAY I GOT -- OTHER WITNESSES --
OPPOSITION.
OKAY QUESTIONS IN QUESTION SIR
DODD YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO ANY
OF THOSE CONCERNS WERE READ WE
LOOKED AT THAT THE ALMOST
CERTAINLY AND I THINK -- YES
JAMES -- SAID IT'S YOU KNOW
SOMETHING WERE -- YEAH WE GOT BE
REALISTIC AND WE'VE GOT A LOOK
AT THIS -- YOUR THROUGH A MORE
YUP.
YUP BROADLANDS AND I THINK THAT
WHAT WE CAME UP WITH WAS HAVING
SOMEBODY ON BOARD THEY CAN.
ASSIST WITH PASSENGERS DISABLED
PASSENGERS YOUNG KIDS -- AND
ALSO -- YOU AT THE END OF THE
DAY -- AS SOME OF THESE OTHER
ISSUES COME UP -- YEAH WE CAN
DEAL WITH THEM IN THE FUTURE BUT
WE WE JUST FELT THAT THIS WAS
THE PROPER WAY TO GO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D ALSO JUST
ADD TO THAT THAT.
WHAT THE IN THE BILL IT IT
DEFINES FULLY AUTOMATED VEHICLE
AND THESE VEHICLES WILL NOT HAVE
ANY CONTROLS FOR A LICENSED
DRIVER TO OPERATE?
SO.
DEPENDS ON WHAT KIND OF
AUTOMATED VEHICLE THERE ARE
WHAT'S THAT MEAN.
LIKE THERE'S STAGE ONE TWO THREE
FOUR AND FIVE YOU KNOW IT'S UP.
THEY GET TO FIVE IT DOESN'T HAVE
ANY.
STRUCTURE TO IT BUT IF IT'S A
FOR THAT MIGHT HAVE A I AM A
DEVICE OR STEERING OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT OTHERS.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF AUTOMATED
VEHICLES SO.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
ISSUE WE'LL SEE.
IF IT WERE GOING TO HAVE A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD WITH THIS LAW WILL
BE IN EFFECT.
UNDER THE MOTION.
AND IT'LL BE AN INTERESTING
EXPERIENCE TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
YEAH I THINK INSTEAD OF
MANDATING IT RIGHT.
BECAUSE TIME GOES ON IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT -- IS FELT BY THE
TRANSIT OPERATORS IN THAT THE
SYSTEMS THEMSELVES SOME CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE COULD BE BROUGHT INTO.
TO MODIFY BUT FOR NOW THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP YEAH WE HAVE
SEVERAL TEST ON AUTOMATED
VEHICLES GOING ON AROUND THE
STATE AND WE HAD A HEARING IN
THIS COMMITTEE ON THE SUBJECTS
SO I THINK.
WE'RE GETTING TO A POINT WERE IN --
FUTURE.
YEARS WE'RE GOING TO START
SEEING.
SOME RESULTS ON THOSE -- TEST
AND SEE WOOD.
THINGS LIKE THE ACCIDENT RATE
WITH -- HOW?
I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES WAS
FOR ME HOW.
AUTOMATED VEHICLES DEAL WITH THE
DISABLED PEOPLE WITH --
DIFFERENT KINDS OF ABILITIES --
ELDERLY -- CHILDREN YOU KNOW
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS OUT UNDER
THE COCOA YEAH -- HOW DO THEY
DEAL WITH -- DODD AND AND
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S SAFE -- A
LOT OF OUR TRANSIT -- WORKERS.
TO SPECIAL BUSES.
FOR ESPECIALLY THE THE TEAMSTERS
IN MY AREA OR DO A LOT OF BUS
DRIVING FOR THE SPECIAL ED
CHILDREN -- YOU KNOW THE
DISABLED -- THE DEVELOPMENT
DISABLED -- SO WE REALLY DEPEND
ON THOSE DRIVERS.
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR OUR CHILDREN
HILL CALLING YOU KNOW MY FAMILY.
AND I THINK THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT CONCERN THAT WE THEY
DO A GREAT JOB BY THE WAY SO.
REALLY APPRECIATE THEIR
ABSOLUTELY -- CARE FOR PEOPLE ON
HAVING A DRIVER'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
SO SIR GALGIANI HAS A COMMENT
CENTER IN THAT EIGHTEEN OR
NINETEEN OTHER COUNTRIES TO HAVE
HIGH SPEED RAIL EVEN THOUGH
THOSE TRAINS HAVE POSITIVE TRAIN
CONTROL THEY STILL UTILIZE.
OPERATORS AND SO I THINK THAT
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR IN THIS
BILL IS IN LINE WITH WHAT OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO HAVE A TECHNOLOGY.
ARE STILL DOING.
YEAH.
HE SAID OKAY SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WILL HAVE CONSIDERATION.
WILL REACH THANK YOU -- SIR MORE
ART.
SIR MORE LUXURIOUS TWO BILLS SIR
MARK -- YOU HAVE -- ITEM
THIRTEEN IS SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN
AND I AM -- SIXTEEN SB.
FIVE ONE ONE AND SAID THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU COULD PICK WHICH ONE
YOU WANT TO START WITH FOUR FOUR
SEVEN YES SIR OKAY WE'LL START
WITH.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN COLLEAGUES SP
FOUR FOUR SEVEN TRANSFERS TWO
PARCELS OF LAND.
FROM CALTRANS TO THE CITY OF
ORANGE. ONE PARCEL IS A PORTION
OF HEART PARK A VERY POPULAR IN
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT.
OF THE CITY'S PARKS SYSTEM IS
JASON TO THE TWENTY TWO FREEWAY
ALSO KNOWN AS THE GARDEN GROVE
FREEWAY.
THE LAND.
USE WOULD BE RESTRICTED TO PARK
LAND IS IT'S NOW CURRENTLY
LANDMARK INSIDE.
THE PARK FOR RECREATIONAL OPEN
SPACE THE OTHER PARCELS A
PORTION OF HANDY PARK ADJACENT
TO THE FIFTY FIVE FREEWAY ALSO
KNOWN AS THE COSTA MESA FREEWAY.
THAT HE'S CALL INSIDE THESE
PROPERTIES REQUIRED BACK IN THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES -- BY
CALTRANS DURING CONSTRUCTION AND
IMPROVEMENT OF THESE TWO STATE
HIGHWAYS ORANGE COUNTY IS NOW
THE SECOND MOST DENSELY
POPULATED COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA
JUST BEHIND.
SAN FRANCISCO PARK LAND IS
PRICELESS PRESERVING IT IS THE
GOAL OF SB.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN AS CALTRANS DOES
NOT INTEND TO RENEW ITS PORTER
BILL LEASE WITH THE CITY OF
ORANGE.
IT BEHOOVES THE LEGISLATURE TO
RESOLVE THE MANAGEMENT.
OF THESE CRITICAL ASSETS IN A
RESPONSIBLE AND APPROPRIATE
MANNER. FOR THE CITIZENS OF THE
STATE AND ITS SUBSIDIARIES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE A WITNESS MISS BONNIE
HAGEN FROM THE CITY OF ORANGE
THANK YOU OF WELCOME YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR YES.
THE OTHER AFTERNOON I CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS BONNIE HAGEN AND I'M
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES DIRECTOR
FOR THE CITY OF ORANGE.
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN THE CITY OF
ORANGES A HARD WORKING MIDDLE
CLASS CITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS AND
RICK RICH AGRICULTURAL HISTORY.
WITHIN THE CITY ARE TO PARKS
CALLED HEART PARK IN HANDY PARK
BOTH PARKS ARE LOCATED ADJACENT
TO MAJOR FREEWAYS I IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND ARE WIDELY USED BY
OUR RESIDENTS RESIDENTS OF
NEIGHBORING CITIES YOUTH SPORTS
GROUPS HIGH SCHOOLS AND EVEN
LOCAL UNIVERSITIES.
PORTIONS OF THE TWO PARKS ARE
OWNED BY THE CITY WHILE OTHER
PORTIONS ARE OWNED BY CALTRANS.
CALTRANS PURCHASE THOSE
PROPERTIES FROM PRIVATE ENTITIES
IN THE LATE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND
EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES. FOR THE
USE DURING THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE TWENTY TWO AND FIFTY FIVE
FREEWAY.
ONCE CALTRANS DETERMINED THAT
THE PROPERTIES WERE NO LONGER
NECESSARY THEY LEASE THEM TO THE
CITY OF ORANGE THROUGH WHAT IS
KNOWN AS THE PORTER BELLY'S.
THE UNIQUE TYPE OF LEASE GAVE
THE CITY THE LAND UNDER THE
CONDITION THAT IT WOULD BE USED
AS RECREATION AND OPEN SPACE FOR
THE DURATION OF THE LEASE.
THE CITY OF ORANGE ENTERED INTO
TWO SEPARATE FIFTY YEAR LONG
PORTABILITY SAYS WITH CALTRANS
FOR HEART PARK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE AND HANDY PARK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE CITY
WAS ALERTED BY CALTRANS DISTRICT
TWELVE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THAT CALTRANS HAD NO INTENTION
OF RENEWING THE FIFTY YEAR
PORTER BUT LEASES AND INSTEAD.
WOULD GO THROUGH THE
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS TO SELL
THE PROPERTY AS EXCESS PLANT.
DUE TO THE COMPLICATED FACTORS
SURROUNDING THE CURRENT USE OF
THE LAND AND THE NATURE OF THE
PORTER BUT LEASES THE CURRENT
LAW THAT GOVERNS THE DISPOSAL
CALTRANS SURPLUS LAND DOESN'T
FULLY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THESE
FACTORS WHEN DETERMINING A
PURCHASE AND SALE PRICE.
THE CITY OF ORANGE AND ITS
RESIDENTS VALUE.
PARK IN OPEN SPACE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THE CITY IS WILLING AND ABLE TO
TAKE AND MAINTAIN THE PARKS FROM
CALTRANS AS PART OF THE CITY'S
EXISTING PARKS SYSTEM.
SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN WOULD ENSURE
THAT THESE TO CRUCIAL PUBLIC
PARKS CONTINUE TO BE RECREATION
AND OPEN SPACE FOR EVER.
THE CITY IS WILLING TO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD ADD A
PURCHASE PROVISION FOR THESE
PARKS AS OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT
TRANSFER PRISON PROVISION THAT'S
IN.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN WE HOPE THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH SENATOR MORE LUCK AND CAL
TRANS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
RESIDENTS HAVE SUFFICIENT ACCESS
TO PARKS AND OPEN SPACE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF SB.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN THIS IS IN FAVOR
PLEASE COME FORWARD [inaudible]
OKAY -- WITNESSES OPPOSING THE
BILL.
SHANE ON THE CENTER OF FOR ME --
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL IS BRING IT
FORWARD -- I THINK IT'S HOWEVER.
A BILL THAT IS -- SOMEWHAT
PREMATURE AND A LIGHT IN LIGHT
OF THE FACT THAT THE LEASE
EXPIRES. TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR SO.
WE DO HAVE TIME.
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
CALTRANS ON THIS ISSUE.
A PERSONALLY I FEEL -- CALTRANS
THE LAW IS THE CALTRANS THE CITY
AS A RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL.
THERE'S SO OF PROTECTIONS THERE
ARE.
ARE THEY CAN'T -- HOW DO YOU SAY
GO AHEAD JUST SO IT FROM OUT
FROM UNDER THE CITY AT THAT SO I
DON'T THINK THE PLAN TO DO THAT?
FIVE YOU KNOW I KNOW THEY'RE NOT --
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT --
NEGOTIATING A PRICE THROUGH A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS PROBABLY
NOT.
A GOOD WAY TO WORK WITH CALTRANS.
SO -- MAYBE YOU CAN COMMENT ON
THAT I I PREFER THAT YOU.
HOLD THE BILL. FOR YEAR CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH CALTRANS.
AND SEE IF WE CAN COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT.
OVER THE NEXT -- FEW MONTHS.
THAT WOULD BE WHAT MY PREFERENCE
WITH LINE AND OTHER WORDS I'M
NOT SAYING.
NO.
WE'LL KEEP WORKING ON IT -- I
THINK WARRANT YOU MADE A GOOD
CASE FOR ORANGE.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT BUT ALL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATOR USE.
GUY.
TRUST AND KNOW WHY I KNOW I CAN
WORK WITH HIM ON THIS
[inaudible]
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I AM --
THAT'S WHAT I'M CONSIDERING FOR
THIS BILL.
NOT RECOMMENDING AT THIS TIME
BUT CONTINUED.
TO WORK WITH THE IF YOU -- MAKE
IT A IN THE SECOND YOUR BILL.
THAT WOULD BE MY PREFERENCE.
OTHER COMMENTS FROM OTHER
MEMBERS.
MAY I SUPPORT THE BILL IN THAT
WAY AND IN THAT IN THAT
FRAMEWORK.
I AM HAPPY TO MAKE IT TO YOUR
BILL MISTER CHAIR THANKS FOR THE
COUNCIL AYE.
WE DID WORK HARD.
WORK IN OUR THE PRICE.
MADE A FAIR OFFER BUT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND NOT TAKE A VOTE AND
WILL MAKE THIS A TO YOUR BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WORK
WITH YOU AND SURVEYS.
BECAUSE SHE'S THE OWNER TO WRITE
YOUR ORANGE COUNTY [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOT YOUR CITY BUT THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOWED YEAH I DO
TOO I'M GRANT TOTALLY AGREE --
OKAY CENTER YOU HAVE A SECOND
BILL I'LL GIVE IT A SECOND SHOT
HERE.
WITH THE SENATE BILL FIVE ELEVEN
BY THE WAY AND COLLEAGUES A AND
A HALF AGO -- DURING THAT THE
BREAK IN AT THE END OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I I CAME UP TO THE
CAPITAL.
AND SPECIFICALLY MET WITH
SECRETARY STATE ALEX PADILLA I
I'VE BEEN GETTING A LOT OF PHONE
CALLS AND EMAILS -- FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS AS THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MOTOR VOTER.
AND SO.
IT'S THE SECRETARY AND I HAD A
REALLY GOOD MEETING AT HIS
OFFICE ANY ASSURED ME THAT.
EVERYTHING WAS TAKEN CARE OF
THAT THERE WOULD BE NO.
REASON TO BE CONCERNED -- ALMOST
LIKE A ABSOLUTELY NOT DON'T
WORRY THAT ONE NON CITIZEN WILL
NOT BE REGISTERED THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS.
EVEN THOUGH AT THE TIME THE BILL
THAT APPROVED MOTOR VOTER WAS
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
EVEN UP TO THE IMPLEMENTATION HI
EVERYONE WAS WARNING THAT THE
SOFTWARE WAS NOT.
READY IT WASN'T FULLY COOKED AS
ONE TERM KEEPS BEING USED AROUND
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
LEARN OF A DMV INTERNAL WHAT IT
SHOWING THAT ABOUT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED CUSTOMERS MAY HAVE BEEN
IMPROPERLY REGISTERED TO VOTE.
SO I FOLLOWED UP WITH A LETTER
TO THE SECRETARY AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH HIS OFFICES.
IN TRYING TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
TO HELP.
COLLEAGUES I'M I'M SOMEONE WHO --
OBTAINED THE PRIVILEGE TO BOTH
THE HARD WAY I HAD TO EARN IT I
BECAME A CITIZEN OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
THEREFORE THAT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE IS PRETTY SACRED. TO ME.
CONSEQUENTLY WITH I WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE MY CONCERNS FOR THE
AUDIT RESULTS WITH REMEDIES WE
HAD A GOOD BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW HEARING MONDAY MORNING
FIRST THING WITH.
REGARDS TO THE WEIGHT LINES AT
THE DMV WHICH DIDN'T HAVE TO DO
WITH MOTOR VOTER MORE WITH --
THE REAL ID BUT WE HAD A GOOD
CHANCE TO TALK TO THE ACTING
DIRECTOR.
AND THE SECRETARY FOR GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS SB FIVE ELEVEN
RECOMMENDS ESTABLISHING A
COMMITTEE TO FACILITATE THE
BETTER SHARING OF INFORMATION
WITH REGARDS TO MOTOR VOTER.
I'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER VOTERS
NEIL KELLY.
A PROFESSIONAL WHO I ENJOYED
WORKING WITH AS A FELLOW
DEPARTMENT HEAD AND THEN IT AS
HIS BOSS IS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
SB FIVE ELEVEN IS THE RESULT OF
OUR COLLABORATION THE LAST THING
WE NEED IS A DARK SHADOW HANGING
OVER CALIFORNIA'S ELECTION
PROCESS LET'S GET THE PARTIES
TOGETHER DISCONTINUE THE BLAME
GAMES AND FOCUS ON PREVENTING
FUTURE ERRORS IN ORDER TO
RESTORE VOTER CONFIDENCE IN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
THIS IS A PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITY TO MANAGE THROUGH
THE SITUATION.
BUT GOALS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
TO ADDRESS ONE PROPER TRAINING
AND TO BETTER SOFTWARE
MANAGEMENT.
THE COLLABORATION SHOULD PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND A FINISHED PRODUCT
THAT CLOSES THE BREACH TO THE
SATISFACTION OF ALL IMPACT THE
DEPARTMENTS.
WITH THE INCREASES IN THE
STABBING FUNDING AND AUDITS THE
DMV HAS BEEN VERY BUSY OF LATE
TRYING TO CATCH UP.
BUT IT ALSO NEEDS TO INITIATE
PROACTIVE EFFORTS TO MOVE
FORWARD.
TOWARD AN ERROR FREE ENVIRONMENT.
DELAYING OR MAKING EXCUSES SHOWS
A LACK OF MANAGERIAL LEADERSHIP
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
WE CANNOT.
LET THAT HAPPEN IT'S TIME TO
FOCUS ON SOLUTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE A WITNESS MISTER.
FRIEDMAN.
HISTORY OF THE FLOOR HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JIMMY FROM
ANIMAL DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE NONPROFIT.
LEGAL AID AN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES -- ONE OF THE
PRIMARY KEYSTONES OF WHAT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
IS BASED ON OUR BELIEF ON EQUAL.%
AND PASSIONATE FULL LIVES FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
AND A BIG PART OF THAT IS
ENGAGING FOR US IS ENGAGING
SYSTEMATIC ADVOCACY. TO ENSURE
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF VOTER INFO
WHICH IS WHAT BRINGS US HERE
TODAY -- DEMOCRACY WORKS ONLY
WITH CLEAN AND HONEST ELECTIONS
AND WE FEEL THAT WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY VOTE IS
COUNTED ADEQUATELY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE
REQUIRED THE SECRETARY OF STATE
AND THE DMV TO ESTABLISH.
THE NEW MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE THEN TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF INS
COVERED SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION.
THE DMV IS REPORTED THAT TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND ERRORS WERE
DISCOVERED AND DESCRIBE THE
PROBLEM AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSING ERROR.
SB FIVE ELEVEN SIX TO ELIMINATE
THE MARGIN OF ERROR BY
ESTABLISHING A COMMITTEE WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES AND
COUNTIES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FACILITATING THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES TRAINING
FOR DMV EMPLOYEES FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TWELVE WITNESSES OPPOSING THE
BILL PLEASE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSING THE BILL -- QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE OF I THINK
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE REASONS-WHY I HAVE RELUCTANCE ON THIS
BILL CENTER.
IS YOUR TRAINING PEOPLE ACTUALLY
THE TONE.
WORK WITH MOTOR VOTER.
IN THE DMV AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT -- JUST.
TO AFTER THE BILL DOESN'T SEEM.
TO FOCUS ON THE PROBLEM AND
ACTUALLY.
CREATES A PROBLEM IN MY OPINION.
SO I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
NOW THAT I'M TWO FOR TWO YEAH
THAT'S RIGHT.
TODAY.
IS SATURDAY BE BETTER.
ACTUALLY ONE AND A HALF TO TWO
YEAH BUT MR TURN NOT REALLY A
BIG ADVOCATE FOR SETTING UP MORE
COMMITTEES RIGHT.
BUT I THINK THAT SOMETHING HAS
TO BE DONE.
AND AND JUST YOU KNOW LETTING
THINGS GO ON THEIR OWN HASN'T
BEEN WORKING QUITE WELL.
SO I I DON'T THINK I WANT TO
MAKE THIS INTO YOUR BILL I'LL GO
AHEAD AND PUT UP FOR BOTH MAKE
YOU KILL IT OUT RIGHT OKAY
[inaudible]
THERE'S NO.
THANK YOU OF FIGURES AND ARMOR
LOCK -- FOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- WHO THE COMMITTEE
REPORT TO AND -- BUT THE
LEGISLATURE AND SECRETARY OF
STATE TERROR [inaudible]
HOW THAT?
COMMUNICATION HAPPEN IF IT
SHOULD IT SHOULD CONCLUDE WITH
THE YOU KNOW AT THE AT THE
CAUGHT A WHITE PAPER IT SHOULD
COME TO THE LEGISLATURE IT
SHOULD PROVIDE FOR PROPER
TRAINING -- PROTOCOLS AND IT
SHOULD -- PROVIDE FOR BETTER
SOFFER MANAGEMENT -- SO THAT --
THE REGISTRARS OF THE STATE ARE
A FEELING COMFORTABLE WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THAT THE DMV
IS -- ACTUALLY BEING CAREFUL
ABOUT HOW ITS HANDLING VOTER
REGISTRATIONS.
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW YOU CAN TO
GET FIVE QUESTIONS ON A SCREEN
AND LEAVES EVERYBODY.
USED IN BEWILDERED -- SO -- THAT
WOULD BE THE THE GOAL THE END
PRODUCT AND THEN IT WOULD JUST
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE GET EVERYTHING.
YOU KNOW RUNNING IN A IN A
PROPER FASHION.
AND HOW WITH THE OF MEMBERS --
OF THE COMMITTEE BE CHOSEN IN
SENATE AND GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENT OR HIS SECRETARYOF
STATE APPOINT SOMEBODY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLE --
PLACES SOMEBODY ON THERE HOW HOW
THAT HAPPENED RIGHT NOW IT'S
SELF APPOINTED TO ASSURE MAKE
SOME AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT REAL
SPECIFIC BUT WE'RE JUST LOOKING
AT HOW DO WE GET YOU KNOW.
WE ARE MAKE IT SO UBER FORMAL
IT'S LIKE LET'S GET SOMETHING
DONE REPORT BACK TO US HELP US
OUT.
WITHOUT MAKING IT A YOU KNOW.
SO THIS IS MORE IT IS IT'S
INFORMATION ON AMBER INFORMATION
FINDING IT DOESN'T PROVIDE A A
MANDATE THAT -- THEIR FINDINGS
HAVE TO BE MANDATED INTO SERVICE
OR AS A WAY TO EDUCATE THE DMB
ON HOW TO BETTER -- RUN THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM IT'S IT'S
THE LATTER IT INTO ITS LET'S
LET'S IT'S A IT'S A I'M GETTING
THE IMPRESSION CENTER STONE THAT
YOU KNOW IF WE WERE BOTH FROM
SUPERVISOR LAND.
AND SO IT SEEMS LIKE I HAVE TO
MANAGE THE STATE OR WE HAVE TO
SOMEHOW MANAGED TO STATE THROUGH
LEGISLATION.
AND SO THIS WAS THE IDEA IT WAS
OKAY LET'S.
IT'S GOT A COMMITTEE TOGETHER --
BECAUSE WE NEED TO REASSURE THE
VOTERS THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWING.
NON RESIDENTS TO REGISTER TO
VOTE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY SO.
WHAT'S IT WHAT'S A CORDIAL WAY
TO FACILITATE THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND THIS IS THE APPROACH WE TOOK.
WELL OBVIOUSLY -- THE STRUCTURE
WITH THE THE DEPARTMENT OR
VEHICLES WE SET A LARGE HEARING
OF ONE WAS AT THE MONDAY -- YEAH.
THE DAYS AGO BY SO FAST HERE AND
AND WE HAVE A WE HAVE A AN
AGENCY THAT HAS A LOT A LOT OF
ISSUES AND FORTUNATELY WE HAVE A
TASKMASTER THE NICELY.
SECRETARY THAT WAS THERE -- CAM
OR HER NAME BUT SHE WAS
WONDERFUL AND SHE HAS SIX MONTHS
TO COME UP WITH --
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW WE CAN
MAKE OUR DEPARTMENT OF A MOTOR
VEHICLES A STELLAR DEPARTMENT --
I MENTIONED DURING THAT HEARING
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONE
INTERACTION THAT PEOPLE HAVE
BULLS COMMON WITH THE STATE
AGENCY AND THAT FIRST IMPRESSION
IS A LASTING IMPRESSION AND
CERTAINLY.
THE IMPRESSION THAT THE DMP IS
BEEN GIVING AND I ALSO QUALIFY
THIS OF 90% OF THE EMPLOYEES OF
THE DMV ARE HARD WORKING
DEDICATED PEOPLE I JUST THINK
THERE WAS A LACK OF LEADERSHIP
AT THE TOP THAT.
BECAUSE THE THE AGENCY DIFFICULT
THE FUNDER -- BUT I SEE THIS IS --
AWAY TO HELP IDENTIFY PROBLEMS
AND THE RESULTS AREN'T
NECESSARILY MANDATED I THINK
IT'S A GOOD WAY TO BRING TO
LIGHT -- ISSUES A COULD IMPROVE
THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM -- AND
FOR THOSE REASONS MISTER SHERROD
I UNDERSTAND YOUR YOUR
OPPOSITION BELOW I LIKE TO MOVE
IT AND WITH THE COURTESY TO MY
COLLEAGUE AND I I DO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THURSTONE ALL OAKLAWN YOU'LL
REACH COR.
OKAY.
SIR DO YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS TO MAKE DOES THAT YOU
KNOW ARE.
YOU KNOW YOU YOU JUST SIT HERE
AS A AS A SENATOR YOU CHECK A
WEEK IDENTIFIED AN ISSUE LET'S
SEE.
WHAT WE CAN DO IN A PROFESSIONAL
MANNER TO GET RESOLVED WITHOUT
YOU KNOW CREATING?
A COMMITTEE THE LAST FOR UMPTEEN
YEARS YOU CAN BE ANOTHER BOX WE
CAN'T BLOW UP.
LET'S LET'S JUST GO AHEAD AND
TRY SOMETHING IN A IN A IN A
FORMAL THE IF AND I'M A KIND OF
AN INFORMAL FASHION TO GET
THINGS ACCOMPLISHED AND I COURT
ARE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THE USER BATES HAD A COMMENT
SENATE JUST A QUICK COMMENT
HAVING GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS
MYSELF AND BEEN A SOMEWHAT
CONFUSED BY THE SCREENSHOT FROM.
I THINK BOB I THINK WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT SENATOR MORLOCKS
APPROACH HERE IS THAT.
WITH THE COMMITTEE TAKING A LOOK
AT WHERE THE ERRORS OCCUR IT
WILL BECOME VERY APPARENT IT IS
IN THE FIRST SCREEN WHERE YOU DO
NOT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAY
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE REGISTERED
BECAUSE OR YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
REGISTERED BECAUSE WHAT I HAVE.
UNDERSTOOD FROM THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ON WHERE THIS IS HAPPENED
OR BEEN INTERVIEWED WHEN YOU
DECLARE YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
REGISTERED BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT.
A CITIZEN THAT INFORMATION IS
TRANSFERRED TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
I'VE HEARD FROM SOME OF OUR
CONGRESS PEOPLE IS A MATTER OF
FACT THAT.
WHEN THEY'RE WORKING WITH
THOUGHT UNDOCUMENTED ON TRYING
TO BECOME CITIZENS THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN VERY CONCERNED WITH
ALL THE FOCUS ON?
YOU KNOW THE ORDER OUR SECURITY
ETCETERA THAT THEY WILL BE
TARGETED. FOR SOME SORT OF PICK
UP BECAUSE THEY NOW KNOW THEY
ARE ON THEIR UNDOCUMENTED
BECAUSE THAT GOES TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND IT'S VERY
CLEAR.
ON THE FORM THAT YOU FILL OUT
THAT THAT'S WHERE THE
INFORMATION'S GOING.
AND PRESENTLY YOU CAN JUST APPLY
FOR A DRIVER'S LICENSE
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED AND
THERE'S NO INFORMATION THE GHOST
ANY OTHER PLACE BUT TO THE DMB.
AND I THINK JUST CHANGING A FEW
OF THE QUESTIONS ON THAT
ORIGINAL SCREEN.
WILL PROVIDE SECRETARY OF STATE
WITH THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
AND CERTAINLY INSURED.
PEOPLE ELIGIBLE TO REGISTER CAN
REGISTER IN I THINK WITH YOUR
BILL TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE IT DOESN'T TAKE A
LONG TIME TO FIGURE OUT THAT'S
WHERE THE MISTAKES ARE BEING
MADE.
IT ISN'T THE EMPLOYEES IS
ACTUALLY THE FORM YOU HAVE TO GO
OUT AND YOU GET TWO SHOTS AT IT
WHEN WHEN YOU WERE NOTIFIED.
THAT YOU HAVE TO GET A NEW
DRIVER'S LICENSE IN THE ENVELOPE
YOU GET IS A NEW REGISTRATION
FORM.
IT'S QUITE LONGER THAN THE WHEN
YOU PICK UP AT THE LIBRARY IN A
HOUSE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
IT THERE WASN'T REQUIRED BEFORE
AND THE TOP LINE IT SAYS.
IF YOU DO NOT WOULD JUST SIT
REGISTERED TO VOTE THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE CONFIDENTIAL
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
MEANING THAT NOW YOUR DMV
INFORMATION IS NOW PROVIDED TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
SO THEY'VE TRANSFERRED BACK ONTO
THE SCREEN THE COMPUTER SCREEN
IN I THINK JUST KIND OF TAKING
THAT OFTEN GET GIVING PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY SAY I DON'T WANT TO
READ STRIVE ALREADY REGISTERED.
MAKING THE LANGUAGE SIMPLER IS
GONNA SOLVE THE PROBLEM IN YOUR
COMMITTEE WOULD HELP WITH THE
GROUP OF PEOPLE SITTING AROUND
SO IT'S NOT POLITICIZED.
THE SE -- LET'S JUST CHANGE A
FEW WORDS HERE AND THEN IT'S
GOING O WORK FINE BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE AREAS --
I'VE SPENT TOO MANY HOURS TAKING
A LOOK AT AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DID I KINDA GET.
NEWS REPRESENTED IN IT WAS
STRICTLY THE WAY I ANSWERED
THOSE FIRST COUPLE QUESTIONS SO
IN.
SO I DO SUPPORT YOUR DIRECTION
IT REALLY PUTS IT WITH A GROUP
OF PEOPLE ALL STAKEHOLDERS WHO
HAVE THE BEST OF INTENTIONS
LET'S GET AS MANY PEOPLE.
INTO OUR ELECTORAL PROCESS AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN THAT'S REALLY GOOD
FOR DEMOCRACY.
THANK YOU CENTER AND THANK YOU
CENTER WILL -- CALL FOR THE VOTE
WHEN -- IT'S A QUORUM THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SERVICE CENTER
LEYVA YOU HAVE THE FLOOR FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
SERVER LABORS INTRODUCING HER
BILL.
THIS IS THE US BE -- TWO ONE
ZERO AND OR THIS IS ON HEAVY
DUTY -- VEHICLE INSPECTION AND
MAINTENANCE.
SO CERTAINLY WE HAVE A FOUR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
OFFERING THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
THINKING YOU AND YOUR FOR YOUR
HARD WORK.
I ALSO WANT TO THINK THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS FOR CONTINUING TO
WORK SO COLLABORATIVELY WITH ME
AND MY TEAM ON THIS MAJOR.
MEMBERS SB TWO TEN ESTABLISHES
SMOG CHECK REQUIREMENTS FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
UNLIKE PERSONAL PASSENGER
VEHICLES CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS TO
HAVE REGULAR SMOG INSPECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR EMISSION
CONTROL SYSTEMS ARE WORKING
PROPERLY.
THROUGHOUT THE LIFESPAN.
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS DRIVE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ROADS ANNUALLY AND
ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
STATE'S POOR AIR QUALITY.
THE BIGGEST ENVIRONMENTAL AND
HEALTH ISSUE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND IN MANY REGIONS
ACROSS OUR STATE IS THE
POLLUTION FROM THE CONSTANT
TRUCK TRAFFIC ON OUR STREETS AND
FREEWAYS.
STATEWIDE ABOUT TWELVE MILLION
RESIDENTS LIVE IN COMMUNITIES
THAT FAIL TO MEET FEDERAL CLEAN
STANDARDS CLEAN AIR STANDARDS.
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS OPERATING
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY
60% OF THE HARMFUL OXIDES OF
NITROGEN KNOCKS.
AND 82% OF DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER PM TWO POINT FIVE A
POTENTIALLY CANCER CAUSING AIR
CONTAMINANT.
INCREASED EXPOSURE TO THE
HARMFUL AIR CONTAMINANTS PM TO
FIVE AN OZONE IS DIRECTLY
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED
HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR CHRONIC
HEART AND LUNG DISEASES.
AND OTHER SERIOUS HEALTH IMPACTS
FOR ELDERLY ADULTS AND YOUNG
CHILDREN.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD CARB CURRENTLY ADMINISTERS
TO INSPECTION PROGRAMS FOR HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS.
HOWEVER THESE PROGRAMS ONLY
REQUIRE THE CONTROL OF EXCESSIVE
SMOKE AND LACK MEASURES TO LIMIT
HARMFUL EMISSIONS.
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THESE
PROGRAMS ARE INFREQUENTLY
PERFORMED AND THEY ARE NOT
COMPREHENSIVE.
SB TWO TEN WOULD DIRECT CARP TO
WORK IN COORDINATION WITH
MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT A HEAVY DUTY
INSPECTION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM FOR TRUCKS.
THOSE ARE TRUCKS FOURTEEN
THOUSAND POUNDS OR MORE.
SB TWO TEN WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH
TEST PROCEDURES FOR DIFFERENT
MODEL YEARS AND A MISSION
CONTROL TECHNOLOGIES TO MEASURE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
EMISSIONS CONTROL OF KNOX AND PM
TWO POINT.
FIVE SB TWO TEN ALSO APPLIES TO
OUT OF STATE TRUCKS AND WILL
HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
ARE LAW ABIDING TRUCK OWNERS AND
OPERATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE NEXT DECADE SB TWO TEN
WILL ASSIST IN THE REMOVAL OF
SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF HARMFUL
PARTICULATE MATTER WHICH IS THE
EQUIVALENT TO TAKING THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TRUCKS.
OFF THE ROADS OF CALIFORNIA.
NOT ONLY WILL SB TWO TEN HELP
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND AIR
QUALITY IT WILL IMPROVE THE LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
SB TWO TEN APPLIES SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO TRUCK
OPERATORS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
MISSION CONTROLS AS WE ALREADY
REQUIRE IN THE CARS THAT WE
DRIVE EVERY DAY.
I WANT TO AGAIN THANK THE VERY
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMIT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH EACH OF
THEM TOGETHER TO FURTHER THIS
BILL WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
IS ALLEN ALPS WITH THE BAY AREA
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
ENVIRONS RYAN SHOOK SHE CARD
FROM CAL START.
WILL BE MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
PLEASE WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BELL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ALAN ABSENT WITH THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
I'D LIKE TO START WITH KNOWLEDGE
IN THE EXCELLENT COMMENTS FROM
SENATOR LABEL IN POINTING OUT
THE AIR QUALITY IMPACTS OF
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS IN AIR
TOXICS EMITTED FROM MEDIUM AND
HEAVY.
DUTY TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA AND
HOW'S SMOG CHECK PROGRAM SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO FOR LIGHT
DUTY CARS AND TRUCKS COULD HELP
IN REDUCING THOSE OVERALL
IMPACTS.
AS THE SENATOR NOTED WE HAVE
CLOSE TO ONE MILLION HEAVY DUTY
AND MEDIUM DUTY TRUCKS OPERATING
IN CALIFORNIA THE DRIVE CLOSE TO
SIXTY MILLION MILES PER DAY.
IN THE BAY AREA WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND TRUCKS THAT
COVER CLOSE TO SEVEN MILLION
MILES A DAY.
THROUGH THE BAY AREA'S CARE
PROGRAM AND ALSO THE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY OR
PROTECTION PROGRAMS WE'VE SHOWN
THAT MANY AREAS WITHIN OUR
REGION AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
EXPERIENCE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACTS FROM AIR POLLUTION AND
IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT MANY OF
THESE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS
ARE IN HIGH TANSPORTATION AREAS
IMPACTED BY DIESEL PARTICULATE.
AS AN EXAMPLE -- IN THE WEST
OAKLAND AREA OVER 50% OF THE
CANCER RISK -- COMES FROM THE
PORT OF PORT OF OAKLAND TO AND
THE HEAVY DUTY AND MEDIUM DUTY
TRUCKS THAT SERVE THAT PORT OF
OAKLAND.
AND SO -- I IN CONCLUSION THE
THE SB TWO TEN WOULD SUPPORT --
THE BAY AREA AND AND THE REST OF
THE STATE IN REDUCING THE RISKS
OF DIESEL POLLUTION.
AND WE HIGHLY -- RECOMMEND
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON IS RUNNING
SHORT ON BEHALF CAL START CAL
STAR IT IS A CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSORTIUM.
COMPRISED OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
BUSINESSES NONPROFITS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IT'S BEEN WORKING
FOR THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
TO CELEBRATE THE TRANSPORTATION
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR FREIGHT
SYSTEM.
WHICH IS A MAJOR ENGINE OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY.
HOWEVER THESE VEHICLES ALSO IN A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS INTO OUR
ATMOSPHERE.
MANY FEET OPERATORS THERE ARE
MEMBERS SUCH AS UPS PROPERLY
MAINTAIN THEIR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE FLEETS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH
APPLICABLE VEHICLE EMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE STATE.
TOGETHER FLEETS LIKE THESE
COMPRISE MANY THOUSANDS OF
VEHICLES USING SCALP USING
CALIFORNIA'S FREIGHT QUARTERS
WEEKLY.
HOWEVER SOME FLEETS ARE GROSS
POLLUTERS TO THE DETRIMENT OF
OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTH THIS
CREATES A DISPROPORTIONATE.
EXCUSE ME THIS CREATES A
COMPLETE COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE FOR THE FLEAS
WHOEVER SPOTS WILL WELL
MAINTAINED EQUIPMENT ON THE BAD
ACTORS ARE ABLE TO KEEP LOSING
OUR COMMUNITIES THERE.
THE CURRENT LACK OF SUCH SMOG
CHECKS EQUATES TO AN UNFAIR TAX
ON RESPONSIBLE RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESSES AND AN UNFAIR TAX ON
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LONGS.
SB TWO CHANNEL LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD ACROSS THE COMMERCIAL
TRUCK OPERATORS BY ENSURING THAT
EVERYONE IS HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO
VEHICLE EMISSIONS.
IT ACTUALLY HELPED MANY FLEETS
BY STOPPING LOWER AND OPERATORS
THAT POLLUTING VEHICLES FROM
UNDERCUTTING THE PROFESSIONAL
WELL MAINTAINED VEHICLE
OPERATIONS.
SB TO DENNIS DENNIS SENSIBLE WAY
IT'S MEANT TO BE A LIGHT TOUCH
REGULATORY SYSTEM EVEN LATER
THAN A CAR SMOG CHECK.
AND IS THAT A STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR FLEAS THAT HAVE AN
ESTABLISHED COMPLIANCE HISTORY.
CARLA ALTERNATELY HAVE TO
DETERMINE THE PROCESS THROUGH
RULE MAKING A PROCESS THAT WOULD
INCLUDE REGULATED PARTISAN
SELVES TO TO BE A PART OF NO
FLEET OPERATORS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CIRCUMVENT STATE
VEHICLE EMISSION STANDARDS.
AND SB TWO TEN IS A COMMON SENSE
SOLUTION TO ENSURING PARITY
ACROSS ALL INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS
IN SOUND THE BILL PROVIDES A
WORKABLE COMMONSENSE APPROACH
PRETENDING DOWN ACROSS COMPUTERS.
BOB WHAT DO YOU NEED FOR
MEASURES THAT CREATE UNNECESSARY
RED TAPE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OF WE HAVE OTHER
PEOPLE WANT TO ADD ON IBM'S
CHAIRMAN BILL MCADAMS CHOLISH
FOR CLEAN AIR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER PEOPLE PLEASE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY DRIVEN
WITH THREE FIFTY MARY ACTION I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ALONG WITH THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY AND FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA.
RENDON TOOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BARGAINS OFFICER TODAY
ABOUT THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THE TERM JUST LEARN FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND ALSO THE LOCAL IN
BERMAN HEALTH DIRECTORS FOR THE
HEALTH REASONS THANK YOU.
ROCKY RUSSIAN WITH COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT
REPRESENTING AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION AS WELL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK.
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH YOUR CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WHEN THE COMMISSION WITH A
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION IN
SUPPORT?
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MARINA FRANCESCHI WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
RUBY MCDONALD THREE FIFTY
RIVERSIDE THREE FIFTY SAN DIEGO
AND SO CAL THREE FIFTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TIM ROBINSON ROBINSON
ENTERPRISES NEVADA CITY.
I'M THE ONLY ONE PROBABLY NOT IN
SUPPORT I WASN'T EVEN HERE TO
LISTEN TO THIS.
BUT I'M HERE TO HOLD ON HOLD ON
ISN'T HELP I THINK WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IN ORDER THE PROCESS
HERE YEAH THE PROCESS WILL BE WE
HEAR THE SUPPORTERS.
AND ONLY AFTER THE SERB ORDERS
SPEAK THEM ALL HERE -- ANYBODY
THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE RIGHT LINE
WHEN IT'S TIME.
SO YOU GET SOME TIME LATER OKAY.
THIS WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET
EVERYBODY THE SUPPORTS THE BILL
FIRST.
SO THE OTHER THE OTHER
SUPPORTERS HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
OKAY -- OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PLEASE COME.
FOR YEAH HE CAN COME UP IF HE
WANTS OVER [inaudible]
MAYBE RIGHT.
A ROMAN WITH THE CALVARY
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THEM OVER SAY CONCERNS
AND COST EFFECTIVENESS AND
DUPLICATE REGULATION.
CITY AND ITS MEMBERS.
DO NOT OPPOSE NEW INSPECTION ON
OUR EQUIPMENT. TO THE CONTRARY
WE BELIEVE THAT INSPECTIONS DONE
WELL -- IN REMOVING DUPLICATION
WILL HELP THOSE TRUCKING
COMPANIES WHO HAVE INVESTED
HEAVILY IN NEW EQUIPMENT AGAINST
THOSE WHO CONTINUE TO REFUSE TO
COMPLY.
WITH STATE REGULATIONS.
HOWEVER WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE P.
THIRTY THIS BILL PROVIDES CARP.
CARP IS STILL IN THE COURSE OF
DESIGNING THEIR HEAVY DUTY SMOG
CHECK PROGRAM.
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF THE
REGULATION WILL BURY DEPENDING
ON DECISIONS CARP STAFF AND THE
BOARD HAVE YET TO MAKE WE CANNOT
SUPPORT HANDING OVER A BLANK
CHECK TO THE AGENCY.
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY ALREADY
INVEST APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. TO COMPLY WITH
CARP RULES. TO DATE CARP IS
LEVIED NO FEES TO IMPLEMENT
THESE RULES.
IF NEW THE AUTHORITIES TO BE
GRANTED CAR MUST DISCLOSE WHY
THE FEES REASONABLE AND
NECESSARY AND THAT THERE AND WHY
THEIR PROGRAM COSTS ARE
JUSTIFIED. TO DATE DESPITE
DISCUSSING THE CONCEPT FOR
NEARLY TWO YEARS.
NO COST ESTIMATES HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO STAKEHOLDERS TO
JUSTIFY THE FEE -- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR -- BUT AT THIS TIME WE
ARE STILL POSE LESS AMENDED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE WITNESS PLEASE YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JUST AN
OLD FIELD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION I TO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE
FOR WORKING WITH US -- AND IN
NOT TRYING TO BE REDUNDANT WITH
WITH WHAT'S IN THE ANALYSIS
BECAUSE AS THE ANALYSIS DOES
STATE -- SEVERAL AMENDMENTS WILL
BE MADE TO ADDRESS -- CONCERNS --
THAT WERE BROUGHT FORWARD BY OUR
COALITION I DO WANNA QUICKLY
FOCUS ON ONE SPECIFIC.
ISSUE THAT I BELIEVE IS IS
OUTSTANDING AND THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE FIX THE TICKET
COMPONENT.
OF THE BILL AND AND PROVIDING A
CERTAIN TIME FRAME FOR AN
OPERATOR TO CORRECT A VIOLATION --
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS NOTES THAT -- AT LEAST IN
OUR OPINION FROM AGRICULTURE
THAT THAT THAT WINDOW SHOULD BE
NINETY DAYS.
AND WE THINK THAT IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE AND A REASONABLE REQUEST --
AND A GOOD EXAMPLE BECAUSE IT
REFLECTS A SORT OF A VERY BUSY
TIMES DURING OUR PLANNING AND
HARVESTING SEASONS -- THAT WE
THAT THAT WE SEE IN CLIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND I I JUST WANNA
MAKE ONE QUICK EXAMPLE AND IT'S
MORE THE LIVESTOCK SIDE GIVEN
WHO I REPRESENT BUT LIVE SOCCER
PRIMARILY MOVE TWICE A YEAR --
IN THE IN THE SPRING -- ERECTION
STARTING IT RIGHT NOW -- WITH A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF LIVESTOCK
THAT ARE MOVED -- FROM FROM
WINTER WINTER PASTURE TO SUMMER
PASTURE AND AGAIN IN THE FALL
BACK TO SUMMER POWER TO WINNER
PRESSURE IN THOSE CATTLE ARE
MARKETED DURING THOSE PERIODS.
AND THEY ROUGHLY RUN FOR ABOUT
NINETY DAYS AND THAT'S IN THE
SPRING AND THE FALL WE CALL THE
SCREEN FALL RUN -- AND WE
ALREADY HAVE A VERY STE WE HAVE
A SHORTAGE OF TRUCKS
SPECIFICALLY LIVESTOCK COLLEGE
IN THE STATE.
SO WE DO HAVE A GOOD AMOUNT OF
TRUCKS THAT COME INTO A SYSTEM
THAT NINETY DAY WINDOW.
AND IF WE WERE TO LOSE TRUCKS
DURING THAT NINETY DAY WINDOW
BECAUSE OF A FIX A TICKET THAT
WAS ONLY AT FORTY FIVE DAYS WE
WOULD HAVE CONSIDERABLE --
ISSUES WITH MAKING UP THAT
CAPACITY AND THAT'S I THINK ONE
GOOD EXAMPLE MY WE REQUEST THAT
THAT NINETY DAY FIX IT -- TICKET
WINDOW SO THIS ISSUE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK -- WITH THE
AUTHOR AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU.
OF OTHER PEOPLE OPPOSING THE
BILL PLEASE YEAH -- GOOD
AFTERNOON MICROBES IN THE I'M
HERE ON THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IF YOU JUST INDULGE ME FOR A
SECOND SENATOR I WE ARE NOT
PRIVATE FLEETS WERE NOT --
COMMERCIAL OPERATORS OF FLEETS
WE WE WITH THIS IS THE THE
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ARE
REGULATED UNDER CARP THROUGH --
SOMETHING CALLED THE PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND UTILITIES.
THAT RICK FLEET REGULATION FOR
PROBABLY EACH SEASON UTILITIES
AND AND THROUGH THAT REGULATION
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO HAVE THEIR
FLEETS REQUIRED HAVE BEST
AVAILABLE CONTROL TECHNOLOGY IN
ALL THEIR OTHER HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES.
AND WE'RE SIMPLY WE UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A MEMBERS GOING IN FOR
THE PRIVATE OPERATORS ABOUT
DUPLICATIVE REGULATIONS IN.
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE ENTERTAINING
TO PUT THE IDEA OF DUPLICATIVE
REGULATIONS ARE STRAW THAT
THROUGH THE PUBLIC FLEETS IN
THERE AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO TO
NOT OVER REGULATE THE PUBLIC
FLEETS WHICH IS ONLY GONNA
BECAUSE YOUR UTILITY RATES AND
OTHER RATES YOU PAY AS UP.
AS TAXPAYERS TO YOUR
PUBLICATIONS HE'S TO GO UP SO
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELL CREAMERS
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION -- WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF ALL ALREADY BEEN
EXPRESSED AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS.
THE IS A RATHER IN CALIFORNIA OF
COMMERCE WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS A
MINUTE FOR THE SAME REASONS
OUTLINED BY MY COLLEAGUES MONEY.
MR JR MEMBERS BREDERODE UNITED
CONTRACTORS IN THE WESTERN LIKE
INSTRUCTORS AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO RECOGNIZE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT -- ARE BEING
WORKED THROUGH AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU.
I'M IN THE RIGHT LINE.
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOOD -- ROBINSON
ENTERPRISES OPPOSE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
CHARLIE RAY CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION DUSTER MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSING UNTIL WE
SEE THAT MEN'S [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON FRIENDS ROSS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY POST
ONCE AMENDED.
JUST LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
FOR THOSE OF SENIOR WAY THANK
[inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY ANY OTHER OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL OKAY
SEEN ON PERHAPS THE ISSUES RACE
WITH THE OPPOSITION RESPONDED.
TO SO WE HAVE -- CENTER LABOR
ALL TURN OVER YOU AND YOUR
WITNESSES PERHAPS BEEN.
RESPOND TO SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED.
I HEARD -- ABSOLUTELY.
PLEASE THE COURT.
INPUT FROM -- PEOPLE ARE
AFFECTED BY THE YOU'LL FEES AND
THE SIX A TICKET ISSUE
ABSOLUTELY OKAY SO I WOULD FIRST
ARE WITH THE THE FEE OF FORTY
AND AND THAT SEEMS TO BE
SOMETHING A BIG CONCERN TO FOLKS
WHICH IT IS TO US AS WELL --
THERE CERTAINLY WILL NOT BE A
BLANK CHECK THAT IS HANDED OVER
TO CARB -- WHAT WE'RE WAITING
FOR QUITE FRANKLY IS TO GET --
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
WHERE WILL HAVE A MORE DETAILED
FISCAL ANALYSIS.
I COULD GIVE YOU A NUMBER I
COULD PULL SOMETHING OUT OF THE
AIR AND JUST GAS BUT WE REALLY
ARE TRYING TO BE VERY THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT THIS AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET WE COME UP WITH THE PROPER
FEE.
SO WE ARE COMPLETELY COMMITTED
TO WORKING ON IT BUT AGAIN THIS
IS A POLICY COMMITTEE WE ARE
LOOKING TO GET THOSE ANSWERS
WHEN WE GET TO SENATE IF WE ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH. TO GET TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS -- AS FAR AS THE
FORTY FIVE DAYS VERSUS THE
NINETY DAYS WE'RE 1100%
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE WE IN NO WAY WANT ANY
ANIMALS TO DIE WE WANT NO FRUITS
OR VEGETABLES TO ROT.
I AM SO CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
FIND A WAY TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE -- I
JUST AGAIN ONE THINK THE STATE
HOLE STAKEHOLDERS -- AND MY
STAFF THIS IS OUR THIRD YEAR
WITH THIS BILL AND WE TRY TO BE
VERY THOUGHTFUL I LIKE TO SAY TO
PEOPLE THAT -- WHEN YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING IF EVERYBODY WALKS
AWAY A LITTLE BIT UNHAPPY EVERY
WALKS WITH A LITTLE BIT HAPPY
THEN WE DID OUR JOB WE ARE NOT
TRYING TO PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS HERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE THE WITNESSES SO CAN YOU
DRESS THE FEES ISSUE HOW DO YOU
DO THAT [inaudible]
THE CARD.
WHAT DO YOU BASE IT ON COST
RECOVERY OR?
IS THERE A WELL OUR THE OUT OUR
THIS OUT HOW WILL.
THOSE.
IT'S OF COURSE.
PEOPLE WHAT WOULD WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT BUT ONE I'M NOT
SURE I'M THE BEST PERSON ANSWER
THIS QUESTION WORKING FOR THE
FOR THE BAY AREA AIR DISTRICT IN
NOT CARB BUT BUT I WOULD JUST
LOOK AT IT SIMILAR -- TO THE
EXISTING LAWS SMOG CHECK PROGRAM
FOR FOR LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES IN
IN THAT THERE IS A OR A SIMILAR
TYPES -- COST RECOVERY KIND OF
THING RIGHT YES SIR I THINK IT
IS YEAH IT IS [inaudible]
THE SIR DODD HAD A QUESTION.
THERE MEMBERS OF ALL I
APPRECIATE THE THE AUTHOR -- FOR
YEAH WORKING WITH THE YEAH
PEOPLE THAT HAD SOME CONCERNS ON
THIS BILL AYE AYE IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THERE IS -- YOU KNOW MORE
WORK TO DO OTHER THAN COST
RECOVERY I I I LOOK AT THIS
THING WE WE HEARD TONIGHT FAIR
TAX -- ON PEOPLE'S LAWNS AND I
AGREE WITH THAT -- IT'S NOT FAIR
TAX ON RESPONSIBLE TRUCK OWNERS.
AND I GUESS YEAH WHAT WE'VE DONE --
THROUGH OUR PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
RIGHT AND JUST LOOK AT WE GOTTA
GET CLEAN AIR IN THE STATE AND-SO WHAT WE'VE DONE.
IS WE FORCE TRUCKING COMPANIES.
TO REALLY GO THE EXTRA MILE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY BUY A
NEW VEHICLES WHILE WE'VE BEEN
ALLOWING OTHER VEHICLES TO COME
IN AND THE POLLUTE THE AIR SO
ONCE AGAIN WHAT MY BIGGEST
CONCERN HERE IS ONCE AGAIN.
THE RESPONSIBLE TRUCK OWNERS.
ARE GETTING TAXED.
AND ALSO WHAT I SEE IS YOU I
USED TO OWN -- PROBABLY THE OVER
TWENTY MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS.
AND WHEN YOU BUY A NEW VEHICLES --
PRESUMABLY YOU'RE PARTICULARLY
IN AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
THIS STARTS.
BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT
THIS IDEA AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE DURATION OF THE TIME PERIOD
IS -- EVEN WITH CARS THESE DAYS
HOW OFTEN YOU HAVE TO HAVE DONE
BUT WITH THE NEW TRUCKS WITH THE
NEW FILTERS AND EVERYTHING THEY
HAVE -- THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
BUYING A NEWER TECHNOLOGY SHOULD
BE GRANDFATHERED IN IT SEEMS TO
ME MAYBE THAT'S YOUR BILL I DID
NOT READ THAT -- YOU KNOW IN IN
IN IN THE ANALYSIS.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
THIS IS A SMALL CHECK IT'S NOT A
TAX SO IT'S LIKE YOU AND I WHEN
WE TAKE OUR VEHICLES -- EVERY
YEAR EVERY OTHER YEAR DEPENDING
ON THE MAKE AND MODEL AND THE
YEAR OF OUR CAR WE TAKE IT IN TO
GET A SMOG EMISSIONS TEST.
WHEN WE FOUND OUT A FEW YEARS
AGO WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT ARE
BIG DIESEL TRUCKS THAT ARE ON
THE ROADS MORE THAN WE TRAVEL AS
PASSENGER CARS -- DAY IN AND DAY
OUT YOU HEARD OVER A MILLION
MILES ON A TRAVERSE OUR ROADS
EACH YEAR I THOUGHT WELL IT
DOESN'T SEEM UNREASONABLE TO ASK.
BIG RIGS TO DO THE SAME THE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US TO WITH OUR
PASSENGER VEHICLES.
SO THE THE BILL CURRENTLY
REQUIRES THE A. R. B. TO
ESTABLISH DIFFERENT TESTING
PROCEDURES AND A REQUIREMENT FOR
DIFFERENT MODEL YEARS TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE STANDARDS AND THE CAP
THE CAPABILITIES OF NEWER AND
OLDER MODELS.
SO IF YOU'RE IN A NEWER TRUCK.
I I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT
TO BE YOU MIGHT NEED A SMOG
CHECK EVERY OTHER YEAR LIKE WHEN
YOU DRIVE A NEWER CAR NOW I KNOW
THAT SOME OF THE NEWEST CARS AT
A MINUTE THE LOWEST.
MICHAEL A FEW YEARS WITHOUT
HAVING TO HAVE A SMOG CHECK THIS
WOULD BE SIMPLEST BILL WOULD BE
SIMILAR FOR HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
THE BILL ALSO CURRENTLY ALLOWS
FOR STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
TRUCKS THAT HAVE DEMONSTRATED
HISTORY OF BEING WELL MAINTAINED.
CURRENTLY THE AIR BE AN INDUSTRY
ARE EXPLORING WAYS TO ALLOW WELL
MAINTAINED FLEET TO CONSISTENTLY
REPORT ON TIME. TO DECREASE THE
FREQUENCY OF TESTING TO EVERY
OTHER YEAR INSTEAD OF EVERY YEAR
OR JUST SIMPLY SUBMIT DATA IN
LIEU OF OPACITY TESTING FOR
ENGINES TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN OR
NEWER.
WE INTEND THIS BILL TO TRACK
WITH THOSE FLEXIBILITY AS IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS ARE DRIVING A
LOT MORE MILES AND MORE
POLLUTING THE RANK OF REGULAR
VEHICLES IN ANY GIVEN YEAR.
SO INCREASE SMOG CHECK FREQUENCY
AS NECESSARY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HEARD WHEN WE INITIALLY
INTRODUCES BILL A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AS WELL WHAT WE DO WITH THE
OUT OF STATE TRACKS WE CAN DO
ALL THIS GREAT WORK IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WHAT WE DO NGUYEN TRUCKS
COME IN FROM OTHER STATES.
THEY WILL HAVE TO HAVE A PERMIT
TO OPERATE THEY WILL HAVE TO GET
A SMOG CHECK AS WELL SO WE THINK
THAT THAT LEVELS THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR THE TRUCKERS.
AND THE TRUCK DRIVERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND A LOOK MEANS THE
BAD ACTORS OUT OF STATE WILL
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THESE
REGULATIONS AS WELL I HOPE THAT.
SOMEHOW I I THINK IT DOES I I
GUESS WHAT I'LL DO IS I WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY BUT I
RESERVE THE RIGHT ON THE FLOOR
THIS IS AND TAKING CARE OF
PATIENTS -- TO YOUR OPPOSE THE
BILL BOERNER HORVATH THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD.
SIR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
GRATEFUL IN WANNA SAY THANK YOU
TO AT THE SENATOR FOR ALL OF HER
WORK ON THIS AND ME MY
STAKEHOLDERS -- IN TWO WE HAD
OPPORTUNITY JEEP GRATEFUL THAT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU BEFORE COMMITTEE AS
WELL SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME.
I'D LIKE TO BE A TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUE IN REGARDS TO FEES AND THE
PILOT PROJECT.
SO BY THE PROJECT.
COMES BUT I'D SO YOU'RE LOOKING
AT POTENTIALLY MODELING YOUR
FEES OFF OF WHAT CARB.
MAYBE RECOMMENDING CORRECT.
THE OUT AND THEN WILL WE FIND
OUT AND SEND APPROPRIATIONS WHEN
WE HAVE A MORE FISCAL ANALYSIS
OKAY SO ALL. EIGHT EIGHT I THINK
THAT THE ANY TIME.
WHETHER IT'S AN INDUSTRY OR
FAMILY -- DOESN'T HAVE
DEFINITION THERE'S ALWAYS GONNA
BE NERVOUSNESS.
IN ESPECIALLY COMING OUT OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN WITH THE RETROFITS --
IN THE PURCHASE NEW EQUIPMENT
THERE'S REAL CONCERN SO NOW THAT
YOU'RE FOCUSING ON THAT IN
WANTING TO BETTER BRING
DEFINITION AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
YOU WINE COMMENTING ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT NOT AT ALL THANK YOU
CENTER MCGUIRE.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
GETTING THE FEE STRUCTURE TAKING
CARE OF LIKE I SAID EARLIER I
THINK THAT TAT'S BETTER SUITED
FOR A FISCAL PA FISCAL COMMITTEE
LIKE APPROPRIATIONS IF WE'RE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET THIS BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY -- AND I
COULD JUST PULL A NUMBER OUT BUT
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT IT MIGHT
BE TOO LOW IT MIGHT BE TOO HIGH
WE REALLY WANT TO DO A GOOD
FISCAL ANALYSIS.
AND AND OF COURSE WAS LOOKING TO
GET THE LOWEST FEE TO COVER THE
COST OF THE PROGRAM.
HI THIS IS NOT A MONEY MAKING
PROGRAM THIS IS STRICTLY BE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM IS COVERED BUT WE ARE WE
HAVE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR THAT
THAT IS A CONCERN TO FOLKS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT.
IN THE LAST PIECE IS ON FIXING
TICKETS AND JUST WANTING TO TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE MAY BE
A SWEET SPOT AND I DON'T WANT TO
PUT WORDS IN THE MOUTH.
BETWEEN FORTY FIVE IN THE NINETY
IN IN TRYING TO CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE ON THAT AND CAN HIS
COMMENT ON THAT A LITTLE BIT.
YET WE ARE ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED
TO FINDING THAT SWEET SPOT --
BUT LIKE I SAID WE DO NOT WANT
ANY ANIMALS TO DIE ON THE ROAD
IF SOMEONE GETS PULLED OVER AND
HAVE A FIX THE TICKET WE WANT
THEM TO CONTINUE. TO FINISH THAT
LOAD -- ALSO WITH -- FRUITS
VEGETABLES WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOOD SO WE DON'T
WANT TO CAUSE ANY HARM TO PEOPLE
AND I AGREE I THINK I ABSOLUTELY
THINK BECAUSE WE'VE HAD SUCH A
PRODUCTIVE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
THAT WE CAN FIND THE SWEET SPOT
AND FIND SOMETHING THAT WORKS
FOR EVERYONE IN MY LAST QUESTION
ON THAT SWEET SPOT AT WHICH IS
VERY TECHNICAL.
IS -- DO YOU HOPE TO HAVE THAT
PRIOR TO APPROPRIATIONS OR IT
CONTINUE TO WORK ON A JUST WHAT
WHAT YOUR IDEAS YEAH I MEAN WE
CONTINUE TO TALK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON A VERY FREQUENT
BASIS -- WE COULD HAVE SOMETHING
IN THE NEXT DAY OR TWO BUT WE
WANT TO DO IT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
SO LOOK I I THINK THE BOTTOM
LINE IS IN AND I WILL STOP THE
GOOD TWENTY QUESTIONS OF THE
GOOD SENATOR -- BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE THERE HAVE BEEN -- AND I
THINK THE ANALYSIS EVEN POINTED
THIS OUT RIGHT.
THE PREVIOUS VERSIONS WE SEEN
MORE AGREEMENT AND DISAGREEMENT.
AND A NARROWING OF THE BILL AND
AND MORE OF A FOCUS -- IN TRYING
TO BE ABLE TO IRON THOSE ISSUES
OUT THEY JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU -- AS THIS IS A BIG -- ONE
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO SENATORS WELL.
UNDERSTANDING THAT SHE'S GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON BOTH ALL
ISSUES A FIX IT TICKETS AS WELL
AS ON THE FEE STRUCTURE WILL
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT THAT HERE
TODAY TO ALLOW THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
TO CONTINUE WITH AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT SHE'S HEARD AS YOU DO SAID
LOUD AND CLEAR THAT NEED TO BE A
FIGURE THAT OUT AND BRING SOME
FROM THIS TO THAT SO.
DISTRICT GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS AND LOOK FOR HAVING FOR
THEIR CONVERSATION THANK YOU
CERTAINLY THANK YOU CENTER
MCGUIRE.
OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
SENATORS SERVICE STUFF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND CENTER LEAVE --
I I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR GOOD
INTENTIONS WITH HIS BILL I'M.
I STILL GOT SOME CONCERNS --
ESPECIALLY WITH -- TRUCKS THAT
ARE COMING FROM OUT OF STATE --
ALL TAKE WALMART IT IS AS AN
EXAMPLE A LOT OF THEIR TRUCKS
ORIGINALLY FROM BENTONVILLE
ARKANSAS.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN A LOCAL --
REGULATIONS AND LICENSORS THE
ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE -- TO BYE
BYE -- THEY'RE DOING COMMERCE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- CAN
YOU COMMENT ON THE INTERSTATE
COMMERCE CLAUSE OF THE US
CONSTITUTION THAT WERE IMPEDING
THEIR ABILITY TO DO BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND LET'S SAY THAT -- YOU'LL
FIND THAT THEY CAN DO THIS IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS LAW ON THEM I
MEAN ARE YOU GOING TO CYNICAL
TALKTALK OUT THERE THEY KEEP.
COMING INTO THE STATE AND THIS
WILL BE OUR LAWS I MEAN IS IS
VERY DIFFICULT WHEN YOU HAVE
COMPANIES FROM OUTSIDE THE US
STATE CALIFORNIA'S KERRY'S ARE.
YOU PLANNING FOR SICKNESS
ABSOLUTELY SO WE KNOW THAT
TRUCKS HOW THAT ARE GOING TO BE
DOING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
THERE FROM OUT OF STATE THEY
HAVE TO HAVE A PERMIT TO OPERATE.
IF THIS BILL PASSES AND BECOMES
LAW THEY WILL HAVE TO DO A SMOG
CHECK BEFORE THEY CAN GET THEIR
PERMIT TO OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA
SO THAT'S HOW WE WILL DO IT IF
THEY COME IN THEY GET PULLED
OVER NO PERMIT TO OPERATE THEN
THEY'RE IN TROUBLE AND THEY GET.
SENT BACK OUT.
SOUNDS SIMPLE I'M SURE IT WILL
BE QUITE THAT SIMPLE NOTHING
EVER IS BUT IT SHOULD BE JUST
THAT EASY.
WE KNOW HOW MANY CITATIONS ARE
AT NEW YEAR FOR TRUCKS OR NOT.
I HAVE REQUIRED INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE NO IDEA THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT ERUPT -- I
HAVE NO IDEA I DON'T THINK IT'S
THAT MANY THAT THEIR ANALYZE
PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
WHOLE ISSUE IS THAT THERE IS NOT
A LOT OF ENFORCEMENT EVEN AND
WHAT.
IS DONE NOW TO TRY AND FIND THE
BAD ACTORS SO THIS IS TRYING TO
BRING SOME REGULATION TO THE
GOOD AT FOR THE GOOD ACTORS TO
THE BAD ACTORS.
OKAY AND THEN THE FOLLOW UP THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE --
IN MY REPORT SAYS THAT -- WE
SUBJECT HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES TO
REGULAR INSPECTION EMISSION
CONTROLS -- THE CALIFORNIA HEAVY
DUTY INSPECTION PROGRAM ALLOWS
CARBON INSPECTION TEAMS TO
CONDUCT RANDOM INSPECTIONS FOR
EXCESSIVE SMOKE -- VEHICLES
TRAVELING TO CALIFORNIA'S ALSO
HEAR ME CALIFORNIA'S EMISSION
CONTROL REQUIREMENTS OR OBTAIN
AN EMISSION CONTROL LABEL SO.
HOW IS THIS NOT A DUPLICATION OF
THE EFFORTS ALREADY UNDERWAY BY
BY CAR?
DOES NOW IS NOT A SMOG CHECK
THIS WOULD REQUIRE EVERY VEHICLE
HAS A SMOG CHECK AT SOME POINT
IN THE LIFE OF THE VEHICLE WHAT
IS HAPPENING NOW IS VERY RANDOM
AND I WILL SAY RANDOM WITH THE
CAPITAL ARE -- IT DOES NOT
HAPPEN VERY OFFICE SO YOU'VE GOT
A FEW TRUCKS THAT MIGHT BE
CHECKED WORDS WITH THIS PROGRAM
EVERY TRUCK WILL HAVE TO PASS AT
A SMALL TEST.
OKAY WELL APPROVED THANK YOU A
APPRECIATED WORKING CLOSELY WITH.
THE OPPOSITION AND MCCARTY TO
CONTINUE TO DO SO THANK YOU WILL
DO THANK YOU SIR -- THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
SENATORS.
OKAY CENTER YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
FOR CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION AND
I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW
GROWING UP IN CHINO IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE WHICH IS WHEN THE
CITY'S I REPRESENT.
TODAY ARE GROWING UP THERE IN
THE EARLY SEVENTIES AS A VERY
LITTLE GIRL THERE ARE MANY DAYS
WHEN WE COULDN'T SEE THE
MOUNTAINS WHEN I WAS IN GRADE
SCHOOL THERE WERE DAYS WHEN WE
HAD SMOG ALERTS HARD CHEST HER
WE COULDN'T PLAY OUTSIDE WE HAD
TO STAY INDOORS.
NOW WE SEE THE MOUNTAINS MORE
OFTEN WE HAVE LESS SMOG ALERTS
SO OVER THE YEARS PRIOR TO ME
EVER COMING TO THE SENATE.
PEOPLE HAVE DONE GOOD WORK TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE CLEANING UP OUR
AIR QUALITY THE PROBLEM TODAY IS
THAT THE PARTICULAR ARE MUCH
SMALLER THAN THEY USED TO BE SO
EVEN THOUGH IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S A
PRETTY DAY WE HAVE SOME OF THE
WORST AIR POLLUTION.
IN THE COUNTRY HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE FAIR ABOUT
WHO IS -- IS WHO IS BEING -- WHO
IS -- ACTUALLY MAKING SURE AIR
QUALITY IS -- IT'S CLEAN WE ALL
DO SMALL CHECKS EVERY YEAR OR
EVERY OTHER YEAR ON OUR CARS
MAYBE LONGER IF YOU HAVE A VERY
NEW CAR.
ASKING THE TRUCKERS WHO PUT CAN
POTENTIALLY -- POLLUTE THE MOST
SUBMIT THEM TO A SMOG CHECK AS
WELL WE THINK IS FAIR.
MAKING SURE THAT ARE OUT OF
STATE FOLKS THAT ARE COMING IN
AND OUT APPLIED TO THE THESE
APPLY TO THEM AS WELL WE FEELS
VERY FAIR.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT MAKING SURE
FOLKS CAN CONTINUE TO DO
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS CLEAN AIR TO
BREATHE.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- WE DRIVE
CORPS WILL -- CALL THE ROLL --
WHEN WE HAD REACH CORPSMAN THIS
ITEM AND -- I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THE YOU'RE A AMENDING
YOUR BILL AND A WILL LOOK IN THE
FUTURE ON THOSE ISSUES RAISED
HERE.
BY THE TESTIMONY IN THE PUBLIC
INPUT.
AND ARE WE RECOMMENDING WITH THE
POOL ON THE BILL WITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A CENTER HER TODD WAS
HERE.
SHE HAS -- HER BILL SP. FOUR
NINETY EIGHT THREE QUARTERS AND
PROVEN FUNDS THE GRANT PROGRAM
SHORT LINE RAILROADS.
AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
AND SHE WILL MAKE HER
PRESENTATION -- SO THIS I'M.
FOURTEEN ON OUR AGENDA CENTER
YOU HAVE THE FOR GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS -- I
PRESENT SB FOUR NINE EIGHT THE
THE SHORTLINE RAILROAD
IMPROVEMENT ACT.
A A BILL TO SUPPORT RAILROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN OUR
STATE.
OF BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED OF
PROPOSITION ONE BE EIGHTY TWENTY
BILLION BOND ACT.
THAT ACT INCLUDED TWO MILLION TO
ESTABLISH A TRADE CORRIDORS
IMPROVEMENT FUND TO ADDRESS HIGH
VOLUME OF FREIGHT MOVEMENT.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA STATE RAIL PLAN IN
BOUND AN OUT.
AND OUT BOUND AFRAID -- RAIL
TRAFFIC IN CALIFORNIA IS
EXPECTED TO INCREASE BY
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY MILLION
TONS BY.
TWENTY FORTY WITH THAT PROJECTED
GROWTH COMES INCREASES AND TRUCK
TRAFFIC AND FREIGHT BOTTLENECKS
WITH WHICH WILL RESULT IN AN
INCREASE IN EMISSIONS UNLESS
MORE IS DONE TO REHABILITATE THE
SHORTLINE RAIL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PLAN ALSO IDENTIFIED THAT WE
COULD INCREASE RELIABILITY AND
EFFICIENCY TO THE ENTIRE
STATEWIDE RAIL WOULD RAIL ROAD
NETWORK IF WE DIRECTED FUNDING
FOR IMPROVEMENTS TO EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SB FOUR NINE EIGHT BUILDS ON UP
THE PLANS RECOMMENDATION TO
INVEST IN PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND CONSTRUCTION UP PROJECTS TO
UPGRADE THE STATE WIDE SHORTLINE
RAIL ROAD NETWORK.
IMPROVING SHORTLINE
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE TRACK RAIL
AND SPURS AFFORDS LOCALIZED IN
STATEWIDE ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND
CONNECTS OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO MORE RESOURCES.
SB FOUR NINE EIGHT WILL KEEP
CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE BY
INCENTIVIZING SHORT LINE
RAILROADS TO INVEST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ABOVE AND BEYOND
THEIR CURRENT ME IN SCHEDULES
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY. TO RECEIVE
GRANT FUNDING.
WITH ME TODAY IS TRAFFIC SHOCK
ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR A CHEN CN
WYOMING AND PHILIPPE IT WENT AS
WITH THE APEX GROUP BOTH CAN.
HELP EXPLAIN SOME OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT THAT
IS IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE RAIL
PLAN.
THANK YOU CENTER -- WE HAVE THE
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
THIRD A BELL A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JEFF AND
SHAKEN I'M THE USES A VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
JANICE IN WYOMING IN OUR SIX
OBSERVE YOUR SHORT LINE
RAILROADS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TODAY I WAS
IN SUPPORT OF US BEFORE NINETY
EIGHT WANT. TO THANK CENTER HER
DAUGHTER FOR HER FOR SIDE --
WITH THIS LEGISLATION -- IN
CALIFORNIA SHORELINES OPERATOR
POSSIBLY 25% OF THE RAIL NETWORK
AND MOVE ABOUT 11% OF THE TOTAL
FOR A TRAFFIC THE SHORELINES
EXIST TO SERVE PARTS OF THE
STATE WHERE TRACK WAS HELD BY
PREVIOUS OWNERS BUT SPOT OFF DUE.
TO A LACK OF CUSTOMER VOLUME OR
INEFFICIENCY IN RAIL ROUTING AS
RESULT THE SPOT A FAST THAT
SUFFERED YEARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AND AN ACTIVE MARKETING MITCHELL
AND REAL COMPANIES LIKE THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY RAILROAD BOUGHT
THESE UNDERPERFORM BRANCH LINES
TO REVITALIZE THEM ALLOWING
RURAL CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES AND
CUSTOMERS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
ACCESS TO THE NATIONAL FREIGHT
RAIL NETWORK.
I THINK THE CALIFORNIA STATE
RAIL PLAN SAYS IT REALLY WELL ON
PAGE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
AND I QUOTE.
THE PRINCIPLE CHALLENGE THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSED IS THAT SOME
OF THE STATE'S SHORELINE
TRACKAGE CANNOT HANDLE FREIGHT
CARS WAY TO AN EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND POUNDS.
A STANDARDTHAT CLASS ONE
RAILROADS ADOPTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR OR LINE IS NOT TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
POUND CAPABLE THE COMMON
PRACTICE IS TO EITHER LOAD A
REAL CAR TO LESS THAN ITS
MAXIMUM CAPACITY.
OR TO TRANSFER THE TRANSFER THE
LOW TWO TRUCKS FOR TRANSPORT TO
A LOCATION WHERE THE RAILROAD
CAN HANDLE THE HAVE YOUR LOAD.
BUT PRACTICES UNNECESSARILY
INCREASED COSTS THROUGH THE
INEFFICIENT USE OF ASSETS THE
ADDITIONAL STEPS REQUIRED AND
THE ADDITIONAL TRAVEL TIME.
THIRTY THREE OTHER STATES.
IN THE COUNTRY HAVE PROGRAMS
DEDICATED TOWARD FUNDING
SHORTLINE RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE TO
HELP IMPROVE THE ASSETS AND KEEP
THEM AT TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND POUNDS AND ALLOW THEM
TO MOVE SAFELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
IN CALIFORNIA I THINK WE SEE
SUCH BENEFITS LIKE IMPROVED AIR
QUALITY THROUGH FEWER TRUCKS ON
THE CALIFORNIA ROADWAYS.
OF YOUR TRUCKS WAS ON LESS
ROADWAY CONGESTION AND IMPROVE
HIGHWAY SAFETY.
OF THIS BILL WOULD SERVE A
DIVERSE BASE OF AGRICULTURAL
MANUFACTURING SECTORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY THAT NEED
SHORELINES TO REACH THEIR
DESTINATION IT'LL PROVIDE
IMPROVE TRANSPORTATION
CONNECTIVITY THERE'S THE STATES
THAT ARE OFTEN RURAL AND LEFT
WITH FEW.
OPTIONS FOR GOODS MOVEMENT TO
APPRECIATE CONSIDERATION OF THIS --
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK
CHAIRMAN BILL FLEET A POINT IS
AVOCATE FOR TENNESSEE IN
WYOMING I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
COURT BATTLE AND OBVIOUSLY YOU
YOUR COMMITTEE IN YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF.
SENATOR FOR ENTERTAINING THIS
MEASURE TODAY -- I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF FOLKS
MAY HAVE BUT REALLY THIS IS A A
SIMPLE MEASURE THAT BUILT ON OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STATERAIL
PLAN IN THAT LEVERAGES ALL OF
THE STRENGTHS OF THAT PLAN WITH
SOME OF THE LOW HANGING FRUIT.
HEARING CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS A
SHORTLINE RAIL INDUSTRY AND SO
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS OF ANYBODY HAVE AS AN
OF OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR I I FORGOT TO
MENTION THAT.
MY APOLOGIES FOR THE LATE
INTRODUCTION OF OUR SUPPORT
LETTER BUT THERE'S A COALITION
OF SIXTEEN COMPANIES AND
SHIPPERS WHO -- FILED THEIR LATE
SUPPORT ALBEIT A FOR FOR THE
MEASURE IN IN YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT HOUSE THANK YOU --
WITNESSES OPPOSING THIS BILL ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSING. ONE PERSON
COME FORWARD [inaudible]
WELCOME.
AND THE OTHER [inaudible]
FOR THE COMMISSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- TO
ME CAN REPRESENT IS SAYING
YOU'RE VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS AND ALSO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS. ONE THING IS NOT
BEEN SERVED ABOUT THE BILLS WERE
ARE THE FUNDS COMING FROM.
THE BILL PROPOSES TO TAKE.
WHAT WE CALL COST SAVINGS FROM
THE? TO SHOW YOUR PROGRAM.
WHICH CURRENTLY OVER THIRTEEN
YEARS TOTAL THIRTEEN YEARS.
HAVE ROTATED BACK TO PROJECT
SPONSORS.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE WE ARE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONSENSUS GROUP.
WHICH IS MADE UP OF THE FOR
COUNTIES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN WE HAVE COST SAVINGS WHICH
WE HAVE HAD COST SAVINGS OVER
THE YEARS WE BRING IT BACK TO
OUR?
MEMBERS -- COUNTIES WHICH
INCLUDES LA.
RIVERSIDE ORANGE COUNTY IN
SEPTEMBER AND YOU KNOW.
AND UNDER THE GUIDELINES AND
UNDER STATE LAW.
WE HAVE TO USE THOSE PHONES FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED.
WITHIN OR WHO IS WHAT THEY CALL
THE SUB -- ALLOCATION REGIONS OR
NO FOUR BY STATE LAW.
HI I HAVE A OF A PARTICULAR.
SITUATION WAS.
UNSINKABLE VALLEY WHERE IF THIS
BILL IS TO PASS.
WE POTENTIALLY WILL PROBABLY
LOSE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM EXISTING THREE REASONS
WHICH WOULD IMPACT FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
SENATOR RUBIO.
THERE WOULD REALLY SUPPORT OUR
ABILITY TO DO A VERY IMPORTANT A
GRADE SEPARATION PROJECT -- IN
HER ACCOUNT AND HER JUST RIGHT
[inaudible]
ARM.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE THREE ROW
PLANNED SALES WE DON'T DISAGREE
WERE SHORT ONE RIVER ROAD.
IN THE NEW FOCUS ON EDGE WE DO
SO HAVE A MAJOR MERGER SURE
THESE FUNDS ARE COMING FROM.
CURRENTLY THE CTC IS WORKING
WITH ALL THE TO SHOW YOURSELF
SPONSORED HELD USE. TO DETERMINE
WHEN WE ARE GOING TO CUT OFF THE
TEE SHOWING OF PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW UNDER THE
GUIDELINES OF THE COMMISSION HAS
ADOPTED.
THE PROGRAM WOULD END IN JUNE OF
NEXT YEAR OR AND I WE BELIEVE
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE. TO AT
LEAST IF WE HAVE WHERE.
THE THE CITY SHE'S LOOKING AT
EXTENDING THE PROGRAM. TO JUNE
OF TWENTY TWENTY WE CHECK IF WE
WERE TO ALLOW THE CITY TO SEE
THE ABILITY TO MARKET THE POLICY.
AND DETERMINE IF TWENTY TWENTY
YEARS THAT NEW DROP DEAD DATE.
THEN WE COULD YOU KNOW.
BASICALLY IN THE TEACHER PROGRAM
IF WE HAVE COST SAVINGS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD GO AHEAD AND
RE PROGRAMMING FOR OTHER WERE
YOU PROJECTS.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR -- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- TO HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE --
PERHAPS WE CAN RESPOND TO THE
CONCERNS PEOPLE OUT ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT IS THE
MEMBERS THE COUPLE OF THINGS
YEAR EXCELLENT ANALYSIS OF
POINTS OUT THAT THE FUNDING FOR
THIS GRANT PROGRAM COMES FROM
THE CDC WITH GUIDELINES
PRESCRIBED BY THE CDC SO TO THE
CONCERNS -- AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
MEET WITH THE OPPOSITION ALBEIT
IT IT'S LATE AND I THINK IT'S
PART OF THE DEADLINE WEEK HERE
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO DISCUSS SORT
OF HOW TO MOVE FORWARD.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S CLEAR IN THE
ANALYSIS IS THAT THE CDC IS
INSTRUCTED TO COME UP WITH THE
GUIDELINES AND IF THERE ARE
ALLOCATION FORMULAS.
THAT HAVE TO BE HONORED -- EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
ALLOCATED PROGRAMMATIC SAVINGS
THEN I THINK.
WE'RE ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO IT --
BUT I I I DON'T SEE A REAL
CHALLENGE HERE -- THAT WE CAN'T
SORT OF DISCUSSES THE BILL
PROGRESSES IF THIS COMMITTEES
WILLING TO TO MOVE IT
[inaudible]
OKAY -- I THINK I THINK -- WHAT
ELSE IS LIKE? THREE QUARTERS --
A LOT OF MONEY.
IN A BILL THAT THE WE APPROVED A
FEW A YEAR OR TWO AGO.
SB.
ONE SO WE GOT A LOT WE GOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS NOW FOR TREE
QUARTERS -- BUT THE TREE QUARTER
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING DONE OR
MAYBE MORE TRUCKING ORIENTED AND
THE REAL QUARTERS.
THE PUT THE TRADE RAIL QUARTERS
OR KIND OF STEP CHILD'S.
OKAY THIS IS I'M GIVING YOU A
KIND OF A BLUNT TALK HERE.
SO SO THIS BILL.
FINDS A LITTLE PROJECTS SAVINGS
IN THE BONDS THAT WERE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX AND IT'S
NOT A LOT OF MONEY GOOD GOOD
AMOUNT.
AND IT SAYS OKAY WE TAKE THEIR
PROJECTS SAVINGS MAY WE CAN USE
THAT MONEY. TO UPGRADE
[inaudible]
THE SHORT.
THE SHORTER -- BLIND RAY RHODES
THAT EXISTS OR THE SENSUALLY.
FALLING APART BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
EVEN HOLD THE WEIGHT OF A
REGULAR TRAIN.
AND WE WANT TO FIX UP THOSE OLD
RAIL LINE SO THEY CAN BE USABLE.
FROM A TRADE QUARTER STANDPOINT.
SO I CAN I I WHEN I LOOKED AT
THIS I THOUGHT WELL THAT'S A
PRETTY LOGICAL THING IT'S NOT A
LOT OF MONEY BUT I THINK WHAT IT
WILL DO IS HELP [inaudible]
THESE -- SMALL.
SHORT LINE RAILROADS TO BE FIXED
UP SO THEY CAN BE USED.
FOR OF THE ECONOMY CALIFORNIA
BENEFIT.
YES THERE'S ALWAYS OTHER
PROJECTS THAT WE COULD FIND I
THINK WE CAN WORK WITH SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY AND WORK OUT.
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES WITH
[inaudible]
THE FUNDS THAT WE HAVE FOR TREE
QUARTERS IN GENERAL SO.
SO THAT'S WHY I THOUGHT IT WAS --
GOOD BILL IN TERMS OF USE OF THE
FUNDS SO I THOUGHT IT WAS A IT
GOES TO THEM THE REPAIR.
OF RELIANCE THAT ARE NOT IN VERY
GOOD CONDITION ESSENTIALLY.
WE NEED UPGRADING SO THEY CAN BE
USED CORRECTLY.
AND I THINK THAT'S A FAIR THING
TO DO [inaudible]
SO.
AND JUST DONE SIR DEFINING THE
PUBLIC PURPOSE IN THIS.
THIS ACT THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
VOTING ON TODAY A PUBLIC POLICY
REASON.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE PUBLIC
POLICIES.
SO OF I DON'T IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT SO WHAT I JUST SAID.
BE HAPPY TO LISTEN.
TO OKAY CENTER YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS A CLOSE.
AT THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE OKAY THANK YOU WILL
WILL TAKE UP FOR THE VOTE WHEN
THE WHEN THE COMMITTEE WHICH IS
A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. FOR THE BY.
THE REQUIRES BILL HE'S HERE.
THIS IS BE.
THREE FIFTY SIX IT'S A NORTH
COAST RAILROAD RIGHT THORLEY
RIGHT AWAY.
SB [inaudible]
FIFTY SIX AND SERRA REQUIRE YOU
PREFER TO SIT DOWN.
OKAY YEAH THAT'S QUITE ALRIGHT --
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR -- IN HIS FANTASTIC
TEAM UP FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK ON THIS
BILL THIS YEAR IN THE BILL OF
SALE SENATE BILL.
TEN TWENTY NINE LAST YEAR.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO EACH
OF YOU.
JUST TO BE ABLE TO OR IN AS
QUICKLY SINCE IT'S BEEN A WHILE
BEING FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP TO TEN
TWENTY NINE WHICH WAS THE NC ARE
A CLOSURE IN TRANSITION A TRAIL
ACT THAT WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
SINCE THE LAST TIME THAT WE'RE
IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT
MOVEMENT BUT THE GREAT REDWOOD
TRAIL AND CALIFORNIA'S NORTH
COAST.
IN THE MOMENTUM IS BUILDING WITH
THE PLANNING PROCESS KICKED OFF
IN THE FORMAL LYING DOWN IT
MEANS YOU'RE A UNDER WAY.
FUNDS HAVE BEEN SECURED WHICH IS
HELPING TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
BOTH OF THOSE ITEMS.
SB TEN TWENTY NINE SETS UP A
PROCESS TO TRANSITION THE THREE
HUNDRED PLUS MILE MOSTLY
DILAPIDATED LARGELY INOPERATIVE
RAIL LINES INTO A WORLD CLASS
TRAIL SYSTEM.
THAT RUNS THROUGH SOME OF THE
WHILE THIS AND I GOTTA TELL YOU
MOST SCENIC LANDSCAPES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE LINE IS OPERATED BY A
FUNCTIONALLY BANKRUPT PUBLIC
AGENCY THE TRACK IS LOCATED
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RUN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO BAY TO HUMBLE BAY IN
ON THE BEAUTIFUL NORTH COAST.
THIS YEAR THIS BILL WERE
INTRODUCED IS SB THREE FIFTY SIX
WHICH WILL CONTINUE IN CHERRY
SHUT DOWN BY TRANSFERRING THE
RAIL ASSETS FROM WILLITS SOUTH
TO THE CINEMA MARINE AREA RAIL
TRANSIT.
WHICH WILL CALL SMART HERE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
BOB IT'S GONNA PROVIDE FOR ONE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM MENDOCINO
COUNTY ON THE SMART BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WHICH WAS FORMED.
BY THE VOTERS IN CINEMA MARIN
COUNTY IS MANY YEARS AGO AND
RUNS A PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE.
THE LANGUAGE THAT IS IN FRONT OF
YOU TWO DAYS NEARLY IDENTICAL TO
THE LANGUAGE THAT PASSED THE
FULL SENATE UNANIMOUSLY LAST
YEAR IN SB.
TEN TWENTY NINE NOW WE DO WE
WILL -- BUT WE REMOVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY -- ONLY AFTER IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO BUY MORE
TIME TO STUDY SIGNIFICANT IN C.
R. A. DEBT WHICH IS ESTIMATED TO
BE.
SOME GOOD TIMES BETWEEN EIGHT
AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
AGAIN THE STATE HAS FUNDED THE
FORMAL AUDIT THAT WILL WIND DOWN
THE AGENCY.
NOW THAT THE DEAD STUDIES UNDER
WAY WE'RE BACK WITH THIS
LANGUAGE THE LANGUAGE IS A WIN
WIN FOR THE STATE IN THE NORTH
COAST.
THE LOCAL ECONOMIES WHO ARE
DEPENDENT ON OUTDOOR RECREATION
IN FOR LOCALS AND OUTDOOR
ENTHUSIASTS ALIKE WILL FLOCK TO
THE TRAIL TO ENJOY WORLD CLASS
HIKING AND BIKING EXPERIENCE.
WITH ME TODAY I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT WE SEE WALLICH
REPRESENTING THIS NUMBER AN AREA
RUG TRANSIT DISTRICT AND THE MAN
THE MYTH THE LEGEND FROM THE
NORTH COAST.
HUMBLE COUNTY SUPERVISOR MIKE
WILSON.
WHO IS ALSO HERE MISTER CHAIR
AND IT WILL BE OKAY WOULD LIKE
TO TURN OVER TO THE TWO
WITNESSES?
WITH THE GODDESS TRAVEL THE FOR
THE SERVICE THE FIRST HIDING.
THE MOBILE COUNTY.
SIR THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME
TODAY -- MY NAME IS MICHAEL
SOMETIME THIRD DISTRICT --
COUPLE COUNTY SUPERVISOR
REPRESENT MOSTLY WHAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER THE ARCADE AREA THE
NORTH BAY -- FROM ON ALL DAY --
WHERE BASICALLY THE TERMINUS OF
THE NORTH TERMINUS OF WHAT WOULD
BE THE GREAT RIVER TRAIL?
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE GREAT
ROAD TRAIL ALLIANCE -- COALITION
OF OF TRAIL INTO CS AND A
PARTNERS THAT -- THROUGH ALL
THOSE COUNTIES WHICH IS MARIN --
CINEMA MENDOCINO AND HUMBLE
COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO BEAR WITNESS
THAT WE SEEN VERY POSITIVE
RESULTS FROM THE PASSAGE OF SB
TEN TWENTY NINE ALREADY -- WELL --
THE ESTEEMED.
MISTER MCGUIRE HERE CENTER
MCGUIRE TALKS ABOUT THE GRAND
VISION OF THE CONNECTIVE ITTY
BETWEEN THIS TO BASS I WILL SAY
THAT TIME THE CONNECTIVITY
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES HAS ALREADY
STARTED ON SO MANY LEVELS AND
THAT WAY -- WE SEEN A REAL
UPTAKE IN TERMS OF PROJECTS THAT
ARE ALREADY UNDER WAY THAT ARE
CONNECTING ARCADED TO EUREKA
EUREKA BEYOND WILL LISTEN. TO
THOSE SOAKED INTO THEIR
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES AND THIS
IS A REAL ASSET.
AND I BELIEVE THAT -- MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS ALLOWING SMART --
TOO AND LEVERAGE ASSETS IN TERMS
OF THE STUDIES AS WELL AS HAVING
A TRAIL MANAGER AS PART OF THIS
WILL REALLY HELP -- ELEVATE
THOSE PROJECTS -- AT LEAST FOR
THAT SECTION IN FLOW FOR THAT I
OFFER SUPPORT.
AS OTHER WITNESSES.
A STEVE ALL CURE ME OF THIS
NUMBER AND EVERY REAL TRANSIT
DISTRICTS MARKED -- WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS BILL WAS
FOR THE LAST YEAR -- THIS
MEASURE CONTAINS A LOT OF THIS
PERSON PROVISIONS THAT CLEAN UP --
SOME OF SPORTS AUTHORIZING
STATUTE YOU'RE SMART IT OPERATES
RAIL SERVICE RIGHT NOW FROM THE
US SANTA ROSA.
DOWN THE CENTER FELL -- BY THE
END OF THE YEAR WILL HAVE
SERVICE ALI DOWN TO LARKSPUR AND
DRUG CONNECTIONS THE BERRY FERRY --
THE GOING TO FERRY SERVICE --
WERE ALSO CONCURRENTLY WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON SERVICE
EXTENDING IN NORTH FROM -- AT
THAT SANTA ROSA -- TO WINDSOR IN
HEALDSBURG EVENTUALLY CLOVERDALE --
THIS BILL WOULD.
POTENTIALLY YEAH I HAVE THAT
PROVE THAT QUARTER ALWAYS TO
WILL IT'S SO WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE SENATOR AND THEN THE
WHOLE PROCESS OF WINDING DOWN
THE NORTH COAST RAILROAD.
IN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST
AVENUE FORWARD -- IN PRESERVING
THIS THIS -- RAIL CORRIDOR SO
THEREFORE WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- PLEASE OTHER
WITNESSESTESTIFIED.
VERY GOOD A MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DUCK HOUSTON
REPRESENTING CINEMA COUNTY
REGIONAL PARK AGENCY AS WELL AS
THE SEC.
BIG THE SAVE THE REDWOODS UP
BOTH IN SUPPORT X..
CATHERINE GARCIA WITHSIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
SO CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRING RC ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OKAY -- TO HAVE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL ANY OPPOSITION --
QUESTIONS.
SO REGARDING HAVE A CLOSING
STATEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK OVER
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
SECURED THIS YEAR TO BE A
CONNECTIVE SEGMENTS OF THE GOOD
SUPERVISORS TALK ABOUT FROM
HUMBLE COUNTY.
I AND WE LOOK FOR TO THE
ADVANCED INDUSTRIAL MASTER PLAN --
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR THIS YEAR
AND THAT FINAL ON IT WILL BE
DELIVERED BY JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YOU DOWN THE AGENCY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTED
THE MOST APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THE THE COMPLETION A
TRAIL OF THE A THE STATE WHERE
JIM.
OF SIGNIFICANCE.
SO -- IS TOTALLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE HARD WORK YOU PUT IN FOR
DECADES IN.
THOSE COUNTIES COMPLETED.
OF KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK AND
WILL BE SUPPORTING OF OF YOU.
IN YOUR EFFORTS AND TAKE THE
WORD BACK THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT YOUR COMPLETION OF THAT
TRAIL THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
US.
I WILL DO THAT.
HE'S EMISSIONS CHAIR
[inaudible]
OF WHAT'S THE CEILING TO FIND
SOME AUTHORS.
THE PRESENT BILL WE HAVE WE'RE
DOWN. TO ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX SEVEN SEVEN AUTHORS.
IT'S WATER STONE HERE
. ZERO HAS
ITEM OF TWENTY WHICH IS SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO AND WELCOME CENTER TO
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE YOU
AT THE FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT I MISS CHAIR.
SO -- THAT SB.
SEVEN FORTY TWO REMOVES THE
PROHIBITIONS IN CALIFORNIA LAW.
THAT CURRENTLY HAMSTRING AND
IMPORTANT NETWORK OF PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED INNER CITY BUSES.
FROM OPEN THE COMPETING FOR
WRITERS WITH PRIVATE. FOR PROFIT
BUS OPERATORS YOU WILL SPUR
GREATER COMPETITION THE MOCHA
OPEN MARKET PLACE.
AND HELP GOVERNMENT SPEND
TAXPAYER MONEY MORE EFFICIENTLY
SO JUST GIVE A LITTLE BACKGROUND
CITY CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SPEND BILLIONS OF
TAX DOLLARS.
EVERY YEAR ON TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ARRAY OF
TRANSIT TRANSPORTATION SERVICES.
TO INCREASE THE MOBILITY OF A
RESIDENCE IN SIR AND VISITORS.
BUT SOME OF THAT TAX MONEY IS
USED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
REGIONAL JOINT POWER AUTHORITIES
TO OPERATE MAINTAIN AND ENHANCE.
INTERCITY PASSENGER RAIL
QUARTERS AT SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT.
A LOT THIS COMMITTEE.
AND YOUR COURSE ONLY A CERTAIN
PORTION THE STATE IS A COVERED
BY RAIL -- AND IN FACT THERE'S A
LOT OF MAJOR GAPS IN THE SYSTEM.
SO WE NEED TO HAVE CORRIDORS
THAT ARE THEN BOLSTERED BY A
LARGE NETWORK OF THROUGH A BUSES.
THE BRANCH OUT FROM RAIL
STATIONS TO CONNECT WRITERS TO
OVER TWO FIFTY POUNDS
COMMUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND EVEN
INTO NEVADA AND TO GIVE ME AN
IDEA TO GET.
FROM LA TO SACRAMENTO THE
FASTEST WAY THROUGH RAN TRACK IS
TO TAKE A BUS. TO OVER THE OVER
THE THE THE THE PAST TO
BAKERSFIELD MEN HOP ON THE TRAIN
THAT GOES UP -- THE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I'M A SIMILAR YOU KNOW IN
IN IN THAT CENTER STONE'S
DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE -- YOU MAY
WANT TO TAKE A YOU KNOW THE
TRAINTHAT GOES EAST ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
ARE THEN THE B. BUS CONNECTIONS
THAT WILL YOU KNOW WILL TAKE OFF
FROM PONDERING STATION FOR
EXAMPLE. TO ALLOW FOR A LITTLE
MORE ACCESS.
AND SO COLLECTIVELY THESE
RAILWAYS AND BUSES TOGETHER
PROVIDE A RELIABLE AFFORDABLE
TRAVEL OPTIONS NOT SIMPLY
BETWEEN URBAN HUBS BUT ALSO TO
MANY OUT OF THE WAY.
MORE RURAL COMMUNITIES HERE'S
THE PROBLEM TWENTY YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA NOT TO LEGISLATION.
SPONSORED BY A PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT BUS COMPANY WHO ARGUED
THAT IT NEEDS PROTECTION.
AGAINST COMPETITION FROM A
NUMBER YOU KNOW FROM FROM --
FROM -- THESE AMTRAK BUSES IN AS
A RESULT THERE'S A STATE BAN
MODELED AFTER -- THAT BASICALLY
PROHIBITS PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED
REAL THROUGH A BUSES FROM
SELLING TICKETS TO ANY PASSENGER.
UNLESS YOU'RE SHE EITHER ROAD ON
A TRAIN BEFORE CATCHING THAT BUS
OR IS WRITING ON THAT BUS TO
CATCH A TRAIN.
HOW YOU KNOW HERE'S THE STORY I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE EVER
WRITTEN ON AN AMTRAK THRUWAY BUS
BEFORE BUT SOMETIMES ESPECIALLY
AT THE BEGINNING OR THE END OF
THEIR ROUTE?
THERE ARE VERY FEW PEOPLE ON THE
BUS.
AND YOU KNOW EVEN IF THE BUS
STARTS A ROUTE FROM A TRAIN
STATION WITH ALL THE SEATS
OCCUPIED AS A TRAVELS FROM ONE
COMMUNITY TO ANOTHER.
IT OFTEN GETS COOKING I AM DEAR
AND I'M HERE AND HOUSE A GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY TO FOR BID.
THAT AMTRAK THRUWAY BUS OR OTHER
JOINT POWER AUTHORITIES FROM
ADVERTISING IN SELLING TICKETS
TO KEEP THOSE SEATS FILLED TO
THE BUSES THEMSELVES TO COST.
LESS PUBLIC MONEY TO OPERATE IN
YOU HAVE LESS PEOPLE ON THE
ROADS THE BUSES RUNNING ANYWAY --
HE WE WE MIGHT AS WELL ALLOW
THAT BLESSED TO BE ABLE TO SELL
TICKETS.
HI YOU KNOW SO SO THAT'S MY
STRONG FEELING I AND AND YOU
KNOW I I REALLY YEAH IF I'VE
NEVER QUITE UNDERSTOOD THIS
UNTIL I FOUND OUT BUT WHY.
I'M GETTING THIS HOPEFULLY AND
WE'RE GONNA GET THIS ADDRESSED
THROUGH THROUGH SB SEVEN FORTY
TWO AND I VERY MUCH -- YOU KNOW
I I I I I THINK THIS IS A IS A
SMART WAY OF ADDRESSING A
PROBLEM IN OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IN WITH ME TO SUPPORT.
THIS BILL -- WE HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES DAN LEVIN WHOSE
MANAGER REGIONAL INITIATIVES FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY ALSO DUG.
FOR REPRESENTING REAL PACK --
THE REAL PASSENGERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA BATTERY OF SOME OTHER
FOLKS TO ORGAN INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES.
JUNE CHAIR BELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MONIES CAN LET THAT.
ARE PERCENT BOTH THE SAN JOAQUIN
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY AND THE
CENTRAL BY WELL WORKING GROUP'S.
SO CAN JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY IS
THE MANAGING AGENCIES FOR THE
AMTRAK TELL TEENS INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE.
AND SUCH A VIRAL WORKING GROUP
IS A TWENTY AGENCY WORKING GROUP
THAT INCLUDES ALL THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
REGIONAL REAL OPERATORS COUNTY
IS A MAJOR CITIES BETWEEN
SACRAMENTO AND MERCED.
SB SEVEN FORTY TWO PROPOSES TO
AMEND -- IN AND ENABLE STATE
FUNDED AMTRAK OPERATED INTERCITY
RAIL SERVICES THE SAN JOAQUIN'S
KAPPLE CORRIDOR AND THE PACIFIC
SURFLINER TO PICK UP AND DROP
OFF PASSENGERS ON THEIR AMTRAK
INTERCITY THROUGH A BUSES.
WITHOUT REQUIRING PASTORS HAVE A
REAL TRIP IS PART OF THE TICKET.
THIS BILL IS A RARE OPPORTUNITY
FOR AT NO ADDITIONAL COST THE
RESULT IN REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IMPROVED AIR QUALITY.
REDUCE CONGESTION ON THE
HIGHWAYS PROVIDE INTERCITY
SERVICE TO DISADVANTAGED AND
UNDERSERVED RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
INCREASE REVENUE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MOST THE SERVICES PROVIDED BY
PRIVATE INNER CITY BUS OPERATORS
CALIFORNIA.
FOCUS ON ROUTES BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA'S MAJOR CITIES WITH
LIMITED INTERMEDIATE STOPS. FOR
THESE MARKETS PRIVATE INTERCITY
BUS OPERATORS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ALREADY COMPETING WITH STATE
SUPPORTED INTERCITY RAIL AND BUS
SERVICES SINCE A TRAIN TRIP IS
PART OF THE AMTRAK.
TICKET FOR THESE MARKETS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE STATE
SUPPORTED AMTRAK THREE BUS
ROUTES WILL BE POSITIVELY
IMPACTED BY SB SEVEN FORTY TWO
ARE CONTRACTED OUT TO PRIVATE
OPERATORS.
AND THAT SB SEVEN FORTY TWO IS
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW
SINCE CALIFORNIA INTERCITY RAIL
SERVICES IN ASSOCIATE THROUGH A
BUSES ARE PREDOMINATELY
SUBSIDIZED BY THE STATE.
IS GOOD GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC
POLICY TO BEST UTILIZE STATE
INVESTMENT FROM TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS AND ON BEHALF OF SOAKING
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY THE
CENTER BY REAL WORKING GROUP WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
[inaudible]
OTHERS SPEAKERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BILL
MEMBERS AS A TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
HI I AM DOUG KERR OF HEALDSBURG.
REPRESENTING REAL PACKED THE
REAL PASSENGERS SOCIAIS TION OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE REAL PACK FIRST OF ALL LIKE
TO THANK A CHAIRMAN THEY'LL FOR
IS CONTINUING SUPPORT FOR
PASSENGER RAIL.
REAL PACKS SUPPORTS SB.
SEVEN FORTY TWO AMENDING
PROVISIONS REQUIRING PURCHASE OF
AN AMTRAK BUS TICKET WITH THE
TRAIN TICKET.
I WILL GIVE TO THE MANY EXAMPLES
OF WHY SEVEN FORTY TWO IS NEEDED.
THE SAN JOAQUIN CORDER OPERATE
SAM TRACKS THROUGH A BUS SERVICE
FROM EUREKA ARCADIA TO MARTINEZ.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE SERVICE
FROM THE NORTH CONNECT WITH THE
SMART TRAIN IN SANTA ROSA
PROVIDING CAPABILITY. FOR OUR
NORTH COAST NEIGHBORS TO REACH
ROHNERT PARK CA TIDY PETALUMA
AND NEVADO CITIES NOT SERVED BY
A PRIVATE BUS OPERATORS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS
CONNECTION IS NOT POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF THROUGH A BUS TICKET
BETWEEN THE NORTH COAST CITIES
AND SANTA ROSA IS NOT LINKED TO
AN AMTRAK TICKET.
AMTRAK TRAIN TICKET.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE I LIVE IN HILLS
BIRD CINEMA COUNTY.
LET'S SAY I WANT TO GO TO FOR
TUNA IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
THE AMTRAK THREE BUSES SERVE
BOTH CITIES BUT CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITS ME FROM USING THEM.
PRIVATE BUS OPERATORS ABANDONED
SERVICE TO BOTH CITIES YEARS AGO.
THE ONLY WAY FOR ME TO TRAVEL TO
FOR TUNA IS BY AUTOMOBILE.
CURRENT LAW PROTECTS PRIVATE
OPERATIONS THAT OFTEN DO NOT
EXIST.
IN FACT ALMOST 60% OF THE STOPS
SERVED BY CALIFORNIA THROUGH A
BUSES ARE NOT SERVED BY PRIVATE
OPERATORS.
SB SEVEN FORTY TWO WILL CORRECT
THESE ISSUES ALLOW FULL USE OF
THE THROUGH A BUS SERVICES.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
TRANSIT CONNECTIONS IN REDUCE
AUTOMOBILE USE.
REAL PACK URGES PASSAGE OF SB.
SEVEN FORTY TWO OTHER WITNESSES --
THIS IS A HERE TO ALREADY SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIDGE
BECAUSE KOREAN BEHALF OF THE SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY ASSOCIATION
A GOVERNMENT'S TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY.
OF MARIE COUNTY AND STENCILS
COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT
FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED BY
THE AUTHOR AND THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS.
JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CAPITOL CORRIDOR JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY THE AMTRAK LINE THAT
RUNS FROM AUBURN TO SAN JOSE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE.
YEAH IN FAVOR.
OUR YOUR POST.
OKAY SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF RIGHT
BEHIND YOU SAYS.
YEAH GO AHEAD THANK YOU AGAIN
MIKE WILSON HUMBLE COUNTY
SUPERVISOR THE TERMINUS OF THAT.
BUS LINE THE AMTRAK BUS LINE
THAT WAS JUST MENTION.
FULL HEARTEDLY IN FAVOR OF THIS
I WILL BE TAKING THIS BACK TO MY
BOARD SUPERVISORS.
FOR A NICE YOU QUESTION YES SIR.
DID YOU HAVE PRIVATE OR PUBLIC
BUSES GOING TO AND FROM
[inaudible]
HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
WE HAVE PUBLIC BUS SERVICE GOING
EAST -- BUT IT TAKES THREE BUSES
TO GET TO READING AND THEN IF
YOU'RE GOING SOUTH -- WE ALSO
HAVE -- WE HAVE GREYHOUND BUS
SERVICE -- BUT IT'S ABOUT UP TO
OREGON.
WE HAVE NOTHING GOING NORTH.
OKAY SO YOU HAVE NOTHING GOING
TO OREGON NOW NOW -- AND THIS
WITH THIS -- FLEXIBILITY IN THE
AMTRAK SERVICE WOULD GREATLY
HELP -- OUR TRANSPORTATION NEEDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JERRY MCGUIRE JUST AS THE YOU
CAN GET THE DOWN OR DOWNLOAD HAS
A SHOULD THE DOWNWARD SINCE
THEIR BUS DOWN TO HUMBLE -- I
THINK IT'S ONCE A DAY BUT THEN
YOU'RE STUCK.
IN CRESCENT CITY CAN'T GET UP.
TO DEL MAR.
IT IS OBVIOUS RESIDENCIA EXACTLY
SPECIALLY IF LAST CHANCE GREAT
CLOSES DOWN -- WHICH IT HAS --
FOUR TIMES THIS YEAR YEAH GO
NORTH OF CRESCENT CITY.
HAVE WE ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO KEEP
THEIR SALES TAX IN CALIFORNIA.
WELL I WAS I WAS SICK AND OF A
MAJOR STATE FACILITY UP THERE
YEAH YES THAT DAY IT'S A VERY
POPULAR -- FACILITY -- AND AS
I'VE BEEN TOLD BY THE CHAIR HE'S
TOOK ITS WALKING.
STREET STORY TOOK HIS WIFE TO
PELICAN BAY -- AS PART AS A
VACATION TWO YEARS AGO SO -- NO
I DID NOT SHE REFUSE -- THAT'S
NOT RIGHT EITHER YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT IF I MAY IF I
MAY ADD THAT THE CONNECTION TO
THE NORTH BAY REALLY IS
CULTURALLY CONNECTION FOR US.
WHERE IS RIGHT NOW THE AMTRAK US
GOES TO MARTINEZ AND THEN IF YOU
WANT TO GO TO SAN FRANCISCO YES
WE ARE?
THANKS OKAY THAT'S THE I THINK.
THIS YOU CAN A YOU CAN SEE HOW
THAT WOULD APPLY TO A LOT OF
READING AND ALL THESE OTHER
[inaudible]
PLACES -- THE AMTRAK TRAINS GO
OKAY -- WILL SPEAK -- AGAINST
THE BILL SPEAKERS AGAINST YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH CON
AND BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BUS
ASSOCIATION.
THE ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN IN THE
THE FIFTY YEAR.
LIGHTNING ROD FOR SAFETY AND
PROFESSIONALISM IN THE STATE.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT.
THE ASSOCIATION HAS NO PROBLEM
WITH AMTRAK EXPANDING THEIR
SERVICE AS WAS JUST SPOKEN ABOUT
UP IN THE NORTH COAST.
THAT'S PART OF WHAT AMTRAK
SHOULD DO AND WE SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF CONNECTING TO RAIL
SERVICE.
HI THE BILL THOUGH IN BRIEF --
DOES BASICALLY SOMETHING THAT WE
CANNOT SUPPORT AND THAT IS IT
SETS A SYSTEM UP -- PROVIDING
TAXPAYER FUNDS TO COMPETE
AGAINST TAX PAYNE BUS COMPANIES.
HI. TWO THINGS ARE HAPPENING
HERE ONE IS THAT THE FEEDER BUS
SYSTEM FOR AMTRAK AND TO IS THE
BILL AS ALLOWING DISTRICTS TO
ENTER THIS MARKET PLACE.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS PRETTY
SIMPLE ALL GIVE YOU JUST THREE
REASONS SENATOR AND MEMBERS --
ONE IS -- THOSE TRANSIT
DISTRICTS ARE TAX EXEMPT SO THAT
MEANS THAT PRIVATE COMPANIES NOT
IN THIS.
AREA.
HAVE TO PAY ALL THE FEDERAL
STATE AND ESTATE SALES TAX
INCLUDING I PERSONALLY SUPPORT
ADDRESS BE ONE MANY BUS
COMPANIES SUPPORT SB.
ONE NOW THOSE FUNDS ARE GOING TO
BE USED AGAINST PRIVATE
COMPANIES A AND E'S SUBSIDIZED
WAY.
HI THE FEDERAL TAX EXEMPTION IS
SEVEN CENTS THE STATE -- TAX
EXEMPTION IS THIRTY SIX CENTS
THE ESTATE SALES TAX EXEMPTION
IS THIRTY ONE CENTS.
NUMBER TWO POINT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A SENATOR -- AND MEMBERS --
THE UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA AND
LOCAL MONIES SUBSIDIZE --
TRANSIT OPERATIONS WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT 7280% OF THE
OVERALL OPERATION COSTS OF THOSE
TRANSIT DISTRICTS -- ARE ARE
SUBSIDIZED BY OUR TAX DOLLARS.
WITHIN THE SUBSIDY A SUBSIDY SIR
TAXPAYER FUNDS FOR CLEAN
VEHICLES AS THE PRIVATE SECTOR --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH CARP TO
CLEAN OUR FLEETS EACH ONE OF OUR
OUR COACHES COST ABOUT A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS NOW.
HI SO AND WE'VE HAD TO UPGRADE
OUR FLEETS TO COMPORT OURSELVES
WITH THE THE AIR STANDARDS THAT
ARE THAT WE HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
FOR FEDERAL LAW PURPOSES IN THE
CLEAN AIR ACT.
THE THIRD PIECE IS RIGHT NOW
MEMBERS THERE IS A VIBRANT
PRIVATE INDUSTRY IN THIS SECTOR.
THE VIBRANT PRIVATE INDUSTRY IS
UPWARDS OF TWENTY DIFFERENT
COMPANIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT OPERATE PRIVATELY WITHOUT
SUBSIDY WITHOUT THE SUBSIDIES
THAT I'VE NAMES.
AND WITHOUT THE SUBSIDIES THAT
ACTUALLY HI.
BASICALLY FREE EQUIPMENT AND AND
CAPITAL COSTS TO OPERATE.
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU -- BUT WE
ARE.
IN OPPOSITION WOULD URGE YOUR NO
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE -- OKAY
LET'S HEAR IF THERE'S OTHER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ANYBODY ELSE ARE.
I SER HAD A QUESTION -- THE
PRIVATE OPERATORS SAW.
WORK WITH THE PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES HAVE WORKED WITH THE
PUBLIC AT TRANSIT AGENCIES YES
AT A COOPERATIVE MANNER YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY IN CALIFORNIA SIR
IN CERTAIN SENT AND CERTAIN
AREAS YES PRIVATE OPERATORS TO
AND IN FACT PRIVATE OPERATORS IN
THE AMTRAK SYSTEM YES.
THOSE ARE MEMBERS OF OURS ROD
BUT THEY ARE EXEMPT FROM IN
THOSE TAXES WHEN HEY WERE --
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES HAVE BILLED
SO.
BUS TERMINALS CONSTRUCTED THOSE
BUS TERMINALS ENCOURAGE.
INTER CONNECTIONS WITH THE BUS
TERMINALS FROM THE TRANSIT
SYSTEMS.
OF SO THAT.
THAT.
IS THE KIND OF RELATIONSHIP
THAT'S A POSITIVE THING FOR
PRIVATE OPERATORS CORRECT.
SO THAT'S THAT SO.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE YOU KNOW LIKE
WE'RE BUILDING BUS TERMINALS IN
SAN JOSE OR LIKE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE ONE RIGHT --
WHILE THE MEGA BUS OPERATES OUT
OF THE SIXTY FIFTH STREET JOSH
AND YEAH THE BUS THAT GOES FROM
RENO TO SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO TO
SAN FRANCISCO YEAH YEAH SO IT IT
IT KIND OF THERE IS -- SO THE
QUESTION.
FOR MAYBE -- SIR ALAN.
IS WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO USE.
PUBLIC.
SYSTEMS BUT ALSO PRIVATE SYSTEM
HOW.
TO HELLO HOW HOW DID YOU -- HOW
DO YOU FEEL YOUR BILL ANSWERS
THAT QUESTION?
YEAH SO THIS.
PORTANTINO SO RECENTLY THIS BILL
JUST RELATES. TO THE THE BUSES
THAT DATE THE X. CONNECT TO AND
SERVE THE RAIL SYSTEM.
SO I IT DOESN'T SUPPLANT THE
RAIL SYSTEM SO ANYTHING THAT SO
SO THE THE THE BIG ROUTES
BETWEEN SAN DIEGO AND LOS
ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT THE PRIVATE BUSES ARE
INVOLVING THE PRIVATE BUSES ARE
INVOLVED IN IN SERVING THAT THE
BIG CITY DID BIG CITY ROUTES.
AND AT MOST OF THOSE ARE SERVED
BY RAIL ALREADY -- WHAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO DO IS IS -- TO
PROVIDE FOR A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO THOSEBUSES THAT
CONNECT UP TO THE EXISTING RAIL
SYSTEM -- AND IN A LOT OF RURAL
AREAS FOR EXAMPLE AS WE HEARD
FROM OUR FRIEND FROM THE NORTH
COAST -- THAT IT'S ACTUALLY ONE
OF THE ONLY YOU KNOW.
MAJOR TYPES OF OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AVAILABLE ARE YOU
THAT THE THE PRIVATE FOLKS
SERVED ARE PROVIDING AN IMP
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SERVICE BUT
THEY ONLY PROVIDE SERVICE.
TO THOSE ARE RUDE SAID OUR MOST
PROFITABLE FOR FOR GOOD REASON.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
FOR GONNA BE RUNNING BUSES WHICH
WE DO BECAUSE WE WANT TO SERVE
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE -- UP AND
DOWN AREAS WHERE THERE MAY NOT
BE THE SAME KIND OF TRAFFIC --
YOU KNOW ON THE NORTH COAST IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE WE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ACTUALLY
FILLING OUT THOSE BUSES.
AT B. THE BUSES ARE RUNNING
ANYWAY WE MIGHT AS WELL GET THEM
FILLED AND SO THAT THAT'S ALL
WE'RE DOING HERE WE'RE NOT
SUPPLANTING THE THE THE MAJOR IN
A RAIL -- INTERCITY RAIL SYSTEM --
YOU KNOW THE MEGA BUS WILL
CONTINUE TO COMPETE WITH THE
RAIL SERVICE.
AND WILL DO SO VERY
COMPETITIVELY EFFECTIVELY -- SUB.
THAT'S ALL THAT THE BILL SEEKS
TO DO IT'S NOT ACT A KIND OF
MASSIVE CHALLENGE TO PRIVATE
BUSES IN UFC RIGHT WE DO OE OUT
PEOPLE ON ON ALL FORMS OF PUBLIC
REGISTRY CLEANING YEAH.
PRIVATELY RUN PUBLIC EDUCATION --
WHEN WE DID SB [inaudible]
ONE WE CORRECT YOU'RE CORRECT WE
WHAT WE DID IS WE SET UP A FUND
FOR THE FIRST TIME. FOR INTER
CITY RAIL IT -- COMMUTER REAL.
FUNDED BY THE STATE TRANSIT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SO WE SET UP
[inaudible]
A FUNDING MECHANISM SP ONE FROM
THE STATE AND TRANSIT TO FIND
THE THE TREND THE REAL TRANSIT --
AUTHORITIES LIKE YOUR ONE IN SAN
JOAQUIN -- THE SMART -- THE
OTHER ONES.
CALTRAIN -- YOU KNOW THOSE
SERVICE.
AND NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUSES.
AND THE QUESTION THE QUESTION
WOULD BE -- I THINK YOU MAY BE
DONE MAYBE.
SERVICE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS BUT I THINK WE NEED
[inaudible]
TO INCLUDE.
SB INCLUSIVE NOT EXCLUSIVE SO WE
STATE WE NEED TO INCLUDE.
THE BUSES YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BUT ALSO WE SHOULD WORK WITH THE
PRIVATE BUSES. TO TALK ABOUT HOW
TO BETTER FACILITATE -- THE BUS
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA -- TO
ENCOURAGE BUSES BECAUSE BUSES.
HELP REDUCE POLLUTION.
THEY HELP THOUGH THAT'S PART OF
OUR GOAL.
AND MORE PEOPLE RIDING THE BUSES
IS GOOD THANK MY OPINION.
SO -- IN TERMS OF THE PLANNING
THAT THAT WE DO -- FOR INNER
CITY [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA PLANNINGWE NEED TO
INCLUDE SOME KIND OF WAY OF
HAVING BUSES INCLUDE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN OF THE STATE.
I MISSED NO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO WORK ON
OKAY ALL AGES FOR WE HOPE YOU
AGREE WITH THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU -- MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND NOT IN THE PLAN RIGHT NOW
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A STATE RAIL
PLAN WE HAVE A RIGHT.
THE MASTER PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION.
SHOULD INCLUDE BUSES THESE
INTERCONNECTIONS THESE BUS
BRIDGES.
EURO SERVING ALL THE COMMUNITIES.
THE DON'T HOUSE PUBLIC SERVICE
INNER CITY SERVICE I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
SO I I THINK THAT SOME NOT BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
I MEAN SURROUND BROKE BROACH THE
SUBJECT I THINK WE CAN WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS HERE.
AND WORK ON THAT TO CONTINUE
PRESS ONE OF THINGS ALL SAY THIS.
IS I KNOW THAT THE RAIL SYSTEM
BENEFITS FROM THE PRIVATE BUSES.
BECAUSE THEY DROPPED PASSENGERS
OFFICE DOES RAIL STATIONS AND
PEOPLE GET OFF THOSE.
PRIVATE BUSES AND THEY GET ON
THE REAL LINES YES AND SO THAT
THAT'S A BENEFIT TO THE A RAIL
SYSTEM AS WELL.
WORKING TOGETHER BOTH BENEFIT
FROM EACH OTHER.
SO THE INTER CONNECTED WITH THE
BENEFITS WE WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND SENATOR ALLEN
ON THAT MR CHAIRMAN I THINK.
MISSION OF CLARIFICATION THOUGH
IT SEEMS LIKE CENTER ALLEN IS ST.
THAT HI HE HE HE ISN'T TRYING TO
GET DISTRICTS INVOLVED IN THE
PRIVATE WORK.
THAT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT'S HAPPENING.
AND SO IF CENTER ALLEN WOULD
WOULD LIKE TO WORK ON THAT AS
WELL AS YOUR RECOMMENDATION
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE WOULD THAT WE
WOULD WELCOME THAT THANK YOU.
BECAUSE WE WE DO.
WE CAN'T OUR OUR CLIENTS OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES CAN'T COMPETE
AGAINST 80% -- SUBSIDIES NO
TAXES ON FUEL WE THEY JUST CAN'T
DO IT RIGHT NO DIFFERENT THAN I
REALLY CAN'T COMPETE AGAINST IN
THIS FORM AGAIN CENTER ALLEN AND
HIS LEGISLATION.
ALL GRANT HIM THAT.
BECAUSE HE'S A WERE THE FOR THE
MEMBER AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND AND SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU OF SOME REQUIRE.
THANK YOU VERY QUICKLY TO CHAIR
AT JUST WANT TO TAKE YOU TO THE
CENTER FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
LOOK BOTTOM LINE IS COMMONSENSE
APPROACH -- IN ESPECIALLY FOR
RURAL CALIFORNIA GIVEN EXAMPLE
IF YOU ARE HAVING TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO SAN FRANCISCO TO ARCADIA.
YOU TRAVEL FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
SANTA ROSA YOU PUT IT VERY WELL
COULD POTENTIALLY SWITCH OR GAIN
PASSENGERS AND YOU GO TO SANTA
ROSA TO UKIAH.
WHEN YOU GO TO YOUKAI AT TO
ARCADIA IN WHAT SHOULD BE A FOUR
HOUR ISRAELI DOUBLE THE TIME TO
BE ABLE TO GET?
UP THE NORTH COAST.
IN WHAT WE KNOW IS RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE VERY FEW SEATS IN MANY
ON OF THESE ROUTES THAT ARE
TAKEN.
AND IF THERE IS AN ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY INTO
THE SYSTEM.
IT JUST MAKES SENSE I APPRECIATE.
THE GOOD CENTER FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S THAT
I THINK COMPETITION IS GOOD
YOU'RE ABLE TO FILL IN THE SEATS --
AND IT'S GONNA BE MORE
CONVENIENT ESPECIALLY. FOR THOSE
WHO LIVE IN SOME OF THE MOST
RURAL AREAS IN HER CHALLENGED --
TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK HOME AND
ALSO HELPS THOSE WHO ARE.
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
DAD WHO REALLY NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO TRAVEL IN A WAY THAT IS
ECONOMIC FOR THEIR FAMILY SO DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE CENTER YOU
HAVE A CLOSE STATEMENT YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
EVERYBODY AND AND AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY BY
OUR FRIENDS FROM THE PRIVATE BUS.
INDUSTRY THE WHAT THE WHY ONE I
GUESS MY ONE PUSH BACK IS.
WHEN AND AND THE CHAIR KNOWS A
LOT MORE ABOUT SB ONE THAN I DO
BUT -- BUT ARE FINDING WENT INTO --
INTO THE INTO GROWING THE RAIL
INFRASTRUCTURE YEAH AND THE
TRANSIT INFRASTRUCTURE NOT --
YES SUBSIDIZING -- THROUGH A
BUSES THE SP ONE FINDS.
I AM SO.
SO I I A A ALABAMA A ONE PUSH
BACK ON THAT BUT I THINK THE
GENERAL BAR TEN HERE IS TO JUST.
YOU KNOW ADDRESS THE THE IN A
GROTESQUE -- SITUATION WHERE
WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW TREAT YOUR
BUSES THAT ARE YOU KNOW
CONNECTING PEOPLE TO OUR
IMPORTANT RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE WE
WANT PEOPLE TO CLEAN RURAL AREAS
THAT ARE FAR FROM -- TRAIN
STATIONS AND OTHER FORMS
TRANSPORTATION TO ACCESS THE
AMTRAK NETWORK AND YET IT'S JUST
CRAZY THAT WE HAVE YOU KNOW
THESE BUSES THAT ARE RUNNING
WITH ONE PERSON ON THE IS ON THE
BUS FOR HOURS AND HOURS JUST
BECAUSE BECAUSE WE WANT YOU KNOW
AND THEN AND AND THEN.
THERE THE BUSES ARE STOPPING IN
IN IN IN GOING ALSO DIFFERENT
CITIES AND IF WE CAN SELL
TICKETS BETWEEN THOSE CITIES WE
REALLY OUGHT TO AND SO.
I I I ABSOLUTELY WITH THE CHAIR
WHEN WE SEE THAT THE PRIVATE BUS
SYSTEM IS IN AS AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF OUR BROADER
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK AND HAPPY.
TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU AND TALK
SHOP ABOUT HOW WE CAN -- WE CAN
WE CAN MEET OUR MUTUAL GOALS
WITH THIS BILL AND SO -- THEM
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION EDU THANKS FOR A VOTE --
OKAY CENTER -- WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL ON THIS BOAT.
WHEN WE REACH MORE OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU BETTER HERTZBERG IS --
MOMENTARILY EXPECTED SO.
ON HIS BILL.
YOUR OVER.
CENTER -- CHURCH BIRD WILL BE.
HE'S GOT TO SB THREE SIXTY NINE
THESE.
RUSHING DOWN TO OUR MEETING AT
THIS POINT [inaudible]
HI.
THE OTHER BURKE.
NO HE LIKES [inaudible]
TO ONCE [inaudible]
HE IS.
THE LADY IS A BIRD.
AS LOWER LAST NAME.
FOR OUR THIS.
IS A MONSTER ONE MORE.
THIS IS A MEDICAL CENTER
HERTZBERG WELCOME TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. FOR
YOUR APPRECIATION ON SB.
THREE SIXTY NINE AND WILL TURN
OVER CENTER HERTZBERG.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR CENTER.
OKAY THANKS BOB JAMES.
TOMORROW OKAY SO YOU TO MARK
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SHERMAN.
HOW YOU DOING TODAY?
LONG DAY SOME ACCOUNTS DID YOU
SAY THE LAST COMMITTEE I'M MORE
THAN ONE OF THE SENATOR -- I GOT
TWO HOURS BEFORE GAME TIME.
OKAY THE SEVENTH GAME OF FIRST
LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE ARGUMENT LAYOFFS I
LIKE THAT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
KNOW HOW.
I KNOW SO LITTLE ABOUT SPORTS I
KNOW PLAYOFFS OF WHAT SPORT H.
DIET.
SO WHAT CAN I SAY WELL THE
SHARKS OR PLANE TODAY FOR THE
SEVEN GAMES.
WERE.
HOLDING OFF FOR A VICTORY.
SO EACH OF US IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT WE REPRESENT ON THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
ON HAVE STORIES ABOUT ISSUES OF
HOMELESSNESS.
JUST ITS PURPOSE IT IS JUST BEEN
NOTHING LESS THAN EXTRAORDINARY.
AND ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
THAT I'VE BEEN QUITE FRUSTRATED
WITH MISTER CHAIRMAN.
IS ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU WERE IN
THE ACT CAN BE OTHER COMMITTEE
THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE.
IS THAT WERE OUT THERE SPEND ALL
THIS MONEY PASSING ALL THESE
MEASURES IN LOS ANGELES CITY AND
COUNTY PASSING MEASURES OF THE
STATE.
PASSING MEASURES FOR HOUSING IN
TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO HELP THE HOMELESS.
AND THE REALITY IS IS THAT THOSE
WHO FIND THEMSELVES HOMELESS
EXCUSE ME.
WITH THE REALITY IS IS IS THAT
WHAT'S THE IMPACT IS IT WE SEE
IT ON THE STREET EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND SO I'VE BEEN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE SOME NEAR
TERM ISSUES THAT WE CAN DO THAT
CAN IMPACT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE.
THAT FOLKS WHO FIND THEMSELVES
HOMELESS CAN CAN ENGAGE IN WE
HAVE A BILL WHICH SOME OF YOU IN
THIS COMMITTEE IS SEEN DEALING
WITH PETS 425% OF THE PEOPLE AND
TOLD IN LOS ANGELES.
HAVE PETS AND WILL GOING.
TO YOU GUYS.
GOING TO A HOMELESS SHELTER
BECAUSE ARE THEY CAN'T TAKE
THEIR PETS ONE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
LIVING ON THE STREETS IN CARS.
THE THE ONLY PLACE THEY CAN LIVE
AND THEY DON'T FEEL SAFE AND SO
WORKING WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TIONAL HERE FROM -- HERE
TODAY BUT TOGETHER WITH -- OTHER
WESTERN CENTER WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHICH TO GATHER WITH
THIS COMMITTEE HOW CAN WE ADD TO
PUBLIC POLICY THEY CAN CREATE.
QUICK A QUICKER RESPONSE IS FOR
FOLKS THAT ARE IN CARS PROVIDING
SAFE PARKING AND SO.
THE THE THE BASICALLY WHAT THIS
MEASURE DOES IS THAT THIS SB
THREE SIXTY NINE ENCOURAGES THAT
THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
SERVICES AUTHORITY.
WHICH CURRENTLY OPERATING AS A
PARKING PROGRAM THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES WERE INDIVIDUALS OR
LIVING OUT OF THEIR CARS TO GET
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED.
AND SO WHILE AT THE THE THE THE
FOLKS WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO HELP
US A TALK TALK ABOUT THAT -- AT
THE AT THE WESTERN CENTER -- WE
HAVE YOU MIKE HERALD WAS ALWAYS
HERE BUT HE HAS -- IT MORE WEEKS
WHEN THE PRESSURE CORRECTLY
WHO'S BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON
THE DETAILS OF THIS AND I WANTED
HIM TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN SPEAKER.
AS WELL AS ANDREW ENTRY THE
THOUGHTFUL -- FORMER -- COULD
CHIEF CONSULTANT OF THE CAN THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE OTHER HOUSE
SOME YEARS AGO BECAUSE OF THE
GREAT TALENTS IN THIS BUILDING
THE SOLID DOWNTREND TRADE. TO
ALSO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU WANT ONE WE HAVE START
WITH A STRANGELY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS INJURY ANTS WE WOULD
SHOW YOUR ANSWER HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI -- THE CITY PARKING
PROGRAMS ARE CROPPING UP --
BECAUSE OF THE EXTREME NEED
THESE ARE SERVICES THAT ARE
RENDERED ON PARKING LOTS AFTER
HOURS TYPICALLY WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GIVEN A SAFE PLACE TO PARK THESE
ARE SICK PEOPLE FIND THEMSELVES
IN A SITUATION WHERE.
THEIR CARS ARE LAST WORLDLY
POSITION IN THIS AND THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY SERVING AS THE PLACE
WHERE THEY SLEEP.
AND WE GIVE THEM A PLACE WHERE
THEY'RE NOT ADDRESS FOR THE
VEHICLES BEING TOLD.
AND THEY'RE ALSO RECEIVING
SERVICES A SIMILAR TO NAVIGATION
CENTERS WHERE THEY'RE ASSESSED.
COM AT THE LEVEL WHERE THEY ARE
AND THE DETERMINATION HAS BEEN
MADE TO THEY NEED SMOG
ASSISTANCE OF ANY RELIEF WITH
BACK PARKING FINES.
THEY NEED TO BE REFERRED TO A
MORE PERMANENT HOUSING SITUATION
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THERE'S
ALSO OPPORTUNITIES FOR PLACEMENT
OF MOBILE SHOWERS -- AND THERE'S
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
TO KIND OF DEAL WITH THEIR
PERSONAL BELONGINGS IN A PLACE
THAT'S LOCKED AND SAFE OVERNIGHT --
BUT WE FOR THE FINAL SOCIAL
SITUATION WHERE BECAUSE THE
VEHICLE -- HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
BE UP TO DATE ON THEIR SMALL.
AND THE TAGS ARE BAD DURING THE
DAY WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN THESE
PARKING LOTS TO GET HAVE THOSE
VEHICLES TOLD ARE TAKEN AWAY.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE THANK
CENTER HERTZBERG FOR BRING IS
MEASURE FORWARD BECAUSE IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO ENHANCE THE
ASSISTANCE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING.
FOLKS THE FINAL CELLS IN THE
SITUATION. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS.
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU THE
CHAIR FOR GIVING ME TIME TO
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE -- WE ALL
KNOW CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE A
CRISIS IN HOMELESSNESS ON LOS
ANGELES ALONE FIFTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND NEARLY A THIRD
OF THEM ARE LIVING THEIR
VEHICLES ARE HALF OF WHICH ARE
CHILDREN -- BUT WHEN INDIVIDUALS
SEEK SHELTER IN THEIR VEHICLES
THEY ALSO PUT THOSE VEHICLES AT
RISK BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA --
LOCALITIES CAN TOLL AN IMPOUND
YOUR VEHICLE IF IT'S
REGISTRATION HAS BEEN LAPSED FOR
OVER SIX MONTHS -- OUR CLIENTS
MANY TIMES CANNOT BRING THE
FUNDS TOGETHER TO PAY THE HIGH
VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEES OUT
ONCE -- AND THEN MANY OF THEM
ARE FORCED TO LIVE IN THEIR
VEHICLES BECAUSE THEY CAN FIND
PROPER HOUSING SO AS A LIVE IN
THEIR VEHICLES ON THE STREETS --
THEY RISK LOSING THEM -- NOW --
SB THREE SIX NINE SIX TO REMEDY
THIS -- IT ACTS AS A BRIDGE OF
SORTS IT'S NOT A PERFECT
SOLUTION BUT IS IMPORTANT --
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES OR CREATES A
FRAMEWORK IN OUR STATE -- TO
CREATE THE SAY PARKING PROGRAM
SO THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN COME AT
NIGHT THEY CAN PARK THEIR CARS --
THEY CAN BE GUARDED -- THEY CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO FACILITIES AND
RESOURCES -- ABOUT ARE IMPORTANT
FOR THEM -- AND WHILE ALL AT THE
SAME TIME UTILIZING UNDER USE
PARKING SPACES ARE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE WIDER COMMUNITY --
SO.
SAY PARKING PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
HAVE ALREADY HAD SUCCESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- MY
COLLEAGUE HERE FROM LOS ANGELES
SORRY TALK ABOUT THEIR PROGRAM --
SANTA BARBARA AS WELL HAVE WON
THE EARLY IS PROGRAM TO STAR IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR THEY'VE SERVE
THOUSANDS OF PARTICIPANTS -- AND
IT'S BEEN HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
COMMUNITY AND BEEN GENERALLY
REGARDED AS A SUCCESS SO --
WHILE THIS LEGISLATION DOESN'T
SAY THAT IT IS -- IT DOESN'T A
RECOGNIZES THAT.
OUR PROBLEM WITH HOMELESSNESS
WILL NOT BE SOLVED TOMORROW --
WE MUST STILL DO ALL THAT WE
CAN'T TODAY TO HELP OUR
NEIGHBORS -- AND THAT'S WHY THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY URGES AN AYE VOTE I
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
AND TESTING -- SPEAK OTHERS
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE.
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
OF SPEAKERS OPPOSING.
AND IF UP OPPOSITION.
OF QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
[inaudible] TO REVIEW.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN -- I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION FOR VERIFICATION
CAN YOU KIND OF EXPLAIN FURTHER
ON THAT.
THE SECURITY AROUND THESE AREAS
TO IS THERE LIKE SOMEONE FROM
ANYTHING AIR HOW DOES THAT WORK.
THE CHAIR -- SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION TYPICALLY --
INSTEAD OF SOMEONE PARKING ON
THE STREET WHERE SOMETIMES BAD
THINGS HAPPEN TO THE VEHICLE.
THESE ARE LOTS TYPICALLY THEY'RE
SECURED LOTS THERE'S A GATE THAT
CLOSES AFTER HOURS AND SO THE
VEHICLE SECURE AND YOU KNOW THAT
WHEN YOU'RE ASLEEP IN THE
VEHICLE YOU'RE STUCK IN THAT
SITUATION -- SOMEONE ONE TAMPER
WITH A VEHICLE OR ACCESS THE
VEHICLE ARE TRYING TO OPEN IT
YOU KNOW.
DURING THE NIGHT TIME HOURS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WILL JUST --
TO ADD TO THAT THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG I KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT
STEPS VALLEY'S.
TRYING TO PROVIDE A SAFE PLACE
FOR OUR HOMELESS POPULATION AND
BUT THAT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU SIR.
WAY TO A RECORD.
SENATOR AND A QUESTION OF A
GROUP CALLED THE STUDENT
HOMELESS ALLIANCE.
STUDENT HOMELESS ALLIANCE.
CAME TO ME IN SAN JOSE THEY'RE
YOUNG.
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT GO TO SAN JOSE
STATE [inaudible]
AND THE ASKED ME ABOUT THIS KIND
OF PROGRAM -- AND THEN I HAD
ANOTHER GROUP COME TO ME.
FROM SALAS.
CITY COLLEGE.
THEY TOLD ME THERE'S LIKE FOUR
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS LIVING IN
CARS AROUND SO AS THE CITY
COLLEGE [inaudible]
OKAY.
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THERE'S
BEEN A RECENT SURVEY ABOUT.
COLLEGE STUDENTS LIVING IN THEIR
CARS SO.
FOR THERE I HAD A SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT FROM [inaudible]
SAN JOSE.
AND I SAID WHAT CAN I DO TO HELP
YOU HE SAID WELL WE GOT.
KIDS AND MOMS LIVING IN CARS.
IN MY DISTRICT.
AND I WANT TO KNOW.
IS THERE A WAY WE CAN HAVE A
PARKING LOT.
WHERE THEY CAN HAVE A SAFE PLACE
TO LIVE?
SO FAMILIES LIVING IN CARS.
THERE.
THEY WAKE UP THEY GO TO SCHOOL.
AND THEY TAKE THEIR SHOWERS IN
THE SCHOOL INTO JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND GET CLEANED UP AND AND GO TO
IS THIS -- HAVE YOU THOUGHT OF
THIS IN THE SENSOR ANYBODY.
THE WITNESSES -- IN TERMS OF
THOSE KIND OF PLACES FOR THESE
SO.
SAY PARKING AREAS IS THAT IN.
DESCARTES STIRS ANYBODY
DISGUSTED.
WHAT IS THE RACE SENATE BASED ON
THESE PEOPLE COMING AND TALKING
TO ME?
COLLEGE JIM BILL UP AND COMING
IN TO SEE ME OR TALK TO STUDENTS
THE DOCTOR ABOUT THREE TIMES ARE
TRYING TO FIND.
HOUSING FOR THE FOR THE STUDENTS
YEAH I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A
STUDENT.
I HAD A LOT OF MY FRIENDS.
BECOME MORE SLEEP ON THE FLOOR
IN MY LITTLE ROOM THAT I RENTED.
AND YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THESE
CREDIT WE SAY YOU'RE GOING TO
CRASH OVER HERE.
FOR A COUPLE MONTHS OKAY FINE
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE A PLACE
TO LIVE SO THEY STAY IN MY MY
LITTLE ROOM THE BUT YOU KNOW IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT CNTER WHAT
YOU SAID MAKES SENSE THE WE
ULTIMATELY DON'T WANT PEOPLE
SLEEPING CARS AT ALL.
RIGHT WE WANT TO PROVIDE HOUSING
FORM THIS IS JUST A BRIDGE THAT
YOU GIVEN THE SITUATION.
IF PEOPLE DO HAVECARS TO
PROVIDE SAFE PLACES THE
INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL CAME
FROM ALL ELDERLY COUPLE ARE
SPENDING THEIR TIME.
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AT
TEMPLE BETH HILLEL THAT I TEND
IN IN IN THE NORTH HOLLYWOOD.
WHO ARE DOING THIS STUFF AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE THEY'RE
GOING TO CHURCHES AND TEMPLES
AND SCHOOLS AND TRYING TO FIND
FOLKS THAT WILL LET THEM USE
THEIR PARKING LOTS SO THE IDEA?
WAS HOW CAN WE KIND OF HELP
OVERCOME SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
AND CERTAINLY.
HE WITH YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THIS BILL IS
TO DO GO AS FAR DOWN THAT LINE
AS AS WE POSSIBLY CAN -- BUT
CLEARLY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GO ON OF MANAGED MISTER ENTRY
FEE OF ANY THOUGHTS TO ADD TO
THAT.
IS THIS WITH TALKED ABOUT IN LOS
ANGELES AND YOUR IT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED -- THERE'S ACTUALLY A
BILL ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE BY
SELLING MEMBER BERMAN THAT LOOKS
AT THIS KIND OF APPLICATION ON
PARKING FACILITIES ON COMMITTEE
COLLEGE SETTINGS.
SENATOR -- THERE'S NOTHING TO
PRECLUDE -- A PROPERTY OWNER BE
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR SCHOOL
UNIVERSITY FROM WORKING WITH THE
NONPROFIT TO SET THIS PROGRAM --
WHAT WE'RE THANKFUL ABOUT IN
THIS BILL IS THAT IT SETS THE
PARAMETERS SO THAT?
THESE WILL BE CERTIFIED PROGRAMS
SO THAT THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
MAKE THEMSELVES ELIGIBLE FOR THE
SMOG CHECK REPAIR SYSTEM.
THAT THEY ARE RECOGNIZED PROGRAM.
AND THAT THERE'S SOME KIND OF
THRESHOLD FOR ENTRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PIPELINE OF PEOPLE TO
COME FORWARD FOR THIS TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE -- THERE'S A BONA
FIDE PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN SOME TALK
ABOUT LOCAL LEGISLATION ON THE
LEGISLATION ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
AND ACTUALLY THAT WAS JUST
INFORMED BY MY CAROL FOR THE
WASHER CENTER.
THAT YOU'RE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MISTER BERMAN HAS A BILL FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR SAFE
DRIVING SO HE HAS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PART RIGHT.
ABOUT -- K. [inaudible]
TWELVE THAT'S NOT.
AS THE SUPPLY THE YEAH WE
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T HEARD OKAY
HAVING HER ON THAT ONE OKAY SO
MAYBE WE CAN.
DISCUSS WE GET FROM.
SENATORS AND HAVE BOTH
EXPERIENCE AND NOVEL FIND OUT.
IF A MORE DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES SUSAN RUBIO WHO'S
WORKED IN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
ON THOSE CONDITIONS.
OF SERVICE ARE WHAT COUNTS THE
HERTZBERG OR STAFF REPORT ON
PAGE FOUR SAYS THAT YOU INTEND --
TO MAY HAVE SOME AUTHORED
AMENDMENTS REMOVING THE SMOG --
WAIVER PROGRAM IN MODIFYING THE
REPAIR ASSISTANCE PROGRAM RIGHT
NOW IT'S SET SAID YOU GO IN YOU
FLUNKED THE SMOG TEST THEN YOU
COME IN AND THEY'LL DO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WITH THE REPAIRS
TO HELP GET YOU FIXED UP.
WHAT WILL LOOK LIKE?
AS IT IS MODIFIED THIS YEAR WITH
RESPECT TO THE AMENDMENTS AS THE
MEN'S WE TOOK NEGOTIATED
COMMITTEE.
I THINK IN ARE WE TAKING THEM
NOW HOURS AT YOUR CHECK IN LATER
THAT'S A ROOM BUT AGAIN NOW OKAY.
AS WERE TAKEN [inaudible]
OFFERS.
THE AUTHOR'S MEMBERS OKAY BUT IS
STILL FIVE HUNDRED THIS THE
THRESHOLD STILL YOU GOT A FLOCK.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR YOU HAVE ANY
CONCLUDING STATEMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR -- WILL
MOVE ON TO SIR I WORK.
ARE YOU. ONE MINUTE OKAY.
OKAY WERE -- CENTER ARCHER
LETTERS.
ON HIS WAY.
SO THERE ARE JEWELERS COMING
DOWN.
WELL HERE'S CEREBRAL IT IS BILL
THIS IS -- I AM [inaudible]
NINETEEN BOB DOLE.
BUT YOU'LL BE READY.
OKAY GO AHEAD.
SIR -- BURKE SAYS HE'S READY.
WAIT A MINUTE WE HAVE A CENTER
ARCHULETA GO AHEAD CENTER CENTER
ACTUALLY YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU FOR WRITING DOWN AYE
FREE ****.
SIR OUR CHILLERS READY SO WE'LL
HEAR HIS BILL.
THIS IS SB SIX SIX TWO BY CENTER
ARE CHIRLA -- CENTER YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU CENTER I APPRECIATE
THE TIME COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN TODAY I
COME BEFORE YOU WITH THE SENATE
BILL SIX SIX TWO WHICH WOULD
ALLOW INVESTOR OWNED.
ELECTRICAL UTILITIES TO MEET
THEIR TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION MANDATE.
WHICH BY INVESTING IN RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN AS A TRANSPORTATION
FUEL.
IN ADDITION TO THEIR CURRENT
SINGULAR COMPLIANCE PATHWAY OF
INVESTMENTS IN BATTERY ELECTRIC
CHARGING PROJECTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
AND TO AFFIRM TO YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY IMPOSED MANDATE THAT
THE UTILITIES DO THEIR SHARED
CLEAN UP OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
AN OVERDUE AND MUCH NEEDED STEP
TO CLEAN UP OUR AIR IN THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS MEANT TO COME TO
COMPLEMENT THE GROUND BREAKING
STRIDES MADE UNDER SB THREE
FIFTY BY BRINGING ANOTHER
TECHNOLOGY INTO THE FRAY AND
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL WEAPON. TO
OUR ARSENAL IN THE FIGHT TO
REDUCE TRANSPORTATION RELATED
EMISSIONS AND CALIFORNIA.
SB SIX SIX TWO DOES NOT IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL MANDATE ON UTILITIES
BUT RATHER ADDS AN ADDITIONAL
COMPLIANCE PATHWAY FOR THEIR
EXISTING MANDATES.
THIS BILL WILL HOWEVER
FACILITATE A TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
STANCE ON TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION AND ALLOW FOR
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY TO
PLAY A ROLE IN HELPING US
ACHIEVE.
OUR EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA.
HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN
WIDELY ACCEPTED AS A ARE A
CRUCIAL PIECE OF THE PUZZLE TO
TRANSFORM OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
PARTICULARLY IN THE HEAVY DUTY
SPACE AND IT IS.
IT IS PAST TIME THAT THE STATE
INVEST IN BEHAVIOR.
THE DISPLAY A RECOGNITION OF
THIS FACT AS WELL.
I'VE BEEN IN THESE TECHNICALITY
I'VE SEEN THIS AT THE
TECHNOLOGIES IN ACTION I'VE
DRIVEN THE HYDRO FUEL CELL
VEHICLE.
AND THE PERFORMANCE WAS IS GOOD
IF NOT BETTER THAN MY OWN
CONVENTIONAL CAR.
I ACTUALLY FEEL THE THE
AUTOMOBILE THAT I WAS DRIVING --
WITH THE HYDROGEN AND THAT THE
SPEED IT TOOK TO FILL BAD WAS
EQUIVALENT TO MY CAR.
AND I PUT THE HELLO BACK ON THE
ON THE PUMP DROVE OFF AND I WAS
REALLY IMPRESSED BY THE BRIDGE
SPOT.
I JUST RECENTLY RETURNED FROM
JAPAN. FOR THE FUEL CELL
TECHNOLOGY IS WIDELY ACCEPTED
NOT AND ADOPTED HYDROGEN WORKS
AND IT'S OUR PLANS IN THE FUTURE
AND IF WE CAN START WORKING WITH
IT TODAY.
LIKE MOST BUILT AT THIS POINT
TIME IT IS NOT YET -- PERFECT
BUT I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH ALL THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO CRAFT A BILL
THAT WILL ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS
AND ADDING HYDROGEN.
INTO OUR TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION EFFORTS.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE JAKE --
DONAHUE AND TIM SAN SCENE WITH --
BILLARD FUEL IN THE FUEL SYSTEM
AND THEY ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL.
AND MISTER GERALD TURN IT OVER
TO THEM IF YOU DON'T MIND.
THANK YOU CENTER -- WITNESSES IN
FAVOR PLEASE.
MR SURE MEMBERS J. DONOHUE ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR BALLARD
FUEL CELL SYSTEMS AS WELL AS
SOME LINE TRANSIT AGENCY RED OR
WHITE FLEET AND GOLDEN GATE ZERO
MISSION MARINE.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT A
BROAD SWATH OF THE HYGIENE
INDUSTRY FROM ALL THE
ENGINEERING MANUFACTURING AND
END USER PERSPECTIVES.
THESE DIVERSE VIEWPOINTS PUT
TOGETHER A COLLECTIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEED FOR
HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY IN
TRANSFORMING OUR HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TWO ZERO
MISSION.
KERN INVESTMENTS IN BATTERY
ELECTRIC TECHNOLOGY HAVE BY
MAGNITUDE OF MORE THAN TEN FAR
EXCEEDED THOSE AND HYDROGEN.
THE ISSUE WITH THIS IS THAT
WHILE THOSE INVESTMENTS IN
BATTERY ELECTRIC TECHNOLOGY HAVE
CLEAR VALUE IN ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
TARGETS THEY WILL NOT GET IS
THERE ALONE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO SIMPLY ALLOW
CALIFORNIA ELECTRICAL UTILITIES
TO MAKE DYNAMIC INVESTMENTS IN
MULTIPLE TECHNOLOGIES AS A PART
OF THEIR PURSUIT OF
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
RATHER THAN THEIR CURRENT
MANDATE TO PUT ALL THEIR EGGS IN
ONE BASKET.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR SPENDING TIME WITH US
IN THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO CRAFT A
MAN IS THAT WE FEEL MAKE THE
BILL EVEN BETTER AND WHAT THAT I
HEARD YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OTHER WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M TIM TESTING WITH
BALLARD FUEL CELL SYSTEMS THE
SPONSORS SENATE BILL.
SIX SIX TWO WE SPONSORED THIS
BILL TO PROVIDE A MECHANISM TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY ACHIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE GAS AND
CRITERIA POLLUTANT REDUCTION
GOALS.
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY IS
PROVEN TO BE THE ONLY FEASIBLE
ZERO EMISSIONS OPTIONS FOR MANY
OPERATORS IN THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY.
ARENAS SUCH AS BUSES TRUCKS
MARINE VESSELS AND LOCOMOTIVES.
THE LONG ROUTES AND OPERATING
TIMES EXTREME TEMPERATURES AND
HIGH ENERGY DEMANDS.
ARE JUST A FEW REASONS WHY FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN NEEDED
IN THESE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
APPLICATIONS.
WITHOUT INVESTMENTS IN RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN THOSE APPLICATIONS
WHERE NEEDS CANNOT BE ADEQUATELY
MET BY BATTERY ELECTRIC
TECHNOLOGY.
WILL LIKELY BE APPLICATIONS THAT
REMAIN POWERED BY DIESEL AND
OTHER NON ZERO EMISSION PAT
POWERTRAINS A PATHWAY WHICH IS
IN STARK CONTRAST THIS
LEGISLATURE STATED GOALS FOR THE
FUTURE.
SB SIX SIXTY WILL BRING SOME
SEMBLANCE OF PARITY IS STATE
AUTHORIZED INVESTMENTS IN ZERO
MISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND FOR
THAT REASON WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES.
GOT TO STEVE ALL COMBAT THE
CENTER FOR TRANSPORTATION
ENVIRONMENT ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ROCKY RAGING WITH COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
NEED TO GO FOR THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS WE
ACTUALLY DO NOT HAVE A POSITION
ON THE SPOT THIS TIME BUT WE'RE
HOPING TO SUPPORT THE BILL IN
THE NEAR FUTURE -- THE ISSUE
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE ON IS.
WHETHER OR THIS BILL PICKS
WINNERS OR LOSERS AND SOME OF BY
MEMBERS ACTUALLY PRODUCE
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN ON IT'S VERY
COST EFFECTIVE IT IS FULLY
RENEWABLE -- IT HAD IT CAN HAVE
A LOWER CARBON INTENSITY AND
EVEN A CARBON NEGATIVE --
INTENSITY BUT UNFORTUNATELY DOES
NOT FIT THE DEFINITION -- IN
THIS BILL AND SO WE'RE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THEM HAVING
VERY POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS AND
JUST WANTED TO STATE OUR ISSUE
FOR THE RECORD THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OKAY -- OTHER SUPPORTERS OF
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
ANYBODY ONE IS BIG.
OPPOSING THE BILL.
QUESTIONS WERE COMMITTEE.
OF SIR WHAT CAO SKI ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU HAD IN YOUR COMMITTEE YEAH.
HELLO NO QUESTIONS SIR YOU HAVE
A CLOSING STATEMENT YES MISS
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT BILL.
SB SIX SIX TWO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SIR -- WE TOUCH OF
EVENTS AND WE'RE GONNA RECOMMEND
I WHEN WE REACH CORPS.
WHICH HOPEFULLY WE SELL -- SIR
ROBERT.
HE WOULD LIKE TO READY GO
[inaudible]
OKAY ROBERT.
SIR ROBERT WILL PRESENT FOUR
HUNDRED SB.
FOUR HUNDRED AND I WILL TURN THE
FLOOR TO HIM YOU OF THE FOR
CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BOB.
SB FOUR HUNDRED EXPERIENCE CLEAN
MOBILITY OPTIONS IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM.
IS DESIGNED TO HAVE CALIFORNIANS
TURN IN THEIR HIGH POLLUTING
CLUNKER CARS. FOR OTHER VEHICLES
WITH THIS BILL DOES IS IT SIMPLY
ALLOWS.
CALIFORNIANS THE TURN IN THEIR
HIGH POLLUTING CLUNKER CARS FOR
AN E. BIKE WHICH IS FAR MORE
EFFICIENT TERMS OF BOTH ENERGY
AS WELL AS POLLUTION.
THEN -- ANOTHER VEHICLE FOR A
VOUCHER FOR EXAMPLE FOR OTHER
MOBILITY OPTIONS IT'S A SIMPLE
BILL AND HIGHER JUGGLED WITH ME
TODAY IS LARA PT ALL SKI
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF UC INSTEAD
OF TRANSPORTATION STUDIES.
AND LINDA -- COMMOTION SENIOR
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION.
NOT PROFESSOR BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT -- CHAIR BILL IN MEMBERS
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY LOWER PUT
ALL SKI WITH YOU SEE INSTEAD OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
BILL JUST HERE TO PROVIDE EXPERT
TESTIMONY -- I'M SPEAKING TO A
NEW BRIEF THAT JUST CAME OUT
THIS MONTH FROM DOCTOR DILLON
FINCH WHO IS THE CO DIRECTOR.
OF THE BICYCLING PLUS RESEARCH
COLLABORATIVE GROUP AT UC DAVIS
SO HE LOOKED AT AND SUMMARIZED
THE EXISTING STUDIES LOOKING AT
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN E.
BICYCLING AND REDUCTION AND CAR
TRIPS.
AND VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
HE FOUND THAT THERE IS EVIDENCE
IN SUPPORT THAT YOU BICYCLING
DOES REDUCE CAR TRIPS AND DOES
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
I'M THEIR MANY STUDIES IN EUROPE
ON THIS THERE ARE THE E. BIKE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS ARE PREVALENT
IN THE IN EUROPE.
AT THE NATIONAL.
REGIONAL AND LOCAL LEVEL THEY'RE
VERY RARE IN THE U. S. THOUGH
I'M SO IN LOOKING AT STUDIES IN
EUROPE HE FOUND THAT THIRTY FIVE
TO FORTY OF 35250% OF P. BY
TRICK IT EASY BIKE TRIPS.
WOULD HAVE MADE BY CAR IF THE
BIKE WAS NOT MADE AVAILABLE.
AND THERE WAS A SMALLER GROUP OF
STUDIES IN NORTH AMERICA THAT
FOUND 112406% OF E. BIKE TRIPS
SUBSTITUTED FOR CAR TRIPS LOSES
JUST TO GO TO SHOW THAT THERE IS
EVIDENCE E. BIKES DO.
OF SUBSTITUTE FOR CAR TRIPS AND
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED -- IN
SUMMARY OF CALIFORNIA DECIDES TO
PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR E. BIKES
WHICH THERE IS EVIDENCE AGAIN TO
SHOW THAT HE BIKES DO SUBSTITUTE
FOR CAR TRIPS AND VMT.
THEN THE U. S. UCITS WOULD
RECOMMEND -- TO INCORPORATE
EVALUATION I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DID NOT SAY THAT AS FROM
UNIVERSITY. TO COLLECT DATA ON
BEFORE AND AFTER OF TRAVELS
LOUIS ACTUALLY CAN PROVIDE
BETTER ESTIMATES BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE SUBSTITUTION
IS THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WITNESS.
HI LINDA COMMISSION WITH A
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION AND
JUST HERE AT TO ASK -- FOR THIS
PROGRAM TO REALLY LOOK AT HOW WE
ARE EXPANDING MOBILITY OPTIONS
TO REALLY BE INCLUSIVE OF ALL
THE DIFFERENT OPTIONS WE CAN
OFFER -- ARE A CONSTITUENTS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND REALLY GIVE
THEM THE THE FAST AT ABILITY TO
MAKE THAT CHOICE FOR THEMSELVES --
THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAS PUT
FORWARD VERY AMBITIOUS I GOALS
COMICAL HEALTH GOALS AND WE
REALLY WANT TO AT TAKE AT A
ADVANTAGE OF EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO MEET THAT -- BICYCLING
OFFERS MANY CO BENEFITS
THE BICYCLING IS ONE OF THOSE
WAYS THAT WE'RE GETTING MORE
PEOPLE ON BIKES AND MORE OF THE
TIME SO.
I WOULD URGE FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE.
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL YEAH -- I'M JOHN SWAN.
PRESIDENT OF THE DAVIS BY CLUB.
I'M A BICYCLE ADVOCATE AND I WAS --
A BIKE -- ANYBODY DEALER -- UP
UNTIL LAST OCTOBER AND I WAS
DOING THAT FOR ABOUT NINE YEARS --
THE THE BIKE IS INCREDIBLY
EFFICIENT VEHICLE -- OF ELECTRIC
CARS GET ON THE ORDER OF ONE TO
TWO HUNDRED MILES PER GALLON.
WHERE'S THE BIKES GET TWO TO
THREE THOUSAND MILES PER GALLON
EQUIVALENT -- THE TECHNOLOGY IS
BEING EMBRACED -- MORE THAN I
COULD HAVE EVER IMAGINED WHEN I
GOT INTO THE BUSINESS NINE YEARS
AGO ON AN EVIDENCE OF THAT IS
THE THE JUMP BIKES RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- THERE IT'S A BIKE
SHARE PROGRAM WITH ELECTRIC
BIKES -- AND THEIR OWN I THINK
MOST PEOPLE KNOW THEIR OWN BY
UBER AND THERE WAS AN ARTICLE
THAT I READ SEVERAL MONTHS AGO
THAT SAID IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA --
THEY HAD DURING A PARTICULAR
PERIOD THEY HAD MORE.
BIKE TRIPS ON THEIR JUMP BIKES
AND THEY HAVE A UBER TRIPS IN
THE CITY OF A SACRAMENTO -- YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE AN ATHLETE AND
IS SO GET IT ACTUALLY REALLY
DOES GET MORE PEOPLE.
ON AN OUT OF THEIR CARS AND
WOULD NOT NORMALLY DO THAT --
AND THEIR SAFETY IN NUMBERS
THERE'S BEEN STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT THE MORE BICYCLES ON THE
ROAD TO SAY FOR EVERYBODY IS
BECAUSE THE CARS BECOME AWARE OF
SIR OR JUST I THINK A TESTIMONY
OKAY A FROM PEOPLE.
WANT TO SAY THEIR FAVOR THE BILL
I'M VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THIS
AMENDMENT THANK YOU.
SIR.
THAT WOULD MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LAURA BENNETT WITH CALIFORNIA
VISORS ON BEHALF OF UBER I'M NOT
SURE NEED TO SAY MUCH HE DECIDED
FOR ME WE ARE IT'S PART OF SB
FOUR HUNDRED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IT.
IS THE CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MILAN
AS THE DAILY COMMUTER BIKE IN
MYSELF AND ON BEHALF OF IN OUR
DC THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
ONLY GOVERNMENT COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR AND REGULAR EBOOK
WRITER IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY.
JONATHAN MATT SAFE ROUTES TO
SCHOOL NATIONAL PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO THE PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE ASKED ME --
TO GIVE TEIR ME TOO AS WELL
SINCE THEY CANNOT BE HERE IN
PERSON.
THANK YOU SIR -- OKAY -- DO HAVE
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL -- SEE
NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE.
SERVER ACOSTA [inaudible]
OKAY. TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
IT'S ME -- SIR.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD OFF FOR A
SECOND AND TAKE THE ROLE.
ALL RIGHT THAT MEANS WE GET TO
VOTE ON THE BILL.
I'M IN FAVOR THAT WE CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE CENTER ABOUT YOUR
BILL PRESENT BATES.
BATES PRESENT DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI PRESENT REQUIRED ROUTE
ROTH RUBIO.
RUBIO PRESENT SKINNER
[inaudible]
SKINNER.
OUR SKINNER PRESENT YOUR STONE.
NUMBER YEAH I'M BURKE PRESENT
WILL COST ME -- CATHOLIC WE HAVE
A QUORUM.
OKAY SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
REGION I VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU OKAY AND THE
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS IS.
TO IS THAT I VOTE AND WE HAVE WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR THAT.
I REMOVED AYE AYE.
SIR WHAT TASK.
KALRA PLEASE SENATE BILL FOUR
HUNDRED BY SENATOR UMBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ABOUT HI WELL I BATES
RIGHT BATES AYE DOT.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORRELL.
ROUGH RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE STONE -- BURKE.
NUMBER I WILL COST ME BECAUSE HE
AYE. SEVEN LOS IN FAVOR OF
LEADER OPEN ABSENT MEMBERS
CENTER.
THANK YOU CAN AVAIL SERVER
SCANNER -- SHE READY TO GO.
SENATOR SKATERS RIVER IS ITEM
ONE SB.
FORTY FOUR AND SIR YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ARM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST I WILL ACCEPT
THE AUTHOR AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH
REMOVES THE SPECIFIC TIME
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOALS
THAT ARE IN THE BILL AT PRESENT
THE BILL AND PRINT.
AND IT ALLOWS -- ARB TO ENGAGE
IN THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
TO SET FOR YOUR GOALS.
NOW WHY BY INTRODUCED SB.
FORTY FOUR CALIFORNIA IS STILL
PLAGUED WITH DIRTY AIR AS MUCH
AS WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP. SEVEN
OUT OF THE TEN CITIES IN THE US
WITH THE MOST POLLUTED AIR ARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW WE ARE ALSO A STATE. TO
FIRST WE WE ARE ONE OF THE FIRST
WE ENACTED A CLEAN AIR ACT
BEFORE THE U. S. GOVERNMENT DID --
BUT WE'VE ALSO BEEN LEADERS IN
CLIMATE PROTECTION.
NOW ONE OF THE KEY WAYS THAT CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESS OUR AIR
POLLUTION PROBLEMS AS WELL IS
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS.
PROBLEMS IS GETTING AT PETROLEUM
BASED DIESEL.
WHY BECAUSE THAT PARTICULAR FORM
OF DIESEL IN OUR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES?
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
THE PARTICULAR MATTER
[inaudible]
AND 33% OF CALIFORNIA'S SMOG
CAUSING POLLUTION.
AND 25% OF THE TOTAL EMISSIONS
FROM TRANSPORTATION.
SO THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL TO BRING SPECIAL ATTENTION.
TO ASSISTING THE OPERATORS AND
OWNERS OF HEAVY.
DUTY AND MEDIUM DUTY VEHICLES SO
THAT WE CAN GET THAT -- THAT
FORMER POLLUTION AND HELP --
ELIMINATE IT -- THROUGH
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL [inaudible]
INCENTIVES.
THAT WOULD.
HELP US MOVE TOWARDS IT SO WITH
THAT I WILL HAVE MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SPEAK TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
HEARING MEMBERS ARE.
ONE PUSH THE BUTTON THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIGHTS YOU
AREN'T ON BEHALF CAL START WHERE
TECHNOLOGY CONSORTIUM -- WORKING
WITH AROUND TWO HUNDRED MEMBERS
TO ACCELERATE THAT THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S AVERAGE JUST KIND
OF GOES HAVE GIVEN RISE TO
RENAISSANCE VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING -- AS I DISCUSSED
EARLIER TODAY ON THAT SPRINT
BRINGING A WHOLE SLEW OF
MANUFACTURERS TO THE STATE
INCLUDING PER TERAMO TO BE Y. DE
AND AND SEVERAL OTHERS.
THESE COMPANIES ARE JUST THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG THAT COULD BE
HERE FOR FOR WHAT'S TO COME FROM
FROM OUR OUR CAP AND TRADE AND
RELATED CLIMATE CHANGE UP
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES.
AS A RESULT OF THEIR WORK HERE A
WHOLE NEW SET OF VEHICLE CLASSES
AND MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF BECOMING
OR HAVE ALREADY BEEN BECOME
COMMERCIALIZED.
SB FORTY FOUR IS THE NEXT
LOGICAL STEP IN OUR STATE
PLANNING EFFORTS TO KEEP
RATCHETING DOWN A VEHICLE
EMISSIONS AND SIGNAL TO
MANUFACTURE THE WE ARE NOT
BACKING DOWN OUR COMMITMENTS.
BUSINESS THEY'RE MAKING
INVESTMENT DECISIONS ON A LONG
TERM BASIS IN THIS THE STATE IN
AND IT NEEDS TO MORE MORE
CLOSELY SYNCHRONIZE AN AMP AND
PROVIDE PLANNING DIRECTION.
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
INVESTMENT CYCLES OF THE
INDUSTRY THIS DOING SO WOULD
HELP TO BRING TO THE MARKET
VEHICLES FASTER AND TO CONTINUE
TO RUN MORE VEHICLES AND
MANUFACTURES TO THE STATE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OR
DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ROCKY RUSSIAN WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND MY
COMMENTS TODAY REFLECT SUPPORT
FROM.
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
AND SEVENTEEN OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH RGANIZATIONS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO SOME OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT AIR POLLUTION
CHALLENGES IN UNITED STATES.
DESPITE REPRESENT A SMALL SHARE
OF TOTAL ON ROAD VEHICLES HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST MOBILE SOURCE OF HARMFUL
KNOCKS AND PM TWO POINT FIVE
EMISSIONS.
EMISSIONS FROM MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY.
DIESEL TRUCKS ADD SIGNIFICANTLY
TO LOCAL AND REGIONAL POLLUTION
AND PUBLIC HEALTH BURDENS
INCLUDING CARDIOVASCULAR AND
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS CANCERS AND
PREMATURE DEATH.
LOW INCOME DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDENS AND
ELEVATED CANCER RISKS DUE TO
NEARBY DIESEL HOT SPOT.
SUCH AS PORTS IN WAREHOUSES.
LOW INCOME.
CHILDREN AND THE ELDERLY ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
ADVERSE HEALTH IMPACTS OF PM AND
KNOCKS FROM DIESEL TRUCKS AND
WORKERS ALSO FACE GREATER RISKS
DUE TO INCREASED EXPOSURES.
DIESEL EXHAUST IS CLASSIFIED AS
A TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND IS CLASSIFIED AS A HUMAN
CARCINOGEN BY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION'S INTERNATIONAL
AGENCY. FOR RESEARCH -- CENTER
ON CANCER.
OVERWHELMINGLY EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT.
BOB PRTICLE POLLUTION LIKE THAT
COMING FROM DIESEL EXHAUST CAN
INCREASE THE RISK OF HEART
DISEASE LUNG CANCER ASTHMA
ATTACKS AND GREATER USE OF
ASTHMA MEDICATIONS AND CAN
INTERFERE WITH GROWTH.
AND WORK OF LUNGS.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS ARE
ALSO A MAJOR SOURCE OF BLACK
CARBON.
CLIMATE POLLUTION THAT THREATENS
HEALTH TODAY IN THAT OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS SB FORTY FOUR WOULD
DIRECT CARP TO DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO IDENTIFY
HOW THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE SECTORS CAN REDUCE
DIESEL EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND TWENTY FIFTY
RESPECTFULLY.
WITH THE GOAL OF MEDIAN FEDERAL
ATTAINMENT STANDARDS FOR AIR
QUALITY AND FOR THOSE REASONS.
CLEAN AIR IN THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT I MENTIONED --
JR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL HERE -- ANY ADDITIONAL OF
REPRESENTATION SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOE CY YOUNG I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION.
AS WELL AS THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ARE
BOTH OUT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR PRAGMATIC
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL APPROACH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UNICA FOR COALITION FOR ANY OF
OUR NATURAL GAS AND SUPPORT.
THE VOICE COACH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
A RYAN CANYON BEHALF OF CLEAN
ENERGY IN STRONG.
NOT HER MOM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
NOTHING IN THE ASSEMBLY HAVE A
SOCAL EDISON IN SUPPORT.
TIM CARMICHAEL AND HAVE A SO CAL
GAS IN SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THAT AFTERNOON MARINA FRANCESCHI
ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
SURE THE MEMBERS HERE TO ANSWER
WITH SHALL YOUR AUNT'S WE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT.
OF BY THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICER TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THEY
HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY DRIVEN WITH
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA IN SUPPORT
AND ALONG WITH A FOSSIL FOR
CALIFORNIA -- DEAR I SUPPORT
THEIR AYE VOTE.
RUBY MCDONALD THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY THREE FIFTY
RIVERSIDE AND SO CAL THREE FIFTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE GARCIA
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN ABS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
JUST MILAN FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
STEVE ALL COMING AT THE ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
X..
MIRAMAR CALVARY TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION -- WERE SUPPORT OF
THE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL RIGHT
NOW.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WLL BE
TAKEN.
WE WILL BE MOVING TO A SUPPORT
POSITION WE WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR IN OUR OFFICE FOR
WORKING WITH THE SENATE -- THE
OTHER SUPPORTERS WE HAVE A OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE. TWENTY YEARS OR
OPPOSING.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AM CHAIR.
I DIDN'T MENTION IN ONE I
INDICATED MY EXCEPT OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THERE WAS
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS APOLOGY
SYFY DISMAY.
SO -- I AM ACCEPTING THE MOMENTS
THAT ARE DESIGNED DESCRIBED IN
THE ANALYSIS BUT I'M ALSO
WORKING NOW ON AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD BE TAKEN AND
APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT IN MY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WOULD REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION
AND SO I'VE COMMITTED TO TAKE
THOSE AND WE ARE WORKING THAT
OUT NOW [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE TOUR -- YOU'RE THE FOR YES
OUR WITH OUR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THAT WE HAD RAISED
SOME CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO
THE GOALS -- MAN -- AMENDMENTS
THAT REFLECT VANCE BINS IN THE
DIESEL TECHNOLOGY IN THE
INDUSTRY ON THREE PC THE
AMENDMENTS MADE TODAY AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS DONE IN THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WITH.
WITH OUR GROUP TO ADDRESS MANY
CONCERNS ON THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
REQUIRE CONSULTATION WITH
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION ON THE
RELEVANT AGENCIES.
AND HER CONSISTENCY BETWEEN THE
SCOPING PLAN AND OF THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM WILL FREE
ACTION PLAN AND IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL INCENTIVES TO HELP THE
FLEETS MEET EARLY ADOPTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS COUPLES WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CAN.
HOPEFULLY -- WITH ACCEPTANCE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS WILL END UP IN
A NEUTRAL POSITION.
OTHERS SPEAKERS OPPOSING.
MATTIE MUNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
POULTRY FEDERATION WE JUST A
LINER COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
CHAMBER AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING AMENDMENTS -- ANYBODY
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK OF
CLOSING THIS.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CENTER ARE YOU MICHAEL -- THANK
YOU -- SAYS I MENTIONED THE BILL
IS BOTH TECHNOLOGY AND FUEL
NEUTRAL IT'S JUST AIMED AT
BRINGING MORE ATTENTION TO OUR
HEAVY AND HEAVY DUTY AND MEDIUM
DUTY VEHICLES WHICH IF WE LOOK
AT FOR EXAMPLE OUR OUR
INVESTMENTS FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FIND.
THEY HAVE -- BEEN MORE HEAVILY
WEIGHTED TOWARDS OUR PASSENGER
VEHICLES ENDS CLEARLY WE WANT TO
CLEAN UP OUR ENTIRE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM BUT GIVEN
THE THE HARMFUL HEALTH IMPACTS
OF THESE PARTICULAR VEHICLES IF
THEY ARE.
POWERED BY -- MORE POLLUTING
DIESEL FUEL.
I IT SEEMS LIKE WE GET AS THEY
SAY A BIG BANG FOR OUR BUCK IF
WE PUT MORE EMPHASIS TOWARDS
TRYING TO SUPPORT.
MOVING AWAY FROM THAT FUEL IN
THE FOR THAT TECHNOLOGY EVEN
DEPENDING ON HOW ONE CHOOSES TO
DO IT.
IN THIS MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
SECTOR AND THAT'S WHAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS TO ASSIST
IN THAT PROCESS MOVE THE WITHOUT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION SIR ACCOUNTS COULD.
OF SENATOR -- I THINK YOUR BILL
COME COMBINED WITH -- THE OTHER
BILLS WE HEARD TODAY ON MEDIUM
HEAVY VEHICLES I THINK ORGAN
RESULT.
TENNESSEE.
REDUCTION.
IN -- AIR POLLUTANTS.
AND IT'S A MAJOR EFFORT ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR. TO REDUCE POLLUTION COMING
FROM THAT SOURCE SO I THINK ALL
THE AUTHORS ESPECIALLY YOU.
AND WOULD URGE AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
IT'S A IT'S A WONDERFUL EFFORT
WE HEARD TODAY -- MADE
MAGNIFICENT EFFORT TO REDUCE
POLLUTION FROM THE SOURCE THANK
YOU.
IT'S CALL ROCK
THE SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ABOUT HI WELL I BATES
[inaudible]
DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MORALE.
MORRELL NO ROCKS.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE STONE.
STONE NO NUMBER.
CASKEY CASKEY AYE.
I'VE ALSO FAVOR TO CLOSE WILL
LIBERAL BUT AN ACT FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS CENTER THANK YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH AND I WILL RETURN
TO COMMITTEE WANTS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCLUDE OKAY.
HAVE TO GO BACK TO CHAIR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WHERE TO GO?
OKAY WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL.
SIR WINTERS BILL AND THERE IS.
IS CENTER WHERE YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR.
LAST BILL TODAY.
SIR YOU HAVE THE FLOOR THIS IS --
YES BE -- ONE TWENTY SEVEN AND
CENTER YOU HAVE THE FLOOR FOR
YOUR PRESENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S GOOD TO BE
BACK -- SO -- FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME AND MY STAFF -- DILIGENTLY ON
AMENDMENTS SP -- ONE TWO SEVEN
AND WE ACCEPT THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS IN COMMON TO THEM IN
ALICE'S -- WILL WITH THE
AMENDMENT WILL REVERT THE ORDERS
OF THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT
BACK TO THE CURRENT LAW -- AND
INSTEAD WILL REFINE THE
DEFINITION PROCEED TO TO ALSO
INCLUDE PEDESTRIANS AND CYCLISTS.
COMMENT WE ACCEPT THE IMINENT
COMMENT HE WHICH WILL ALLOW
AUXILIARY MERGING AND TOLL LANES
TO BE FUNDED BY THE SHOP PROGRAM.
WE ACCEPT THE MA'AM AND COMMENT
NINE WHICH WILL ALLOW AUTOMOBILE
DELAY TO BE USED AS A
PERFORMANCE MEASURE ON THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
AND WE ACCEPT THE COMMENT THAT
WITH IT WE ACCEPT THE MEMORY
COMMON.
SEVEN WHICH WOULD LEAVE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR BICYCLE LANES ON
SHOP PROJECTS BY THE FALL.
AND INSTEAD REQUIRE CALTRANS TO
INCLUDE THESE FACILITIES.
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON CERTAIN SECTIONS
OF HIGHWAY.
THIS BILL IS -- PASSED OUT THE
AMENDMENTS FOR EVERYBODY WRITTEN.
SO WE GOT COPIES.
THANK YOU CENTER I THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
ON THIS BILL -- IT IS I SEE
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD -- WE
HAVE IN OUR STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA -- NUMEROUS --
HIGHWAY SEGMENTS QUOTE ON QUOTE
THAT ARE ACTUALLY CITY SURFACE
STREETS.
WE HAVE THEM ALL OVER THE CITY
WHETHER IT'S PORTIONS OF SANTA
MONICA BOULEVARD WERE VENICE
AVENUE OR NINETEENTH AVENUE IN
SAN FRANCISCO OR SAN PABLO
AVENUE IN THE SPARE.
MANY PARTS OF HIGHWAY -- ONE
WHERE IT'S A STATE HIGHWAY BUT
IT'S REALLY THE MAIN STREET OF A
CITY.
AND SO PEOPLE ARE WALKING ON THE
STREETS AND CROSSING THE STREET
AND AND AND BIKING ON THOSE
STREETS AND WAITING FOR THE BUS
ON THE STREETS.
UNFORTUNATELY CALTRANS HAS
TYPICALLY TREATED THOSE STREETS
AS IF THEY WERE JUST REGULAR OLD
STATE HIGHWAYS -- WERE NO ONE'S
WALKING OR BIKING.
MAKES A VERY DANGEROUS AND SO --
WE HAVE SEGMENTS OF OUR STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM THAT OUR CITY
STREETS AND HAVE NO SIDEWALKS OF
DOING OF CROSSWALKS BUT DON'T
HAVE AN APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR
PEOPLE TO WAIT. FOR THE BUS OR
TO BIKE -- AND THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE CALTRANS -- TO ACTUALLY
WHEN THEY'RE DOING WORK IN THESE
AREAS -- TO WORK WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY TO INCORPORATE WHAT WE
CALL COMPLETES THREE ELEMENTS --
STREET SAFETY FOR ALL USERS NOT
JUST FOR CARS.
I WANT TO SAY -- THE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD WITH THIS
BILL COLLEAGUES.
TIME IS THAT -- WE HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO GET -- GOOD DATA FROM
CALTRANS BACK CALTRANS HAS
COMPLETELY FAILED TO GIVE US ANY
DATA -- RELATING TO THESE
PARTICULAR THREE FACILITIES THAT
RUN THROUGH CITIES -- SURFACE
STREETS -- I SENT A LETTER TO
CALTRANS -- ABOUT A YEAR AGO
REQUESTING THIS INFORMATION THE
DEPARTMENT HAS -- FAILED.
NOT DESPITE REPEATED FOLLOW UPS --
TO TO PROVIDE INFORMATION AND SO
I'VE DIRECTED MY STAFF JUST TO
THE COMMITTEES INFORMATION -- TO
SUBMIT AN AUDIT REQUESTS TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE.
THEY WANT TO INFORMALLY WILL GET
IT THROUGH A FORMAL AUDIT.
SB -- ONE TWO SEVEN INSURERS ARE
CALTRANS CONSIDER THESE COMPLETE
ST ELEMENTS SO THAT EVERYONE IS
SAFE ON OUR STREETS.
WE KNOW THAT -- CALTRANS THIS
CONFERENCE IS SPENDING.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR --
TO FIX THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
AND I SUPPORT THAT WORK WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
DEPLOYING THOSE RESOURCES
EFFECTIVELY -- IN THESE AREAS
THAT RUN THROUGH CITIES.
AND TOWNS -- SO THE BILL DOES A
FEW THINGS A REQUIRES -- THAT --
WHEN CALTRANS AS HIS PROJECTS --
THAT A CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF ALL
ROAD USERS -- AND SO FORTH -- SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME --
TODAY -- OR PAPA JOH VOLUNTEER
AT AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION --
LYNN THE COMMISSION FROM OTHER
CAL FROM CAL BIKE WHO'S HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS -- AND
INNOVATIVE -- YOU SALAS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CULT OF
CALL TO VOTE NOT SALUTE.
A WITNESSES IN FAVOR PLEASE.
AIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KIND OF A BY YOU SLICE I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF COURSETHE BY
LAST ALLUDE AND WE ARE A SMALL
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION.
THAT'S BEEN WORKING IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY TO CREATE HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES I'M ALSO A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER FOR FRESNO UNIFIED
ALTHOUGH I'M NOT HERE TO
REPRESENT THE SCHOOL BOARD I AM
HERE. TO GIVE VOICE TO MANY OF
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT I
AND YOU REPRESENT IN THIS REGION.
I GREW UP IN RURAL FRESNO COUNTY
I WALK TO SCHOOL MOST OF MY
CHILDHOOD EVERY DAY WAS A RISK
LIKE MANY CHILDREN IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES TODAY.
I DIDN'T HAVE NICELY PAVED
SIDEWALKS ARE BRIGHTLY PAINTED
CROSSWALKS.
THERE WERE A FEW NEAR MISSES BUT
HERE I AM.
THERE ARE MANY OTHERS WHO DID
NOT HAVE THE SAME LOT CAN I WON
IT REMEMBER.
DIEGO ESTRADA WHO WAS NINE YEARS
OLD IN PART THEY'RE CALIFORNIA
WHO WAS STRUCK ON HIS WAY TO
SCHOOL.
AMIN ABANG WAS TWELVE YEARS OLD
SHE WAS CROSSING THE STREET TO
CATCH THE BUS THAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY TAKE HER TO SCHOOL.
WHEN SHE WAS KILLED AND ERICA
MEAN THOUGH WHO IS FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD?
HE WAS JUST A FEW STEPS FROM THE
GATE OF HIS SCHOOL WHEN HE WAS
STRUCK BY A VEHICLE.
WE CN ARGUE ABOUT WHO SHOULD BE
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
DEATHS.
BUT I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PROTECTED -- CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITY SHOULD
NOT RELY ON LOCK THEY SHOULD
RELY ON GOOD INFRASTRUCTURE --
FOR THEIR SAFETY.
THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE THE ODDS
FOR MANY OF THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
THAT I REPRESENT.
ENSURING THAT CALTRANS
RESPONSIBLY WORKS TO CREATE
COMPLETE STREETS ON ALL THE
STREETS UNDER THEIR PURVIEW
HELPS TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN PARTICULAR AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
BISECTED BY THESE HIGHWAYS.
ARE DUE TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL --
AT ONE TWENTY SEVEN BECAUSE IT
REPLACES CHANCE WITH PREVENTION
IT ALLOWS RURAL COMMUNITIES
WHICH OFTEN STRUGGLE TO DRIVE
DOWN GRANT RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THEIR LIMITED INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
HAVE ONE LESS THING TO WORRY
ABOUT IN RELATION T THOSE ROADS.
WE'VE SEEN THIS WORK IN MODESTO
ON THE SOMEBODY AVENUE AND IN
STOCKTON ON HARM HAMMER LANE AND
TURNED AWAY -- THIS BILL IS AN
OBVIOUS SOLUTION TO A PRESSING
NEED I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND I WOULD BE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR ACTION ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR THE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS PAPA JOE.
AT THE VOLUNTEER THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION OUR HOLY THE
SUPPORT.
SB.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN THIS BILL WILL
HELP IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS MAKING IT
EASIER AND SAFER FOR THEM TO BE
ACTIVE. TO THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION THE NEEDHAM BENEFITS
COMPLETE STREETS OF CLEAR
WALKING AND BICYCLING.
AS A MEANS OF TRANSPORTATION OF
DOUBLE BETWEEN 200-022-00012.
BETWEEN 200-020-0012 CONSISTING
NEARLY 20% OF TRIPS IN
CALIFORNIA.
URGING EVEN MORE CALIFORNIA'S TO
WALK OR BIKE.
UNNECESSARY OUTCOME FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENT
[inaudible]
PERSONALLY.
I HAVE BENEFITTED FROM COMPLETE
STREETS.
IF YOU SAW ME SIX YEARS AGO YOU
WOULD RECOGNIZE ME.
THAT'S BECAUSE IN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS WALKING UP TO FIVE MILES
A DAY RAIN OR SHINE MAKING THE
SIDEWALK BY MY TREADMILL AND THE
CITY MY GYM I LOST OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY POUNDS BY
WALKING.
I WAS LUCKY BECAUSE I LIVED IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH SIDEWALKS WHY
FELT SAFE TO WALK.
LATER OUR STARTER BIKE RIDING.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT HAD A
ACCIDENT TWO YEARS AGO ON MAY I
MET MAGNOLIA BOULEVARD AND MY
QUESTION.
WHERE THE SIGNS WERE NOT
PROPERLY WHERE THE STREETS ROUTE
PROPERLY SIGNED AND I WAS I WAS
STRUCK BY A CAR?
AS SOMEONE WITH BENEFITTED FROM
ACCEPTS ACCEPTS ABILITIES TO
SIDEWALKS AT THE SAME TIME
HAVING SURVIVED A BICYCLE
ACCIDENT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ME TO HAVE
THE STREETS WERE THE FATE FOR
PEOPLE TO SHARE THE ROADS WITH
CARS AND TRUCKS.
YOU HAVE SHOWN PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN WALKABLE NEIGHBORHOODS
GENERALLY GET MORE PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY EACH WE CAN HAVE A
LOWER RISK OF DEVELOPING
DIABETES HEART DISEASE.
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE AND SOME
CANCERS WHO LIVE IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE LESS
WALKABLE.
WHEN OUR COMMUNITY HAVE SAFE
ROUTES TO SCHOOLS ROADS -- AND
PROTECTED BY CLAIMS AND ACCESS
TO PARKS AND SIDEWALKS RESIDENTS
ARE ENCOURAGED TO BIKE MORE.
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY GIVEN LESS THAN HALF
THE U. S. CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS
WITH THE REQUIREMENT GUIDELINES
OF LESS THAN 60%.
OF EXERCISE SIXTY MINUTES OF
EXERCISE EACH DAY.
IN ADDITION TO THAT 10%.
OF ADULTS MEET THE REQUIRED
GUIDELINES OF AT LEAST THIRTY
MINUTES.
OF MODERATE TO VISIT VISIT BITS
OF THIS VIGOROUSLY PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY EVERY DAY.
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES AND ABILITY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE SAFELY
AND CONVENIENTLY WITH A LIVE.
WORK GO TO SCHOOL AND PLAY.
WE NEED ROADS THAT CAN
ACCOMMODATE EVERYONE WHETHER YOU
USE A WHEELCHAIR.
RIGHT A BIKE.
POR BRIGHTER TRAIN BUS OR TRAIN.
OR DRIVE A CAR.
THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ARJUN AYE ARE YOU A VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
A THANK YOU -- OTHER WITNESSES
STATE IN FAVOR AND YOUR IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR I JUST WANTED.
TO MAKE A NOTE THAT THIS HAS
BEEN A COLLECTIVE EFFORT AND WE
APPRECIATE THE THE COMMITMENT OF
THE COMMITTEE OF OF THE STAFF OF
ALL OF YOUR STAFF.
MEMBERS THAT HAVE REALLY BEEN UP
FRONT TO TO TAKE IN OUR OUR
CONCERNS AND TAKEN THE CONCERNS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND WE AGREE TO
THESE AMENDMENTS TODAY WE REALLY
WANT -- TO INTO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND FOR SENATOR
WINNERS LEADERSHIP TO REALLY
BRING THIS BACK AND MAKE THIS A
AN EFFORT THAT WE ALL CAN WORK
ON TOGETHER.
CALIFORNIA'S STATE HIGHWAYS AND
TOUCHES UPON EVERY COMMUNITY AND
OUR COMMUNITY AND ART AND ART.
OUR LOCAL -- ADVOCATES AND AT
ITS CITIES EVERYONE NEEDS
ACCOUNTABILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN HAVE THE STREETS THAT WE
NEED THAT ARE SAFE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND WE ARE TONIGHT BUT
WITH THIS IS.
A STEEP ALL COMING UP THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND THE SAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
PLANNING DEPARTMENT ALL IN
SUPPORT WE ARE DRIVERS THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC WATTS
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND ALLIED
LABOR.
COALITION SUPPORTING OF US
SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE WE ARE PLEASED WITH HIM AS
WE SAW TODAY AND WE WILL NOT NO
LONGER BE IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
REVIEWING THE LANGUAGE WHEN IT
COMES OUT.
AND APPRECIATE THE EFFORT OF THE
STAFF AND AND THE CHURCH.
MR JR MEMBERS BRADBURY WAS
UNITED CONTRACTORS WE HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION BUT
RECOGNIZE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
LIKE TO REVIEW THOSE.
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THANK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA'S
ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AT THE END OF THE GOON ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO COALITION FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA PLEASE SIERRA
GIVE A DRUMMER WITH THE COUNTY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IS OUR
BELIEF THAT THIS WILL ENHANCE
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF EACH OF
THE TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT WALKER BACK TO OUR
SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
IS TO MAKE IT AFTERNOON ESTHER
BEAR WITH CALIFORNIA LOCKS AM
HONORED YOU'RE EITHER TODAY I'M
THIS BILL DEFINITELY TOUCHES
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND WANT TO ECHO WHAT A LOT OF
THE TESTIMONY WAS TODAY -- THERE
WERE A FEW VISUAL FACTSHEETS
DROPPED OFF IN MANY OF YOUR
MEMBER OFFICES THAT SHOW THE
IMPACT SO THAT THEIR SCHOOLS
THAT ARE WITHIN A BLOCK -- RIGHT
OFF THE STATE HIGHWAY
PARTICULARLY IN WATERFORD AN
EMPIRE THIS BILL GOES A LONG WAY
TO ADDRESS THE SAFETY IT ALSO
ADDRESSES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND ARCHER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JONATHAN MATS --
WITH THE SAFER TO SCHOOL
NATIONAL PARTNERSHIP RUNNER TO
BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
ALONG WITH CAL BY CAL WALKS THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION IF WE
MAKE IT EASIER FOR JUST A FEW
HUNDRED KIDS. TO WALK OR BIKE TO
SCHOOL THROUGHOUT THE STATE I A
NEW -- AND ALSO -- THE PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE AND
LEADERSHIP -- COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY ALSO
ON ASKED ME TO GIVE THEIR ME TOO
AS THEY COULD NOT BE HERE IN
PERSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON A KATHY DRIVEN
WITH THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
ALSO AS A CLIMATE CHANGE
SOLUTION IN ADDITION I'M A
PUBLIC HEALTH -- PROFESSIONAL SO
I SUPPORT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES AS WELL THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON JONES ONE REPRESENTING --
DAVIS BY CLUB IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
FOR AFTERNOON JAMIE MORGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THE ONLY GOVERNMENT COLLEGE FOR
CLEAN AIR SUPPORT.
MIKE WILSON THIRTY DISTRICTS THE
RISER HUMBLE COUNTY AND
REPRESENTING THE COALITION FOR
RESPONSIBLE TRANSPORTATION
PRIORITIES FOR AMBLE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT YOU'RE A CAL START
SUPPORTS A FANTASTIC MEASURE TO
EXPAND AND DIVERSIFY THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY THANK
YOU.
THANKS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
WE HAVE -- PEOPLE THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO BILL PLEASE CALL.
FOR THE NUMBERS BECAUSE BUT I
HAVE A SEAT.
UP BILL HIGGINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNCILS
OF GOVERNMENTS WITH TRUTH
REPRESENTS THE COUNCIL TO
GOVERNMENTS AND READ.
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
I'LL JUST SAY IT ON THE BIG
PICTURE WAY WE AGREE WITH ALL
THE POSITIVE AND SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY TODAY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PLANNING FOR
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION.
ON URBANIZED STATE HIGHWAYS.
THE REASON FOR OUR OPPOSITION
THIS TODAY IN IT AND WE TAKE A
LOT OF IT IS ADDRESSED IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE TAKEN.
IS SEVERAL ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL
ADDRESS THE STATE HIGHWAYS WHERE
THERE ARE NO CYCLISTS ARE
PEDESTRIANS ALLOWED THINGS LIKE
AUXILIARY LANES IN AUTOMOBILE
DELAY THAT ARE ON THE OTHER
PORTION OF THOSE SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
WE THERE'S ONE OR TWO AREAS THAT
I THINK THAT WILL STILL WORK
WITH -- TO AUTHOR WITH AND WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN WE
JUST WANTED TO PUT INTO
PERSPECTIVE WHILE WE'RE ON THE
SIDE TODAY WE APPRECIATE THE
VERY IMPORTANT VALUES THAT YOU
TESTIFIED ABOUT TODAY.
AND THAT IS THAT WHEN WE CONCUR
WITH THAT.
IT'S JUST WHERE THIS BILL
REACHED BEYOND THAT SCOPE THAT
BRINGS US UP HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY -- WE
DO HAVE AN OF OFFICIAL OPPOSE
POSITION -- BUT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT --
MORE DRESS TODAY -- THANK THE
AUTHOR AND AND YOUR STAFF -- FOR
TREMENDOUS WORK TO I THINK TAKE
CARE OF THE BULK OF OUR MOST
SERIOUS CONCERNS AS MISTER
HIGGINS MENTIONED -- I THINK WE
TO AGREE WITH THE NEED -- FOR
GOOD SAFE COMPLETE STREETS --
BUT I THINK THAT THERE ARE FROM
A TRAIN FROM A TRULY TECHNICAL
TRANSPORTATION PERSPECTIVE --
THERE WERE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT YOU SEE IN
THIS IN THE BILL -- EVEN IF IT'S
COMING FROM -- OUT WITH US THAT
WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ON I THINK THAT
WE ALL SHARE THE SAME GOALS --
AND AND AND WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE -- TO TO
FINE TUNE THE BILL JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE SO IT DOESN'T HAVE
THOSE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES TO
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
THANK YOU -- OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE.
THE RUBIO SIR WHAT COUNTS THE
NUMBER.
SEVERAL.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I
PERSONALLY HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
BENEFITS OF COMPETE STREETS AND
I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY.
AS IT PERTAINS TO AREAS WERE
SCHOOLS IN KIDS SEEN ALL HARM.
I A WALK AROUND SO I APPRECIATE
THE STORIES BECAUSE THEY WERE SO
A COUPLE OF INCIDENTS IN MY
COMMUNITY AS WELL BUT I ALSO
KNOW THE RISK CONCERNS AND FROM
WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING THAT
COULD -- THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN AND I'M GLAD THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THAT.
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THAT YOU ALSO
THANK YOU WITH THAT MOVE THE
BILL THINKING.
M. I'M READING ON THAT
AMENDMENTS AT ONE FOUR FIVE TO
SIX POINT.
EIGHT DOESN'T MENTION.
URBAN I STREET TO JUST MENTIONS
THE STATE PROJECT.
OUR STATE PROJECT THE CROSSES A
LOCAL STREET AND THEN YOU GIVE
SORT OF A KNOCKED OUT YOU HAVE A
HEARING.
IT SO IT'S THE BURDEN IS ON THE
LOCAL AGENCY TO SHOW THAT THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE OPT OUT
FROM.
FROM THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
IS AT MY UNDERSTANDING THE
NATURE OF THE MEN'S.
I THINK THAT I THINK THAT'S
CORRECT YEAH. TO SHOW ALL THE
SHOP FUNDING BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
IT BUT YOU HAVE TO OPT OUT.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THIS IS NOT
LOCAL AGENCIES IT'S THE DISTRICT
THIS IS A DISTRICT RIGHT SKEWS
ME.
ADS SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
OPT OUT AND AGAIN THIS IS THE
SECTION WHERE SENATOR AT WIENER
MENTIONED THAT WE DID NOT GET
THAT THE DATA WE NEEDED FROM
CALTRANS.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THERE'S A BED.
NOT MAYBE SOME CLARITY THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING -- FOR BUT AS IT
IS RIGHT NOW THIS IS.
IT'S A LIMITATION TO THE PLACES
THAT ARE MAIN STREETS -- AN
URBANIZED AREAS AND RURAL AREAS
WHERE STATE HIGHWAYS GOING
THROUGH AND THAT'S THE MAIN
STREET ACROSS NOW WE'VE WE'RE WE
WILL.
ONCE WE GET THAT DATA -- WE CAN
WORK TO REFINE THE DEFINITION
EVEN MORE.
OKAY SERVE THE RIGHT I GET YOUR
SEVEN SUBPARAGRAPH C. INCLUDES
THAT PROVIDED BY THE DAY THE
DATA [inaudible]
THEY WROTE. TWO SIX THE NAME
ROAD AND SENATE DISTRICT MISSION
BOULEVARD AND HAYWARD -- SIXTY
TWO ALL RIGHT RIGHT THROUGH WILL
FIGHT ON MOVE THE BILL. FOURTEEN
WE ARE LOW HERE.
WE WE WE ALLOW THE STREETS IN
SAN JOSE WHERE THERE IS A STATE
HIGHWAY.
GOING RIGHT THROUGH THE MIDDLE
AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO WHAT WE DID IS WE WENT TO
CALTRANS AND SAID WE WANT YOU TO
RELINQUISH THESE ROADS.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DID WE GOT WE
GOT TO TOOK OVER THEIR INNOCENCE
TOOK OVER.
ELIMINATE THE STATE HIGHWAY
COMPLETELY AND JUST TOOK OVER AS
LOCAL ROADS AND THAT WAY.
WE HAD COMPLETE CONTROL OVER HIM.
HOWEVER THERE'S SOME ROADS.
THE WE CAN'T REALLY.
REALISTICALLY DO THAT.
SO THERE HAS TO BE A WAY.
FOR THESE LOCAL SAFETY BY SCHOOL
SAFETY OTHER KIND OF PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY.
COMMUNITY.
EURO ORIENTED PROJECTS CAN BE
DONE S.
THAT'S WE GOT WE GOT NOW WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS WEEKLY WHERE WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
WITH CALTRANS IN THESE LOCAL
ORDERS MISTER CHAIR YOU DID IT
BACK IN THE DAY WHEN.
CALTRAIN HAD TO RELINQUISH THE
ROADS IN GOOD A STATE OF GOOD
REPAIR.
THE LAST TWO BILLS THAT I RAN ON
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM I JUST
TOOK THEM AS THEY WERE BEAT UP
FOR YOU SHOULD.
ASK FOR MONEY GROUND AS WE DO WE
GOT ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S WHAT THE
RECESSION BROUGHT ON MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF FINANCE I'M NOT SURE
IF YOU OF OKAY CENTER RUBIO AN
ANSWER NUMBER.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
YES IT IS OKAY.
ALERT ALL OF HIM AND THEN WE'LL
GO BACK TO CENTER RING.
SO US AND WE ARE THANK YOU --
I'VE REVIEWED THE AMENDMENTS
APPRECIATE THAT I ASSUME THIS IS
STILL A WORK IN PROGRESS THOUGH.
THE RIGHT.
EVERY BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS BUT NOT BUT
IT'LL YOU KNOW WHAT IT AYE AYE.
YEAH SO I HAVE STATE ARE YOU
STILL HAVE CONCERNS WITH RESPECT
TO FOR EXAMPLE ORANGE COUNTY
WHICH IS LARGELY COMMUTER --
AREA AND IN TERMS OF
PRIVATIZATION IN TERMS OF WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND OUR
PRECIOUS RESOURCES I AM
HOPEFULNESS PORTABLE BUT I'M
HOPEFUL THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH.
WITH US TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT --
SOME COMMUNITIES ARE NOT -- DE
PRIORITIZED.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW I PRETTY I
MEAN THAT THE CLICK OF MY LAST --
ANSWER -- BUT YOU KNOW.
AB.
THE INTENT IS NOT TO BE
PRIORITIZE COMMUNITIES AND EVEN
IN THE VERSION OF THE BILL --
BEFORE THEM AND THEN WE PUT
SAFETY.
AS THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY WHICH
I DON'T CARE WHAT COUNTY YOU'RE
AND YOU KNOW ORANGE COUNTY VALUE
SAFETY AS MUCH OF SAN FRANCISCO
OR LOS ANGELES WE ALL VALUE IT --
FOR ALL USERS A WE WANNA -- BUT
YOU KNOW I THINK CALTRANS CAN DO
BOTH IN THEIR DIFFERENT NEEDS
AND DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW THE ACTUAL
FORMAL HIGHWAY IN.
GETTING PEOPLE WERE THERE GOING
OFFICIALLY AND ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT CALTRANS IS.
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES FOR THOSE STREETS
AND INTERACT WITH PEDESTRIANS
AND TRANSIT RIDERS IN CYCLES SO
WE'RE WE'RE NOT LOOKING.
TO TAKE AWAY AND I THINK
PARTICULAR WITH THE AMENDMENTS --
IN EUROPE BUT I'M INTERPRETING
IS YOUR POTENTIAL CONCERNS.
HAVE.
POTENTIALLY BEEN ADDRESSED SO
ONE OH MITIGATED MEDICAID AND I
WERE UP AROUND HAPPY TO TAKE FOR
THE PEOPLE FROM THE ONES YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY.
LOOK AT IT MORE CLOSELY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU I JUST FELT SAID TO
MENTION AND DIE I SHARE YOUR
FRUSTRATION ABOUT -- CALTRANS
AND I'M EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED
FOUND DATING BACK TO YOU -- THAT
MAKES YOUR JOB HARDER IN OUR JOB
HARDER BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION WE NEED AND ARE MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT I FIND THAT
THEY'RE SLOW TO RESPOND IN SOME
DOUBT THAT YOU'RE GETTING THE ON
INTENT I JUST WANTED TO POINT
THAT OUT FOR THE RECORD I THINK.
YOU NEED TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE
THANK YOU YOU WERE ASKING FOR
WHAT WERE YOU TRYING TO GET.
FROM CALTRANS WELL JUST LOCALLY
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN INITIAL FOR US
AN ONGOING ISSUE -- SO I'M
WHETHER PERTAINS TO A NO
GRAFFITI ON THE FREEWAYS AND
IT'S JUST BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE
FOR ME PERSONALLY SO I JUST
WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT THAT I
WAS DISAPPOINTED THAT AND GET
THAT INFORMATION TO YOU.
SERVER CO SKI.
I WAS JUST THINKING THIS IS LAST
YEAR.
OR TWO YEARS CAN WE PASS SP ONE
WE PUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWO BICYCLE PEDESTRIANS.
THIS IS THIS IS -- CONSIDERATION
OF SHOP PROGRAMS.
THE SHOP PROJECTS TO THIS IS
ADDITIONAL MONIES WERE SISTERS
SAY MONEY.
MAY EXPLAIN AT IT'S NOT TRUE
OKAY AS A TRUE YEAH THE IN THE
IS IN THE SHOP PROGRAM THERE
IDENTIFIES CALTRANS IENTIFIES
AREAS.
ON THE STATE HIGHWAY THAT NEED
TO BE BROUGHT TO STATE OF GOOD
REPAIR RIGHT SO THEY'RE LOOKING
AT MEASURES WHERE THE PAVEMENT
NEEDS TO BE -- CHANGED RIGHT SO
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES THERE TO
HAVE A COST EFFECTIVE IN.
A PROJECT WHERE YOU'RE DOING THE
THE SIDEWALKS OR THE BIKE LANES
OF THE CROSSWALKS AT THE SAME
TIME THE PAVEMENTS BEING BROUGHT
TOGETHER -- SO IT'S IT IT'S AN
EFFICIENCY OKAY.
SO THEY'RE JUST AS IN WHEN THEY
GO THROUGH THE REHABILITATION
PROJECT OF JUST.
CLEAN UP ALL HIGH WITH AS MANY
CLEANED UP IN TWENTY YEARS OR
MORE.
WE HAVE A TON OF THOSE RIGHT SO
THEY GO THROUGH THAT AND THEN
THEY LOOK AND SEE.
HOW THEY CAN -- DEAL WITH THE
COMPLETE STREETS.
AND THAT'S A MANDATE SP ONE THAT
WAS PUT IN SP ONE SO THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE TO DO THIS THIS BILL.
KINDA IN FORCES THAT AND MY MY
OPINION THIS IS MORE.
IN FOR SPENT THE DAY ACTUALLY DO
IT.
SO I THINK I THINK IT ACTUALLY
FALLS WITH THE PAST.
IT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE PASS
LEGISLATION THIS.
OF FOR THIS CRAFT EFFORT SO
THAT'S MY OPINION.
ANY OTHER -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY.
JERRY MY CLOTHES NUMBER THIS
TIME THE OTHER MAN I'VE A SERVER
HAS CLOSING WE HAVE MOTIONS BILL.
CENTER RUBIO MADE A MOTION.
OKAY SO WILL CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED ND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CENTER ABOUT I FELT I BATES NO
BATES NOW DOT [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
DOES AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORRELL.
ROTH.
ROUGH I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STONE.
DOWN NO I'M BERG.
NUMBER I WOULD CASKEY CASKEY AYE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL SEVERAL WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE PUT OUT A CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE CAN I OPEN THE RULES WE CAN
ALL VOTE.
IS EVERYBODY READY FOR THAT
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE.
SO YOU YOU IF YOU HAVEN'T CAST A
VOTE.
ON THESE BILLS WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
TO HAVE THE MEMBERS ROSA RAFIA
QUESTION.
MISTER WOULD WHEN YOU CALL THE
ROLL WOULD UTILISATEURS VOTE IN
THE IN THE CURRENT VOTE OKAY THE
THE THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AND INDICATE -- THE CHAIRS SO
RECOMMENDATION COULD GO HEAD.
START WITH ENCOUNTERS WILL BEGIN
WITH.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
456-915-1718 TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY THREE SENATOR BOB.
HI WELL I BATES ALL RIGHT BATES
AYE DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORRELL.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE.
STONE I AMBER.
AMBER I WOULD COUNTY WHAT COUNTY
AYE.
SKIP DOES NINE VOTES.
SO IT.
THIS TOWN.
TOP TO BOTTOM.
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ON APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR.
CHAIR VOTING I BY SURE NOT
LOADING [inaudible]
CENTER BATES [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DODD I MCGUIRE.
ROSS AYE ROTH AYE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
NUMBER I BATES NOW.
REALLY MOTIONS AND EXCELLENCE
EIGHT THREE NOW WE HAVE A TWO
THREE ON THAT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB. FORTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE SENATE BILL ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR WINNER.
I WOULD JUST VOTER ON THE SHOW.
ONE THE SENATE BILL TWO TEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
PREPARATION.
THE MOTION THE MOTION THANK YOU
CENTER ABOUT HI WELL I BATES NO
BATES NO DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORRELL.
ROUGH.
ROUGH I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE NOVEMBER.
NUMBER I WILL COST ME BECAUSE HE
AYE [inaudible]
MORRELL NO [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible] SIXTY THREE
SIXTY SIX VOTES IN FAVOR THREE
POST.
THE SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY SIX
BY SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES HI BATES I DON.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE.
MORRELL.
BROWN NO ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE KASKI.
BECAUSE HE ACT.
MOTION BY THIS IS SB. THREE
THIRTY SIX CENTER DODD CENTER
DOGS BILL.
IT'S A RESTORED SAID ON NO.
I DON'T KNOW [inaudible] EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT VOTES IN FAVOR TO
OPPOSE. EIGHT TO TWO LEAVE THE
ROLE CONTRAPTION MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible] ONE NEED A
MOTION WITH A THERE'S A MOTION
FOR A SB OF THREE FIFTY SIX
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES RIGHT BATES AYE DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE.
STONE I AMBER.
AMBER I WOULD COUNTY BECAUSE HE
AYE. TEN ROSA FAVOR.
THIS IS IN THE BILL. THREE SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SURVEY ABOUT I FELT I BATES ALL
RIGHT BATES I DON.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MORRELL MORRELL AYE ROSS.
ROSS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE STONE AYE AMBER.
AMBER I WILL COST ME.
BECAUSE HE I LEAVE IT OPEN A
SMALL PORTABLE.
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE BILL.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT A BELT THREE
SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I
SENATE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THERE ARE SEVERAL LEVELS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
SEVEN BY SENATOR GLAZER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
COCO BILL.
THIS CENTER ABOUT I FELL AYE
BATES RIGHT BATES I DON.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'M AROUND.
MORRELL AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE STONE AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY TO COUNTY
I LIVE IN [inaudible] ELEVEN
ZERO COCO GET SO ON THE BUS.
SENATE BILL FOUR HUNDRED BY
SENATOR UMBERG THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AD REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SOME MOVED CHAIR AND I SURE
VOTING I CENTER DOT.
DODD AYE.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'M AROUND.
MORRELL AYE ROSS.
ROTH AYE STONE STONE AYE.
MOTION.
ON THE NEXT ON THE NEXT ITEM.
SIR MORE LOOKS BILL YOU'RE GOING.
TO SET THE NEXT.
HE HELD A FOUR OKAY OKAY OKAY
THE ONE IS -- SIXTEEN SIXTEEN
RIGHT FOR THE LOWER.
CASE SO WHAT WILL NOT RIGHT NOW
WILL GO DOWN THE LIST SO.
WE HAVE TWELVE VOTES ON SP --
FOUR HUNDRED THE MOTION CARRIES.
THAT'S THE RUMOR [inaudible]
WELL DESERVED.
I DON'T KNOW.
SELECT COMMITTEE THE SEARCH IS
THIS IS SENATE BILL FOR NINETY
EIGHT BY SENATOR HER TITLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR ABOUT OUR BELL AYE BATES.
BATES I DON.
DON AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
YES GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'M AROUND.
MORRELL NO ROSS.
ROSS I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STONE STONE I AMBER.
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY BECAUSE HE
AYE. NINETY NINE TO FAVOR. ONE
OPPOSED.
SENATE BILL FIVE ELEVEN BY
SENATOR MORE LOCK THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS NO
WITH THE THE THAT'S THE MOTION.
OKAY.
IN THE END -- THIS IS SO.
SB.
FIVE ELEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER ABOUT NO.
WELL NO BATES RIGHT BATES AYE
DODD.
DODD NO GALGIANI.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE NO MORALE.
WELL I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO NO.
SKINNER.
STONE.
STONE I AMBER.
NUMBER I WILL CASKEY WE ASK YOU
KNOW. TWENTY FOUR ROADS IN FAVOR
OF WILL BE THE ROLE OF ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OKAY SIR SIR -- MORE LIKE ONCE A
RECONSIDERATION YEAH IF IT DOES
OKAY -- MAKE SURE OKAY OKAY.
OKAY I'LL TELL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR ARCHULETA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES.
BATES NO DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE ROSS ROTH IRA.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE.
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER AYE STONE.
STONE NO AMBER.
AMBER GUY BECAUSE HE BECAUSE THE
ICE AROUND [inaudible]
WELL NO. 789-223-99390.
THREE NINETY THREE THOSE VOTE
[inaudible]
NINETY THREE NOW.
WHERE?
WHERE IS NOT?
IT'LL CLOSER. NINE THREE NINE
TWO THREE YEAH.
IN.
IF THEY CAN SO THEY CAN SEE
THROUGH ALL TOTAL [inaudible]
NINETY THREE NINETY THREE THIS
IS AN INFILL SEVEN FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER ABOUT BY BELL AYE BATES.
BATES I DON.
DON AYE GALGIANI.
JOHNNY AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'M AROUND.
THIS IS AN APPLE.
SEVEN FORTY TWO ITEM TWENTY ON
THE AGENDA ITEM.
TWENTY MORRELL AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO.
VIA AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
STONE.
STONE I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I WILL CASTING I WOULD
ASK YOU HIGH. TWELVE ZERO TWELVE
TO ZERO I THIS.
IS A CODE OR SOMETHING -- WILL
GO OVER THE CONCERT COUNTER
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE WERE NOT
HERE.
TAKE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
456-915-1718 TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY THREE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING HIGH.
CENTER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
TWELVE ZERO TWELVE TO ZERO ON
THE OKAY WILL RUN THE ROLE WILL
ONE ROLL THROUGH ONE MORE TIME
AND THEN.
WILL JERK [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YES.
THIS IS THOSE A CAME IN LATE
WILL RUN THE ROLE ONE MORE TIME
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO WE CAN RECORD EVERYBODY'S
[inaudible]
THANKS.
SHARKS ARE GOING TO GO TO
VICTORY.
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
END OF NINETY THREE MOTION
PASSES.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'M AROUND.
AROUND NO SKINNER.
CENTER SKINNER SKINNER
[inaudible]
SKINNER I OKAY. NINETY THREE
NINETY THREE MOTION PASSED.
THIS ISN'T A BILL TO TEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER GALGIANI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MCGUIRE I SKINNER.
RIGHT SKINNER I EIGHT EIGHT TWO
THREE MOTION CROSSES.
BETWEEN [inaudible]
NINE OKAY. THREE THREE THREE
THIS IS THE BILL THREE THIRTY
SIX BY SENATOR DON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
CENTER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER SKINNER HI
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER.
NINE TWELVE TO ZERO WORLD ZERO
MOTION CARRIES [inaudible]
SENATE.
TWELVE SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
NINE BY CENTER HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. TWELVE TO ZERO THE
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN
BY SENATOR GLAZER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER SKINNER AYE SKINNER HI.
ZERO TWELVE TO ZERO MOTION THURS.
THE SENATE BILL FOR NINETY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HER TACO MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER RUBIO SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. ONE TEN TO ONE
MOTION KERR'S.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE ELEVEN
BY SENATOR MORLOCK THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS SURE
VOTING NO PRESSURE VOTING AYE.
SENATOR GALGIANI [inaudible]
ROSS [inaudible]
SKINNER.
OKAY. TWENTY FORTY FIVE
FORTIFIED RECONSIDERATION
GRANTED